bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur lcp pour
cette grande soirée électorale
législative 2022 nous sommes ravis de
vous accueillir ici dans ce nouveau
décor et sur ce nouveau plateau pour
plus de quatre heures de direct nous
sommes ensemble jusqu'à minuit pour vous
faire vivre minute par minute les
résultats et tirer les grands
enseignements de ce second tour des
législatives
mon sort myriam bonsoir brigitte bonsoir
à tous toute la chaîne parlementaire est
mobilisée pour vous ce soir nos invités
sont déjà là en plateau politologues
sondeurs éditorialistes ou encore
historien et puis nous sommes également
sur le terrain un peu partout en france
avec nos envoyés spéciaux vous les voyez
ils sont là nous sommes ce soir dans le
calvados en gironde dans le finistère ou
encore à cahors dans le lot sans oublier
bien sûr l ile de france assure
également ce soir les grandes
déclarations des principaux responsables
de politiques en direct à quoi va
ressembler la nouvelle assemblée
nationale emmanuel macron aura-t-il une
majorité absolue pour gouverner
jean luc mélenchon peut-il réussir son
pari et jusqu'où ira la recomposition
politique clément perreault bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le monsieur résultat
de cette soirée et c'est vous qui allez
nous présenter le nouveau visage de
l'assemblée nationale oui vous l'avez
découvert au premier tour voici notre
hémicycle en réalité augmentée qui va
nous accompagner tout au long de cette
soirée grâce aux estimations de notre
partenaire ipsos dès 20 heures nous
serons en mesure de vous montrer bien
une projection de ce que pourrait être
le nouveau visage de l'hémicycle lorsque
vous voyez c'est l'hémicycle avant ces
élections en violet la majorité
présidentielle en rouge la gauche en
bleu la droite comment vont évoluer ses
rapports de force politiques nous le
verrons tout au long de cette soirée
puis un nouveau visuel fait son
apparition ce soir sur notre plateau le
voilà c'est cette carte de france alors
pour l'instant elle est toute blanche
mais elle va s'animer elle va se colorer
circonscription par circonscription à
mesure que les résultats définitifs nous
parviendrons et nous pourrons identifier
les places fortes du centre de la droite
de la gauche et du rassemblement
national merci clément dans un an temps
place au débat à l'analyse avec les
résultats bien sûr et tous nos
spécialistes
il y aura également ce soir des invités
politiques en plateau à partir de 23h
antennes et émission commune avec france
info le tout en partenariat avec ipsos
oprah steria voilà pour le programme de
cette grande soirée électorale
législative 2022 installez-vous c'est
parti
[Musique]
rarement rarement un second tour des
législatives n'aura réserver autant de
suspense majorité absolue ou majorité
relative pour emmanuel macron c'est la
grande question de la soirée les
rapports de force à l'assemblée
nationale pourrait bien changer ce soir
oui meriem jean luc mélenchon va t'il
imposer une cohabitation l'eau
rassemblement national aura-t-il un
groupe dans moins de 30 minutes
maintenant vous connaîtrez les premières
estimations de notre partenaire ipsos
sopra et steria et c'est vous pierre
latry qu'il est représenté ce soir
bonsoir à vous bonsoir anne charlotte
vézina merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
nos constitutionnalistes et politologue
bonsoir jean garrigues bonsoir ravi de
vous retrouver pour ce second tour cet
historien spécialiste de l'histoire
parlementaire et puis richard wehrli le
correspondant du quotidien blick
quotidien suisse correspondant à paris
va nous rejoindre dans quelques petites
minutes magiques alors regardons meriam
un premier chiffre un premier indicateur
de cette soirée celui de l'abstention
elle est de 54 pour cent cinquante
quatre pour cent ce qui veut dire que
plus d'un électeur sur deux ne s'est pas
déplacé pour aller aux urnes ce dimanche
ce qui veut dire aussi qu'elle est un
peu supérieur à l'abstention du premier
tour vous le voyez c'était 50 2 5 %
dimanche dernier on va tout de suite
comparer ce chiffre à celui de 2010 est
il ya cinq ans l'abstention au second
tour elle était vous le voyez de
57,4 % alors avant de commenter ces
chiffres clés je vous propose de partir
tout de suite dans le calvados où la
première ministre elisabeth bornes joue
son poste ce soir hélène mondial vous
êtes sur place
exactement elisabeth bornes qui joue ce
soir son poste de première ministre où
il savait en cas d'échec à ces élections
législatives et bien elle devra quitter
son poste à matignon c'est la règle
fixée par le président de la république
c'est vrai que les abeilles borne est en
ballottage favorable
elle a devancé son adversaire nos égos
char de la nuque de dix points au
premier tour de ces élections on attend
les résultats ce soir évidemment
elisabeth bornes comme dimanche dernier
est allé voter à vire ce matin plus elle
est repartie à paris ce sera donc pas là
ce soir elle écoutera ses résultats
depuis matignon à paris direction
l'essonne à présent vous vous êtes ce
soir est la montagne à quel est l'enjeu
sur place
est bien l'enjeu c'est de savoir si
amélie de montchalin conservera son
poste de ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires puisque la règle est la même
que pour la première ministre une
défaite et c'est la démission du
gouvernement sauf que au 1er tour la
ministre elle a été distancé de sept
points par le candidat de la nuque
jérôme guedj ancien député socialiste
ancien compte président du conseil
général de l'essonne ici on attend les
résultats définitifs autour de 22h 22h30
autre enjeu ce soir pour les
républicains stéphanie des pierres vous
êtes dans le lot à cahors où aurélien
pradié le secrétaire général ndlr joue
sa réélection
élu de façon inattendue en 2010 est ici
dans des terres de gauche aurélien
pradié espère réitérer son exploit une
gauche divisée et l'absence de candidats
macro nist lui ont facilité la tâche au
premier tour le député sortant est en
ballottage favorable face à elsa
bougeard la candidate de la nuque une
victoire pour aurélien pradié ce soir
est un préalable à ses ambitions
nationales enfin au parent à bordeaux
marion becker la gironde territoires de
conquête pour le rassemblement national
ce soir
eh oui mes amis si tous les regards du
rassemblement national sont en gironde à
sont tournés vers la 11e circonscription
où le parti espère bien avoir un député
ou plutôt une députée la candidate et de
vias est arrivé largement en tête au
premier tour avec plus de 43% des voix
le parti a donc confirmé ici sa poussée
en gironde et leur parti le
rassemblement national espère donc au
moins une députée dans cette 11e
circonscription voire deux notamment
avec la circonscription du médoc merci
marion becker revenons à présent sur ce
chiffre de l'abstention avec nos invités
en plateau pierre latry vous êtes notre
partenaire ipsos qui nous fournit ce
chiffre 54% c'est une abstention qui est
un petit peu plus forte qu'au premier
tour ce n'est pas une abstention
historique mais ça reste à un niveau
record oui c'est un niveau très élevé
c'est le deuxième niveau le plus élevé
de la cinquième de l'histoire de la vème
république donc c'est très important
c'est un peu plus élevée effectivement
qu'au premier tour ce n'est pas le
record puisqu'en 2010 est on avait vu
une hausse de 6 points de l'abstention
entre les deux tours il semble là qu'il
y ait eu beaucoup moins de pertes de
votants par rapport à l'élection
précédente mais ça reste un score très
important sans doute qu'il ya eu plus de
suspense eu plus de campagne dans cet
entre deux tours qui a motivé davantage
d'électeurs a quand même aller voter
quand même on pouvait s'attendre à un
petit sursaut de mobilisation
cet entre-deux-tours une semaine quand
même qui a été très prudente un voyage à
kiev un duel avec jean luc mélenchon et
le président de la république 54% sait
plus
on avait l'impression que oui cette
campagne se réveiller au second tour
beaucoup dans la polémique d'ailleurs
dans l'outrance on s'aperçoit finalement
que la mobilisation attendue n'a pas n'a
pas véritablement eu lieu on voit que la
france manière s'installe dans ce dense
et 50% de cette fourchette des 50 % je
rappelle à la semaine dernière au
premier tour qu'au début de la vème
république on était à des votes à 70
même plus il ya eu un choc au début des
années 2000 à 60 et maintenant on est à
50 % on s'installe là dedans mais il ya
une toque tout petits progrès la
participation entre les deux tours qui
s'explique parce que les enjeux sont
quand même beaucoup plus important qu'il
ya cinq ans il ya cinq ans il y avait le
raz-de-marée macro nist d'ailleurs qui
avait été moins fort que ce qui était
attendu et là on a beaucoup plus
d'incertitudes
je pense qu'aucun second tour
d'élections législatives n'a été aussi
incertain que celui d'aujourd'hui c'est
assez passionnant d'ailleurs parce qu'
on va certainement avoir des surprises
mais les français ne se sont pas
déplacés et charlène bezina le président
la république appelait un sursaut
républicain
il n'a pas eu lieu ce soir est ce que
c'est un désaveu pour lui
moi j'ai le sentiment en tout cas que le
premier enseignement on peut tirer de ce
chiffre c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu de
front front républicain front contre
front pour on a vraiment le sentiment
que la période de l'entre-deux tours qui
est censé normalement remobiliser ou en
tout cas permettre d'avoir des votes
d'adhésion au contraire de on va dire de
controverse est donc de 2 de rejet et
bien ne s'est pas cristalliser les
français sont restés sur l'idée de d'un
entre-deux tours exactement équivalent à
la campagne qu'ils ont fait au premier
tour c'est à dire c'est déjà joué la
présidentielle a cristallisé l'état des
forces et donc on va rester dans ce
niveau d'abstention il faut dire aussi
qu'un deuxième tour c'est quelque chose
de particulier puisque vous n'avez plus
que des duels donc généralement la
plupart des français ne retrouve pas
aussi leur candidat local d'affiliation
et donc on est dans une voie là dans une
spirale un peu dangereuse delà de la
désaffiliation c'est à dire qu'en fait
on se rend compte tout simplement que
malgré les sursauts malgré le fait que
on a nos spécialistes vu un véritable
enterré dans ce second tour parce qu'il
aura des conséquences sur les cinq
prochaines années eh bien les français
ne se sentent pas particulièrement
investis ou représentés dans ce type de
mandat du cac alors pourtant que la
législative c'est vraiment l'élection
par laquelle les cinq prochaines années
vont se jouer vous dites un désintérêt
dangereux
est-ce que c'est grave ce soir ce
chiffre et qui est responsable au fond
de la désertion des urnes grave ou oui
parce que parce qu'on est on s'enfonce
c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure on
s'enfonce peu à peu dans une sorte de
démocratie fatiguée qui a été beaucoup à
mon sens pollué par parce qu'on a
entendu de la part des des politiques
eux mêmes par un certain nombre de
d'image de désintérêt venant y compris
du président la république qui je pense
a une responsabilité dans cette cette
désaffection même si c'est un phénomène
de longue haleine c'est un phénomène
général qu'on peut retrouver même dans
d'autres pays mais qui est corrigé quand
même dans les autres pays qui ont des
régimes ou des système politique
différent du nôtre il ya effectivement
aussi cette question du du surpoids de
l'élection présidentielle dans notre
système et du fait que les français on y
revient toujours sont persuadé que le
parlement ne joue pas un rôle majeur que
c'est quand tout est joué finalement la
présidence d'exactement certains pensent
que c'est une chambre d'enregistrement
d'autre que sont des privilégiés qui ne
connaissent pas les réalités du terrain
et s'est beaucoup de fantasmes mais la
réalité c'est que les myriam demandé ce
qui était en cause effectivement est ce
que cette chambre d'enregistrement qu'on
a beaucoup critiqué pendant les cinq
années qui viennent de passer est-ce
qu'on peut reporter une partie en tout
cas de la faute sur emmanuel macron
comme toujours la faute incombe à ceux
qui sont au pouvoir qui donne
l'impression d'une verticalité excessive
de ne pas respecter suffisamment les
contre-pouvoirs et à cet égard on a une
présidence qui est plutôt jupitérienne
donc c'est c'est pareil c'est pas la
même présidence que françois hollande
qui ménage est un peu plus mais assez
d'état son détriment aussi on a vu ce
que telle et les frondes mais c'est pas
le seul responsable
les responsables c'est aussi
l'opposition qui a qui nous a répété
pendant cinq ans que l'international ne
servait à rien alors que c'était pas
tout à fait la réalité et puis
responsable s'est aussi nous les
citoyens et qui parfois ne faisons pas
les ford de comprendre nous intéresser
au rôle majeur au rôle de poumon que
joule l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
aussi dans le système institutionnel
allez on repart dans les
circonscriptions et notamment dans le
val-de-marne où vous vous trouvez marco
pommier quel est l'enjeu sur place chez
vous
oui myriam la semaine dernière dans
cette septième circonscription du val de
marne est la candidate de la nuque a
survolé le premier tour +2 37% des
suffrages rachel cliquez ici c'est un
symbole pour la gauche si elle gagne ce
soir elle deviendra la première femme de
chambre à entrer à l'assemblée nationale
mais dans cette circonscription est les
reports de voix pourrait jouer en faveur
de la majorité présidentielle cette
semaine leur candidate roxana
maracineanu appelé à faire barrage
appelé au front républicain contre sa
concurrente alors cela suffira-t-il sur
le papier en tout cas les jeux
s'annoncent serrées merci marco pommier
puis nous sommes aussi en seine saint
denis où la france un sou mais il rêve
de faire un grand chelem nicolas coadout
êtes sur place
oui sinon je principal celui qui
s'inquiètent c'est jean christophe
lagarde le député sortant et président
de l'udps et il en jeu pour lui ça va
être de conserver son siège pour les
cinq prochaines années il est élu depuis
20 ans dans cette cinquième
circonscription de seine saint denis il
faut dire qu'à chaque scrutin il n'a
aucun mal à justement à passer le
scrutin mais cette année les choses
s'annoncent sensiblement différente
puisqu'il est en ballottage défavorable
derrière raquel garrido la candidate de
l'union de la gauche la nuque qui se
verrait bien faire un gros coup ici en
seine-saint-denis en rappelant toutes
les circonscriptions dans un appartement
qui votent peu mais qui vote à gauche
enfin direction châteaulin le finistère
ce soir où vous trouvez kathia gilder le
président de l'assemblée nationale remet
son mandat en jeu
wii myriam et il y a beaucoup de
suspense ici en centre bretagne richard
ferrand effectivement est arrivé en tête
dimanche dernier mais avec seulement
deux points d'écart sur la candidate de
l'union de la gauche mélanie tome 1
1180 une voix exactement sépare les deux
prétendants entend dire que la clé du
scrutin se trouve parmi les
abstentionnistes que les deux camps ont
tenté de remobiliser et surtout dans le
report des voix de dlr et du et rennes
qui a fait ici plus de 14%
merci kathia gilder et nous accueillons
sur ce plateau richard wehrli bonsoir et
éditorialiste france europe pour le
média en ligne blick on donnait et on
commentait richard ce chiffre de
l'abstention 54% qui est plus élevée
qu'au premier tour on sait que la nuque
n'a pas de réserve de voix et qu'elle
compte évidemment sur les
abstentionnistes est ce que c'est un
mauvais signal peut être envoyé au camp
de jean luc mélenchon en tout cas c'est
pas un bon signal et ça prouve surtout
que les jeunes puisque c'est ce qui
s'était passé au premier tour n'ont
peut-être pas compris qu'il y avait
cette urgence démocratique parce que
c'est quand même de ça qu'on parle alors
pourquoi en france il n'y a pas ce
sentiment de de nécessité d'aller voter
dans un pays qui ont ces fractures et
divisé je dois dire que vu de l'étranger
c'est quand même ce qui pose question à
la fois un système très vertical dont on
voit que les français sont souvent là
c'est en tout cas c'est ce qu'ils disent
mais quand on leur donne l'occasion de
s'exprimer ils boudent les urnes donc la
question que tout le monde un peu que a
en tête c'est mais comment on va y
arriver car latrille on sait ce soir
qu'on a beaucoup voté dans le lot par
exemple est moins en seine-saint-denis
l'abstention ça a forcément des
conséquences politiques électorales pour
les uns pour les autres oui évidemment
ça a des conséquences en fonction comme
vous le dites de la zone géographique on
s'abstient de plus ou surtout de la
catégorie délectera notamment en
fonction des tranches d'âge puisqu'on
sait que c'est devenu le critère
peut-être le plus clivants en tout cas
celui qui fait de plus de distinction de
vote l'âge donc effectivement si les
jeunes ne vont pas voter ça ne
bénéficiera pas à jean luc mélenchon
inversement pour les personnes âgées
pour emmanuel battront donc ça va avoir
un impact évidemment l'abstention
géographique et l'abstention par
différentes catégories majeures gardeur
avant nos premières estimations bref
jean garrigues est ce que le fait que ce
soit une réélection pour emmanuel macron
ça peut jouer sur les les électeurs le
fait de ne pas vouloir se déplacer
incontestablement il ya une usure du
pouvoir ça a joué d'ailleurs pour les
précédents présidents
simplement on aurait pu attendre du
président un investissement plus
important dans cette campagne très
clairement je pense que mon alma kron a
joué plutôt la carte de l'abstention
sachant précisément ce qui venait d'être
dit c'est à dire que le lecteur a le
moins abstentionnistes c'est le sien et
l'abstention mais pour lui et peut-être
moins préjudiciable mais la ccl jouer
comme à lille et ferait une majorité par
les fossés je suis prêt de majorité par
défaut et il faut retenir aussi un
phénomène qui date de la présidentielle
et même d'avant qui est un surcroît de
mobilisation notamment du côté du
rassemblement national qu'on a pu
observer depuis quelques années on se
souvient qu'au premier tour on avait eu
une montée assez spectaculaire du vote
en termes de nombre de voix pour le pour
le rassemblement national donc c'est
aussi une question qui se pose de savoir
si par exemple les électeurs
rassemblement assure est con qu'on
disait il n'intéressait un peu exclu de
cette section législatives vont
éventuellement se mobilisent 19h47 dans
un peu plus de dix minutes maintenant
nos premières estimations de notre
partenaire ipsos sopra steria une petite
question peut-être sur ce qu'on appelle
maintenant la vanité du vote quand on
leur pose la question les électeurs
français estime qui a presque plus de
sens au fait même d'exercer son devoir
son droit de citoyen alors qui comme on
le voit s'engager dans des grandes
causes comment expliquer ce paradoxe on
est aussi dans une période de crise et
j'ai envie de l'envoyer au pluriel c'est
à dire qu'on est dans une crise
économique on est dans une crise
mondiale une guerre dans le monde on est
dans une crise de la représentativité
une crise aussi social avec beaucoup de
colère autour de la représentation d
identité et donc je crois que on ne peut
plus vivre le siècle qu'on a vécu au
début de notre vème république où
finalement ce qu'on a ce qu'on reproche
à cette constitution aujourd'hui c'est
son adaptabilité mais justement elle
peut survivre à ce genre de dekheila mai
il ya en effet à mon avis dans sept
abstentions l'idée de dire que de toute
façon la politique ne change plus la
qualité de la vie alors que c'est
justement ce qui avait fait leur gain de
cette cinquième c'est qu'on était épuisé
par la quatrième république et on s'est
dit bon voilà on va enfin pouvoir
changer les choses et aujourd'hui c'est
tout simplement le politique qui ne
parvient plus à être beauty du
changement du quotidien donc je pense
que cette législature plus que n'importe
quel autre ce quinquennat plus que
n'importe quel autre parce qu'il est
celui des fractures parce qu'il est
celui des crises doit arriver à reparler
à eau conscience nationale et finalement
à aa la réassurance on doit être celui
d'un changement de la confiance la
réforme des institutions de la réforme
des institutions mais je crois pas que
ce soit forcément les institutions qui
sont en cause c'est le politique c'est
la manière de parler redonner confiance
dans la voie politique en changeant la
qualité de la vie donc ça passera par
l'économie ça passera par
l'international ça passera aussi par la
manière dont on aura traité les
oppositions et peut-être d'apprendre
aussi à travailler ensemble et à montrer
aux français la voix du vivre ensemble
c'est vraiment le vivre ensemble qui
souffrent maloya cette crise
institutionnelle que vous évoquez il ya
eu un changement des institutions en
2014 avec le non cumul des mandats
est-ce que ce non cumul et la plus
éloignée finalement le député du citoyen
et ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui et bien on
s'intéresse moins et on va moins voté
aux législatives ce qui est certain
c'est qu'il ya quand même une
contradiction dans les faits avec ce
système français puisque à la fois les
députés ne peuvent plus être maire mais
il reste élu dans une circonscription
c'est que le non cumul des mandats par
exemple je prendrai l'exemple suisse où
l'exemple allemand dans des pays
parlementaire où les députés sont élus à
la proportionnelle le non cumul des
mandats il est quasiment logique vous
êtes élu sur une logique nationale pour
un parti et donc s'est dissocié de votre
fonction local en france vous ne pouvez
plus être maire vous ne pouvez plus
assurée de responsabilités exécutives
locales mais vous restez quand même le
député d'un territoire cette
contradiction les électeurs à ils sont
clairement mal à l'aise avec jeux
j'ajoute une chose c'est que ce qu'on a
vu quand même pendant cette campagne
c'est un duel un duel mélenchon macron
arbitré par un marine le pen où vous
pouvez le prendre dans l'autre sens et
ce duel lag peut-être que quelquefois
les français ont sont là c'est aussi
parce que il y a des gens qui bien sûr
se sont mobilisés par ses chefs mais
s'est fait mal même gel à la
présidentielle à l'adresse infernale
emmanuel masson marine parce qu'il est
normal qu'une législatif devienne une
présidentielle allez y les 19h51 dans
moins de dix minutes nos estimations
ipsos sopra steria en nombre de sièges
le suspense est intense on va accueillir
clément père vaut pour regarder ensemble
la carte la photographie de l'hémicycle
du premier tour alors ce que je vous
propose c'est de regarder maintenant
notre carte de france qui dégage les
grandes tendances du premier tour avec
d'abord en violet je vais faire
apparaître toutes les circonscriptions
où la majorité présidentielle est
arrivée en tête et là vous le voyez
cette carte elle penche à l'ouest avec
de bons résultats dans les régions
bretagne pays de la loire mais aussi
nouvelles aquitaine maintenant regardons
les circonscriptions où la nuque est
arrivé en tête là on voit de bons
résultats dans plusieurs grandes villes
notamment paris marseille et lille ou
encore toulouse également certains
départements de banlieue je pense en
particulier à la seine saint denis au
nord de paris dans ce département ce
soir la nuque et espère réaliser un
grand chelem maintenant regardons les
résultats qui ont porté les candidats
aient l'air et udi en tête là vous le
voyez ça penche plutôt à l'est avec les
régions grand test et auvergne
rhône-alpes enfin regardons les
circonscriptions où le rassemblement
national est arrivé en tête vous le
voyez de bons résultats dans le nord
dans l'est et aussi dans le sud dans ce
que les météorologues m appeler le
pourtour méditerranéen voilà en somme
pour cette météo parlementaire mais
attention c'était les résultats du
premier tour ce n'est donc pas la carte
définitive celle là nous la connaîtrons
ce soir et elle pourrait réserver
quelques surprises effectivement clément
perreault et nous la connaîtrons dans
huit minutes maintenant les estimations
de notre partenaire ipsos au prince
derrière nous donnera les estimations en
nombre de sièges est ce que pourrait
être la nouvelle assemblée nationale
demain jean garrigues parlons un peu des
enjeux pas reparti pour le président de
la république c'est évidemment d'avoir
une majorité absolue c'est vraiment
nécessaire d'avoir une majorité absolue
pour gouverner je vous ai trônerait
peut-être en vision que non en réalité
c'est une tradition c'est un usage c'est
ce que souhaitait le général de gaulle
même si au départ entre 58 et 62 est pas
une véritable majorité absolue derrière
lui c'est vrai qu'on s'est habitué à
cette idée hormis l'épisode de 1988 où
michel rocard avait une majorité
relative et s'appuyait sur des majorités
d'idées sur les textes donc ce n'est pas
une obligation on peut essayer de
gouverner je pense même que ce que c'est
souhaitable pour la respiration la
démocratique et pour que les citoyens
aient l'impression justement que
l'assemblée n'est pas une chambre
d'enregistrement faire un petit peu de
pédagogie même si nos téléspectateurs
connaissent ce chip 289 matches et nous
pourquoi c'est le chiffre magique ce
soir c'est la majorité absolue sur 577
circonscriptions
c'est le chiffre à atteindre
puisant alors la moitié plus un on peut
on pouvait on pourrait imaginer qu
ensemble la coalition de renaissance de
dorison et de mode et du modem pourrait
atteindre ce chiffre mais je le répète
on peut essayer de gouverner autrement
et comme nous sommes mais ça a été bien
dit on est dans une attente un peu
presque schizophrénique des français
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont ils attendent
ils ont besoin d'avoir un cap d'avoir eu
une gouvernance une efficacité qu'il qui
n'ont pas rencontré depuis des décennies
entourés considère que le politique
n'est pas efficace mais en même temps
ils ont besoin aussi qui est des
contre-pouvoirs qui s'exprime et s'il
advenait que mad men a qu'on n'ait pas
une majorité absolue on pourrait
imaginer que précisément que c'est
contrepoids s'exprime par le biais de la
délibération car il faut toujours
rappeler que le lieu de la délibération
le lieu du 10 ans us réguler là où on
parle pour pour faire la loi pour faire
pour produire de la politique c'est
l'assemblée c'est l'assemblée nationale
et c'est vrai que cette fonction là elle
a un peu disparu au fil de la vème
république l'a retrouvé ce serait une
belle chose pour re légitimer le
politique sauf que sauf que pour pouvoir
parler discuter il faut avoir des
opposants il falloir des camps qu'ils
puissent se parler et pour l'instant ce
que nous montre les politiques de touba
c'est qu'il n'arrive pas été la
radicalité aussi qu'ils s'expriment
altrad les musées alors l'enjeu
justement parlé de la radicalité pour la
nuque c'est la grande nouveauté de cette
législative la coalition autour de jean
luc mélenchon toutes les forces de
gauche sont parvenus à s'allier dans ce
scrutin il vise aussi la majorité
absolue au vu du premier tour difficile
à atteindre l'idée c'est d'avoir le
maximum de députés c'est ça ce soir pour
eux représenter une force d'opposition
au sein de notre assemblée nationale
s'est déjà crucial en effet donc je
pense que ça fait partie aussi du
vocabulaire de mobilisation des troupes
de continuer à croire en la majorité
absolue de bien disciplinée sa majorité
même si on l'a dit c'est vrai par
rapport à nos provisions premier tour on
est encore loin de pouvoir avoir
vraiment une cohabitation qui est assuré
mais c'est vrai que c'est important de
dire que la majorité absolue n'est pas
une nécessité elle est simplement l'idée
d'une gouvernance plus simple et plus
évidente elle a été souhaitée au début
de la vème république pour se dire que
finalement lorsqu'on élire est un
président qui choisirait son premier
ministre et bien on lui donnerait la
majorité à l'assemblée nationale pour
que les cinq ans soit les cinq ans de
l'application au g présidentielle donc
aujourd'hui si toutefois la majorité
était relative et bien les cinq
prochaines années le contrat de
législature ne serait plus celui de
l'application du programme présidentiel
mais de la négociation de ce programme
présidentiel point par point avec des
majorités alors son michel rocard du
coup on disait qu'il y avait des
majorités stéréo sont plaints d'albi
qu'est ce qu'on ne savait pas donc
combien on aurait en fonction du texte
est sacrée et des nouveaux enjeux qu'on
a dans d'autres pays ça s'appelle les
femmes parlent iman c'est-à-dire lé
parlement suspendu ça existe dans
beaucoup de démocraties comparé
notamment en grande bretagne en italie
c'est plus difficile mais c'est un enjeu
aussi de la démocratie donc la majorité
absolue c'est une solution qui existe
sous la vème république pour plus de
fluidité dans la gouvernance mais en
effet les affrontements doivent nous
montrer aussi que les oppositions
peuvent se parler c'est tout l'enjeu du
résultat ce soir alors nous sommes
justement à 3 minutes maintenant de ses
résultats de ces estimations ipsos sopra
et steria pour ce second tour des
élections législatives le suspense est à
son comble ici en tout cas en plateau
richard vers lille je pour le
rassemblement national c'est d'avoir un
groupe c'est pas arrivé depuis 35 ans
c'est un double enjeu parce qu'en fait
il y à il y a un match dans le match si
l'on peut dire c'est quand même cette
rivalité est presque éternel entre
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon et
vous vous souvenez que jean luc
mélenchon avait même été à une époque
candidat contre marine le pen dans sa
propre circonscription
si je ne me trompe pas c'est
donc il est évident que si le
rassemblement national arrive un score
qui se rapprochent qui dépasse qui n'est
pas très loin de celui de la france
insoumise qui est le coeur de jean luc
mélenchon le coeur de son de sa
formation de la nuque baisse et bien ce
serait là un élément très important donc
il faut regarder aussi ces rivalités
c'est pour ça parce que c'est la place
de premier opposant finalement qui se
joue peut-être ou en tout cas il ya
beaucoup de symbolique moi je dis féret
un petit peu quand même dans le système
français la majorité absolue elle est
quand même elle a quand même un avantage
n'oublions pas que on est maintenant sur
un quinquennat on n'est plus un
septennat comme c'était le cas de
françois mitterrand à l'époque de michel
rocard est la logique tout va très vite
et la majorité absolue ça permet quand
même de gouverner mieux dans un pays
dont on sait qu'il a des tendances un
peu fatale à se fracturer moins de deux
minutes à présent avant les estimations
ipsos sopra steria jean garrigues les
enjeux pour les républicains on a vu que
voilà il voulait jouer l'ancrage local
ça plus ou moins bien fonctionné au
premier tour il perdait selon les
estimations la la moitié de leurs sièges
c'est déjà ça enjeu majeur décisif pour
pour les républicains je dirais même
pour le pour leur survie car s'ils
arrivent à
protéger un groupe relativement
important plus d'une cinquantaine de
députés et s'il advenait qu'on soit dans
une situation justement de majorité
relative et là je vous rejoins
l'efficacité la gouvernance c'est la
majorité absolue mais par rapport à ce
que les français attendent dans la
démocratie jeu j'ai l'impression les
sondages le mot qu'ils attendent une
majorité relative est donc au cas où
emmanuel macron se retrouveraient qu'une
majorité relative verts qui pourrait-il
se tourner pour gouverner forcément vers
les républicains parce qu'ils ne
trouveraient pas d'alliance ou d'appui
du côté de la nuque et il n'en trouverai
pas non plus du côté du rassemblement
national
donc il y aurait là un rôle central à
jouer pour les républicains et ça va
être un des enjeux cruciaux de ce qui
nous attend 30 et 20 heures dans moins
de 30 secondes maintenant vous
connaîtrez les premières estimations de
notre partenaire ipsos sopra et steria
alors emmanuel macron aura-t-il une
majorité absolue ou relative pour
gouverner c'est en tout cas l'enjeu
principal de cette soirée l'air et
combien de députés jean luc mélenchon
aura à l'assemblée nationale quelle
place pour la droite quelle place pour
le rassemblement national dont les
mythiques quels seront les nouveaux
équilibres à l'assemblée
et voilà le chiffre tombe dans huit
secondes maintenant il est 20h vous
découvrez le visage de la nouvelle
assemblée nationale les estimations
nombre de sièges et c'est ensemble
qu'ils arrivent en tête avec 2 124
sièges on est très très loin de la
majorité absolue de 289 sièges suit la
nuque 149 sièges le rassemblement
national troisième force d'opposition 89
sièges et l'air udi divers droite 78
sièges et les divers gauche 21 sièges
sur garrigues m c'est un tremblement de
terre ce soit assez qu'un tremblement de
terre on disait tout à l'heure qu'on
aurait sans doute décider surprise
surprise oui et non parce que n'oublions
pas que la présidentielle nous avait
décidé un paysage tripartite de la vie
politique et c'est un petit peu ce qu'on
va retrouver là mais d'abord premières
constatations
jean luc mélenchon a perdu son pari il
ne sera pas premier ministre et on peut
dire que le la mobilisation attendue
pour la nuque ne s'est pas réalisé la
nuque et en dessous du score qu'elle
pouvait réaliser mais
évidemment le grand enseignement c'est
cet échec deux des candidats d'ensemble
de 124 sièges on est très très loin
c'est tout petit majorité relative c'est
la plus petite majorité relative qu'on
ait pu trouver sous la vème république
c'est quelque chose qui est
véritablement historique on est d'un
très très loin d'aider des sondages qui
pouvait se mettre en place mais qui sont
très difficiles et moi je ne cadrais
palais les sondeurs le celui qui est à
côté de moi parce que parce que c'est
impossible de définir ce que pourra être
une assemblée nationale on est vraiment
très très loin de ce qui était attendu
avec 224 ciel on est à 65 sièges de la
majorité absolue je vous propose tout de
suite de regarder nos estimations ipsos
sopra steria avec les rapports de force
en sièges au sein de chaque alliance
pour l'alliance ensemble 154 sièges pour
le modem de françois bayrou 44 sièges
pour horizon d'edouard philippe 26
sièges on va voir maintenant le détail
pour la nuque la coalition autour de
jean luc mélenchon la france insoumise
86 sièges le ps 22 député europe
ecologie les verts 28 sièges enfin le
parti communiste 13 sièges pierre latry
on voit que ensemble à 154 sièges ou
plutôt la république en marche tout seul
on se souvient qu'en 2017 c'était 314
sièges seul c'est véritablement un coup
de tonnerre ce soir ah oui c'est un
séisme et c'est vraiment une défaite
complète même s'ils finissent en tête
c'est quand même une défaite complète
pour la majorité présidentielle on avait
déjà dit au premier tour que c'était eux
qui avaient réalisé sans doute le score
le plus décevant avec seulement 25% des
voix au premier tour là c'est
véritablement un tremblement de terre
parce que l'estimation peut encore
évoluer au fur et à mesure de la soirée
expliqué nisar est peu probable que la
république en marche ne peut plus enfin
ensemble n'aura pas à l'après vol et
dans quelles proportions on peut avoir
une évolution sur nombre de sièges mais
ça ne sera pas suffisant pour plus ou
moins 10 sièges c'est ça on perd et on
peut voir une évolution sur mon dossier
mais on ne pourra pas rattraper le la
majorité absolue ce soir pour cent à
charlène médina c'est un vote sanction
pour le chef de l'état alors oui il faut
le redire quand même le caractère inédit
sous la vème république c'est à dire
qu'on n'a jamais eu un résultat aussi
bas pour un président qui vient d'être
élu notamment depuis une règle
importante qui est celle de la de
l'inversion du calendrier c'est à dire
de la suite des législatives de la
présidentielle dont depuis 2002 on avait
des majorités raz-de-marée qui
consolidait complètement un président en
place alors que là finalement c'est
comme si l'élection du président de la
république n'avait pas été du tout suivi
donc en quelques semaines seulement on a
tout cette difficulté du second mandat
qui se matérialise comme jamais parce
que ici être à une majorité de 220 alors
qu'il s'agit d'une majorité déjà deux
coalitions donc c'est à dire que le
parti majoritaire lui même est tout
juste
majoritaire dans son alliance eh bien ça
signifie qu' aucun des textes aucun même
des votes de confiance au sein de cette
législature parce que cinq ans c'est
très long pour gouverner et bien aucun
de ces votes là ne pourra être une
évidence ne pourra être assurée à cette
majorité ça c'est vraiment important de
le dire c'est à dire que quand on a une
victoire à 220 sièges ça signifie qu'on
est encore à près d'une cinquantaine de
gobineau dit c'est que la france est
ingouvernable ce soit la france n'est
pas gouvernable par la majorité qui est
celle qui soutient le président de la
république donc on a complètement créer
un schisme entre la majorité
présidentielle la majorité
gouvernementale et la majorité on est on
est dans une situation totalement
inédite d'initiation been également un
seul tir totalement inédite et ça va
être du cas par cas leur premier
résultat de la soirée s'est lui-même
qu'il communique sur les réseaux sociaux
gérald darmanin est réélu réélu dans sa
circonscription du nord à tourcoing le
ministre de l'intérieur réélu ce soir
les chars wehrli
qui aurait pu imaginer telle situation
que doit penser ce soir emmanuel macron
réélu à c'est finalement largement
au premier et au deuxième tour avec des
scores tout à fait honorable incapable
de gouverner ce soir ce qui pouvait
permettre de d'anticiper une situation
comme ça c'est quand même la dynamique
d'entre les deux tours même avant le
premier tour et entre les deux tours il
était évident que la dynamique était en
faveur de la nuit passée de jean-luc
mélenchon et du rassemblement national
mais là quand on regarde le nombre de
sièges c'est pas non plus le
raz-de-marée pas du tout non sans la
muette on est dans 49 quand même je
dirais prenez les quarts jean luc
mélenchon part d'une d'un nombre de
députés je suis une vingtaine donc c'est
difficile par le dynamique la dynamique
est clairement du côté de ces forces
politiques elle n'était pas du côté du
camp ma trogne impossible pour une
raison qui a été dit c'est qu'ils n'ont
pas fait campagne la campagne a été
quand même très très faible en intensité
du côté du camp des baleines macron ce
registre dire une chose c'est prendre un
point de vue européen l'aïe un vrai
motif d'inquiétude pour les partenaires
européens de la france car si vous
reprenez ces chiffres qui encore une
fois vont être affinés vous avez d'un
côté la nuit ps qui s'est quand même
positionnés très eurosceptique puisqu'il
y avait la remise en cause des traités
européens etc brandie par jean luc
mélenchon vous avez le rassemblement
national qui europhobe vous avez des et
les deux ensemble font un très grand
nombre de députés dollars il y a matière
à s'inquiéter ça veut dire qu'elles vont
parier sur une alliance
des oppositions dans l'hémicyle non
contre éventuellement la majorité
fléchit pas jusque là mais je pense que
sur certaines questions et notamment sur
l'europe il y a pour les pro européens
matière à saint-charles bezina je crois
qu'on parle des républicains oui parce
que le score est quand même assez assez
élevé 1 78 on peut imaginer que les
républicains dont au fond le champion
n'était pas qualifié au premier tour
sont restés chez eux au deuxième tour
comment expliquer le si faible score de
la coalition ensemble est ce que c'est
la droite qui n'a pas voté macron alors
moi je crois qu'on peut dire que
auparavant quand on a eu des coalitions
ou des eaux des majorités courtes comme
ça on avait toujours des variables on va
dire de gouvernance qui était notamment
les partis centristes ou les parties aux
radicaux pendant un moment aujourd'hui
lr avait ce ce jeu du pivot et oui en
effet dans l'entre-deux-tours lr pouvait
les et l'électorat et l'air pouvait
aller se positionner du côté de la deûle
du front finalement anti gauche anti
nucléaire est aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit
c'est que l air à jouer l'autonomie donc
finalement on aura pas peut-être chez l
air cette force d'ajustement même si ce
qu'il faut dire aussi qu'en même temps
le résultat de ce soir ce qui est
important c'est de voir de quel droit tu
par le ton et la droite républicaine
n'est finalement pas si forte que ce que
l'on croyait puisque la droite
aujourd'hui semble bien plus représentée
par le rassemblement national et ce qui
est original de noter c'est que la
dynamique de l'entre-deux tours elle a
bien plus profité au rassemblement
national va encore parler boutique alors
à nouveau résultat avant cela qui nous
parvient à l'instance est annie genevard
pour les républicains député du doubs
numéro deux des républicains qui est
réélu dans son fief pour un nouveau
mandat jean garrigues le front
républicain n'a effectivement pas
fonctionné a priori ce soir comme
semblent le dire at charlène bezina
n'ont manifestement pas un nom ce qu'est
ce qui est ce que ce qui est notable
fallait beaucoup de choses qui sont
notables mais c'est que vous avez quand
même essayer ça a été dit du côté de la
droite une poussée du rassemblement
national et du côté de la gauche une
poussée de l efi c'est à dire que les
extrêmes sont en pointe ce qui ne fait
que retrouver
finalement ce qui s'était passé lors de
la présidentielle où la france était
était coupée en trois et si vous
additionnez les voix de l'efi et de
d'url nous aviez vous aboutissez à
quelque chose comme 170 députés
c'est-à-dire une force jeudi
protestataires certains l'appellent
populiste mais qui est très important
alors c'est une force qui n'est pas
homogène puisque ils ne voteront pas là
mais la même chose mais ça veut dire qu
on a là une conception du débat public
qui est très hostile à la démocratie
représentative avec ma démocratie
parlementaire et qui va jouer un rôle
majeur dans cette nouvelle assemblée par
leur assemblée nationale parlons-en un
peu parce que 89 sièges selon nos
estimations avec un mode de scrutin qui
n'a jamais jamais été favorable à ce
parti il était parti à ces modestes dans
leurs ambitions ces cellules sont sales
et voudrait être le plus spectaculaire
ce soir
les derniers groupes que nous avons eues
qui était un groupe rassemblant fin
front national à l'époque était un
groupe qui avait été de 35 de mémoire et
qui était obtenue à la suite justement
notre confort sionnel intégral en 86
donc une proportionnelle intégrale c'est
à dire pour tous les sièges ce qui
favorise évidemment l'hyper
représentativité même de petits partis
ce pourquoi il avait réussi à constituer
un groupe depuis lors plus aucun groupe
n'avait pu être constitué donc là on
parle même pas d'un groupe on parle d'un
groupe qui sera quasiment à hauteur d'
être le même groupe d'opposition que la
france insoumise donc ce qui signifie
complètement que on aura une droite
nationale qui va être minoritaire dans
la représentation de la droite à
l'assemblée donc ce qu'il faut bien dire
c'est que la droite nationale je veux
dire la droite républicaine excuses en
effet la droite front national
voilà tout à fait excuser moi à force de
parler de droite ont les confondrait
mais la droite républicaine et donc
minoritaire et c'est la droite nationale
qui qui l'emportent en effet ce qui veut
dire finalement que on a affaire à des
groupes d'opposition qui vont être très
fort dans l'assemblée nationale et qui
vont pouvoir jouer le rôle en fait de
deux voilà deux peut-être de voir les
effets du quinquennat la seule solution
finalement c'est de s'allier pour
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui et pourquoi
pas avec les républicains dans une
coalition défendue par certains à droite
dont le premier nicolas sarkozy je vois
difficilement d'autres d'autres
solutions d'autres d'autres hypothèses
parce que son vient me dire c'est que
vous avez avoir 160 députés avec
lesquels il ne sera pas question de
pouvoir faire alliance alors peut-être
pourra-t-il watts d'avoir des majorités
d'idées majorité la géométrie darien
variable en allant un peu cherché du
côté par exemple du groupe socialiste
vous voir d écologie sur certaines
questions de transition écologique mais
fondamentalement l'allier qui apparaît
comme ça comme immédiat c'est plutôt les
femmes et en même temps mc rognan ben
écoute de droite et de gauche et les
soirs c'est celui d'un côté on est
forcément dans une droitisation de 2,2
de la gouvernance macro parle pas de ma
chronique mais on est dans dans une
droitisation et cette droitisation on va
vraisemblablement l'a trouvé très très
vite dans la composition du nouveau
gouvernement lien la très est ce que les
français voulaient une coalition s qui
se sont prononcés là dessus il était
plus qu à la nation effectivement les
français étaient 60 % à préférer que
emmanuel macron est une majorité
relative jean garrigues l'a dit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire qu'en fait il
souhaiterait qu emmanuel macron
consultent davantage des autres forces
politiques
quand il applique sa politique et que
l'assemblée nationale ne soit plus
seulement une chambre d'enregistrement
ce qui sort de ce sondage quand on leur
demandait plutôt à droite plutôt à
gauche la coalition gouverner de quel
côté un peu plus à gauche que lors du
quinquennat précédent mais c'est
seulement de l'ordre de 38% donc on
n'est pas non plus sur une volonté
vraiment d'une barre à gauche de la part
du français ça dépend des électorats en
réalité l'électorat et l'air évidemment
c'est que peut-être les les philippines
le parti horizon jouera les arbitres
seraient en position pivot aujourd'hui
il faut le redire c'est l'information de
la soirée ce sont les républicains sont
les 78 sièges des républicains mc on ne
peut pas gouverner en effet il faut dire
aussi que la surprise à laquelle on
s'attendait c'était qu'en fait on avait
eu la présidentielle avec une vraie
droitisation du discours du débat et
puis on s'était dit finalement les
législatives vont se jouer à gauche or
l'enseignement de ce soir c'est que la
gouvernance de la france sur les cinq
prochaines années ne sera pas à gauche
certes l'opposition pourra être incarnée
par la gauche et c'est important à
l'imposition à des moyens à l'assemblée
nationale mais la majorité c'est à dire
en fait celle qui va gouverner au
quotidien elle sera à droite puisque
comme vous le dites la majorité simple
c'est une majorité des autres voilà de
coalition centriste qui ne pourra se
faire qu'à partir du moment où le groupe
ait l'air joue l'alliance alors
justement ce rôle s'inverse puisque
valéry giscard d'estaing avait joué un
petit peu ce rôle une alliance dans
plusieurs élections notamment je pense à
des élections légistatives de 78 où il
avait dit je ne sais pas si je fait
complètement partie ici s'il est à l'air
finalement foulé fine bouche et bien
tout simplement la majorité ne pourra
pas faire passer ses textes à moins
d'avoir des majorités au cas par cas
peut-être même en allant chercher un
petit peu à gauche mais mais sans le
soutien de l air il n'y aura pas de
majorité présidentielle c'est important
de nouveaux résultats qui nous parvient
ce soir celui de boris vallot qui est
député socialiste qui a été donc réélu
les normands nouveau mandat dans les
landes avec
59,9 % jean garrigues si effectivement
il faut une alliance avec la droite
voire une coalition pour emmanuel macron
afin de pouvoir gouverner ou en tout cas
à appliquer une partie de son programme
qui sera évidemment renégocier ça veut
dire que dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
nationale on va retrouver le clivage
gauche droite oui oui on va retrouvé ce
clivage mais avec une c'est ce qui est
très paradoxal dans cette dans cette
élection qui s'est joué effectivement à
gauche qui était dominé par un le
programme et la personnalité de jean-luc
mélenchon et qui va aboutir à une
droitisation du pouvoir si vous prenez
l'exemple de
la loi sur les retraites à 65 ans on
considère que ça a été le répulsif
majeur qui a provoqué cet échec de
d'ensemble tout cas c'est une des
raisons majeures qui est que qu'on
voyait apparaître dans tous les sondages
or cette idée de la retraite à 65 ans
elle devient beaucoup plus probable si
vous vous alliez avec les républicains
parce qu'elle entre dans le logiciel d
des républicains donc voyez on a quelque
chose de là-bas la réforme des retraites
n'est pas enterrée c'est ce que vous
nous dites ce soir écoutez c'est au
contraire là encore de manière
paradoxale alors qu'elle apparaît
rejetée par une majorité de français
elle apparaît comme une potentialité de
deux législations comme il faut qu'il a
été politique extrêmement intéressant
c'est qu'à l'intérieur même de la
coalition ensemble ya aussi une partie
plus à gauche c'est ce qu'on appelle les
maquereaux nice venant du parti
socialiste on peut dire ce soir que les
arbitrages se feront à droite sur les
retraites par exemple on va devoir
travailler plus longtemps il y aura
forcément la question de l'âge et du
report de l'âge légal c'est la droite
qui décidera au fond une fine et les
réformes oui je pense qu'on peut dire
que l'équilibré est en train de se
droitiser à partir du moment où cette
majorité est trop courte pour que de
toute façon il y un modèle de
gouvernance qui se fasse sur un modèle
ma chronique du en même temps puisque
finalement la macro ni ne représente
plus la majorité à elle seule je crois
qu'il faut dire aussi que c'est l'échec
finalement de l'ouverture à gauche de
l'entre-deux tours où on avait emmanuel
macron qui parfois emprunté des slogans
à l'extrême gauche etc puis où tous ses
appels du pied avec les colonials
isabelle borne et bien finalement ne
suffisent pas à convaincre les français
puisque on retrouve un petit peu là la
précampagne que nous avions eue avec
l'émergence d'eric zemmour on se rend
compte que finalement les français ont
plutôt envie que les arbitrages se fasse
à droite ça veut dire qu'il n'a pas eu
la bonne lecture entre les ports de la
présidentielle emmanuel marc convention
attention tout de même parce qu emmanuel
macron d'abord il a quand même montré
qu'il sait il sait être à ses fins
stratèges même si là il il est face à
une défaite il a encore des outils pour
éventuellement tenter autre chose qu'une
alliance à droite
le premier rudi c'est la composition du
prochain gouvernement on va voir comment
il s'y prend on va voir s'il maintient
elisabeth bornes wi d'abord on va voir
si elle est réélue et un autre élément
que vous versez la farine et violent
d'éléments perd ce soir est diablement
donc tout le monde va suivre à partir de
de ces résultats c'est qu'ils aient
battu et qui l'emportent parce que si
parmi les battus il y a beaucoup de
proches des manuels macron des gens qui
sont très associé à lui alors la défaite
personnelle viendra s'ajouter à la
défaite politique et il sera de fait
très affaibli si en revanche les barons
de la république en marche qu'on connaît
christophe carte castanet richard
ferrand sont réélus déjà ça lui donne
plus de tranquillité le problème des
malades macron c'est de ne pas se
retrouver trop isolé parce que plus il
sera isolé plus il aura du monde eu du
mal à faire une politique d'ouverture et
quand mais je redis l'europe imaginez le
prochain coup de fil qui aura lieu ce
soir des malins de macron sans doute au
chancelier allemand choles il y à 17 18
% on va voir des députés français qui
sont aujourd'hui d'extrême droite opposé
à l'union européenne
et bien croyez moi ça de coin alors un
nouveau résultat à vous communiquer ce
soir vous en parliez à l'instant richard
vernis christophe castaner est battu
dans les alpes de haute provence on va
vous donner ces chiens le groupe la
république en marche à l'assemblée
nationale 48,13 symbolisant dévoile sa
volée ce soir c'est c'est vraiment la
tectonique des plaques oui on a le
sentiment voilà on va voir les résultats
au fur et à mesure d'asseoir et que les
proches des manuels macron sont battus
que ceux qui viennent de la gauche vont
avoir beaucoup de questions à se poser
que la recomposition commence qu'elle
est loin d'être terminée joker et
l'échec de christophe castaner c'est
l'échec de dames acronis de gauche honda
qui vient qui vient de la gauche il
faudra voir ce qu'il en est de richard
ferrand notamment clément bodmer et
clément bonne merci beaucoup de
ministres effectivement c'est
vrai on a tendance à considérer la macro
ni ensemble et surtout le le groupe
renaissance comme homogène mais non il
ya déjà des courants qui les
sous-tendent le centre de gravité il
faut le rappeler il ya cinq ans ici à
l'assemblée nationale du groupe
majoritaire des marcheurs étaient à
gauche était plutôt à zama complètement
chance ça va complètement changer les
vies de laura d'emmanuel garnements est
en train de complètement
déjà changé il avait évolué les
victoires des mains autre résultat que
je vous communique à présent ils
concernent le ministre damien abad qui
vous le voyez est largement réélu avec
57,10 % des voix dans sa circonscription
de l'ain ça confirme aussi gens
regardaient alain temps la droite
royaume exactement ce qu'on disait
damien abad en dépit des affaires qu'ils
ont sorti qui ont quand même beaucoup
animé la campagne il est comme
magistralement réussi c'est on voit bien
là y'a qu'à il ya quelque chose qui se
joue au sein même du bloc ma chronique
alors quel sera le rôle d'edouard
philippe là dedans parce qu'il faut
quand même bien le dire edouard philippe
c'est celui qui a priori ce se
positionne pour être le successeur pour
être le dauphin le fait que le rôle
d'arbitré devait jouer finalement n'est
pas considérablement affaibli il joue
sur le terrain
c'est quand même un arbitre
qui voulaient les espérés précédemment
joué les premiers rôles bien sûr il est
pris en étau entre la macro dit d'un
côté et de l'autre les républicains et
les les accords les alliances elles vont
se faire je veux dire par dessus ça
m'embête parce qu'on a besoin des
républicains mais ça va être très
intéressant aussi de voir la composition
de ce groupe des républicains est-ce
qu'on va avoir une une droite de xavier
bertrand ou de valérie pécresse ou
plutôt une droite de d'eric ciotti ou de
houe de laurent wauquiez c'est
tout va être autour de ça de la manière
dont sont composés ces groupes pourrait
y avoir aussi
ça peut être un cadeau empoisonné
puisque ça veut faire complètement
éclaté ni contre qui sont très très très
divisés quand même cela votre travail
encore vous pensez que dernier avec un
pourrait
décider de rejoindre ensemble oui parce
que je vois mal eric ciotti lefert et
alain verrait bien les républicains du
centre-droit en même temps le président
de la république a dit qu'il remanierait
en fonction des résultats de ces
législatives là c'est plus un simple
remaniement quand on voit un certain
nombre de ses proches battu on va on va
voir ça au fur et à mesure de la soirée
est ce que le mot de crise politique et
est exagéré ce soir
crise politique tout dépend de la de la
représentativité que l'on souhaite à
partir du moment où les français
finalement se sont exprimés c'est que
c'est le tempo la couleur de l'électorat
du moment donc voilà on prend le
résultat est ce que c'est une crise pour
la majorité pour le président en place
oui ça certainement et il faut bien le
dire l'assemblée nationale on a les
français qui se désintéressent de cette
élection et qu'ils ont c'est dire que
c'est un îlot y à part c'est pas du tout
vrai voyez un signal la première
répercussion ça va avoir c'est sur le
gouvernement on ne peut pas garder un
gouvernement qui a été nommé en fonction
d'une majorité pressenti avec la
majorité qui sera celle qui sortira de
cette borne est ce qu elle peut rester à
100 personnes est-ce qu'il faut
réfléchir dans cet accord de
gouvernement qui pourrait éventuellement
se dessiner est-ce qu'il faut réfléchir
à un premier ministre de droite
ce qu'ils contiennent et isabelle dans
la première question avoir la réponse je
pense dans les minutes qui viennent c
est ce qu elle est réélue
ferrand vient d'être battu dans sa
circonscription du finistère c'est le
président de l'assemblée nationale voilà
donc elisabeth gauche réélu ou pas ce
qui est sûr c'est que dans le petit mois
qu'elle a eu à la tête du gouvernement
elle n'a pas convaincu je crois qu'il
faut le dire et c'est le résultat de
cette élection le prouve est-ce qu'elle
tiendra pas justement sa légitimité de
l'élection alors sa légitimité
personnelle sans doute mais là emmanuel
macron on est en train de le dire doit
faire des choix et des choix qui dépasse
la personnalité de sa première ministre
surtout s'il doit par exemple il va s'y
employer seuil est fragmentée par
exemple groupe l'est républicain essayer
de rallier post élection donc très
franchement même si elle est réélue je
dirais qu'elle ressemble quand même à
une première mini sur un siège un peu et
j'ai alors il ya deux personnalités de
droite qui militait déjà pendant les
législatives à une forme de deux
contrats de gouvernement à droite c'est
jean françois copé et c'est nicolas
sarkozy et même s'il ne l'a pas formulé
ouvertement à quoi ça pourrait
ressembler ça veut dire que vous allez
avoir un certain nombre de personnalités
de droite qui vont entrer au
gouvernement ça me paraît un
indispensable si l'on veut considérer
qu' on peut se syndiquent s'est
agglomérée à la majorité présidentielle
une partie dlr il faut leur donner des
gages et peut-être même puisqu'on est en
présence de quelque chose d'historique
on a répété c'est ça ne s'est jamais
produit on peut envisager un changement
de premier ministre pour donner
justement un gage majeur à une droite
alors une droite modérée libéral par
exemple de xavier bertrand je dis pas
que c'est xavier bertrand qui va devenir
premier ministre mais en tout cas il ya
des signes forts qui vont être donnés on
a vu que gérald darmanin qui vient de
cette droite avait été et qui est un
état proche de nicolas sarkozy lui avait
été réélu donc voilà un signe aussi qui
est clé ce groupe des républicains
finalement est ce qui peut exploser en
charlène bezina il ya beaucoup de
courant aujourd'hui à droite ça peut
clarifier les choses voir justement
diviser tout le monde je pense que c'est
bien ce qui est bien qu'on n'explique ce
soir c'est notamment que là on a des
forces politiques qui se sont des sons
des forces politiques de sortie d'urnes
mais en fait la composition de
l'assemblée nationale elle repose sur un
sur un terme qu'on emploie depuis tout à
l'heure qu'on n'a pas expliqué que le
terme de groupes politiques qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un groupe politique c'est
la vie du parti politique à l'intérieur
de l'assemblée et un groupe politique
c'est très simple c'est quinze députés
et c'est une déclaration d'affiliation à
des valeurs communes d'accord donc
aujourd'hui si on à aller une 4e
vingtaine de députés a l'air on a assez
pour deux groupes lr c'est à dire un
groupe l air plus attirés vers le centre
et un groupe l air plus attirés vers la
droite nationale et donc justement je
crois que l air en jouant ce contrat de
gouvernance va jouer son unité les as
survie et la cohérence interne qui
arrive dans un contexte particulier
parce que l air n'a plus vraiment de
capitaine à la barre solide qui veut
s'engager sur l'avenir il accueillait le
patron dlr pour l'instant christian
jacob est encore en poste mais les
choses sont quand même flottant et on
divise le post le groupe
personne n'a vraiment trouvé la réponse
est comment jean luc mélenchon va
fonctionner parce qu'il n'est fait ça
dans cette assemblée nationale il
n'était pas candidat il y à différentes
sous groupes dans la nuit baisse on le
sait bien qui sont amenés à devenir des
groupes parlementaires trop tôt n'ont
eux il est évident qu emmanuel macron va
tenter d'en jouer et comment il va
pouvoir 2 l'extérieur faire assurer une
forme de discipline à la formation qu'il
a quand même conduite pendant la
campagne amatil panneaux qui assurait la
présidence par intérim du groupe qui a
se disent en fait le fait le job on
pourrait dire est ce que vous pensez
qu'elle est capable de tenir le groupe
elle est fille qui passe donc de 17 à 86
député et puis voir cet intergroupe ou
avec il y aura le parti socialiste les
verts et les communistes
alors moi j'ai la conviction d'abord que
l'alliance nubes risque d'éclater sur un
certain nombre d'enjeux par exemple
européen au fil de ce nouveau de cette
nouvelle mandature au fil de ce nouveau
quinquennat économique sauf à imaginer
que le groupe socialiste parce qu'il
devait y avoir un groupe socialiste le
groupe écologiste
s'aligne sur les positions de la france
a soumises on a bien vu que dans le
pacte du ps il y avait un certain moment
on avait acté un certain nombre de
divergences et j'ai peur que ces
divergences n'éclate au moment de 2,2
des projets de lois qui vont être
déposées proposition peut aller quoi
jusqu'aux européennes de 2024 on
peut le dire est ce que mathilde
panneaux alors maintiendra le la
discipline au sein du groupe alors de la
france insoumise que personne ne peut le
dire parce que personne pour l'instant
ne bénéficie au sein de ce groupe de
l'aura du prestige et je dirais de la
gouvernance assez autoritaire tout le
monde le sait qui était celle de jean
luc monschau qui est celle de jean luc
mélenchon au sein de son groupe même
temps il a fait monter toute une
génération
future députée
admettront il la concurrence de le
penser que jean luc mélenchon sens de
cette arène va le regretter au fond de
ne pas avoir été candidat moi moi je
m'interroge dire comment on peut faire
pour faire tenir un groupe avec ses
différentes composantes et en plus avec
ces thèmes qui divisent comme l'europe
par exemple quand on est à l'extérieur
il y à un mot qu'on n'a pas prononcé et
on est dans cette maison assemblée
nationale c'est le mot de dissolution
dans un an est ce que tout ça nous
conduit pas skis emmanuel macron fourbit
ses armes pendant un an pour pouvoir à
ce moment-là eu avec un risque qui est
choquant même habitat importe mais
franchement qu'est ce qu'il a maintenant
donc on peut aussi le jargon raison tout
à l'heure la majorité aurait peut-être
dû dissoudre après la présidentielle oui
mais là je pense que c'est le
il n'a pas été le maître des horloges
contrairement à tout ce qu'on a connu
jusqu'à présent il n'a pas vu venir
cette société se désaxer son échec
personnel c'est quand même un échec
personnel où il faut il faut il a perdu
la baraka emmanuel macron il ay eu
d'abord il ya eu à faire de l'ukraine
etc mais mais mais mais je pense que ma
langue ma qu'on vous a réussi quand même
le pari le défi d'être réélu président
de la république cet unique bon c'est
bien hors cohabitation et qu' il a mal
joué sept cette élection laissait
élections législatives aussi parce que
jean luc mélenchon lui les attraits les
a très bien joué au décor il y avait un
excès de confiance chez le chien mais
derrière tout ça il ya l'évolution de
l'électorat lui même les sous que
veulent les français tout simplement et
on a bien vu et ça dès l'élection
présidentielle que les français je le
répète ils étaient partagés en trois
voire quatre si on compte les
abstentionnistes trois blocs la gare on
va voir ses voiles à ces blocs peuvent
coexister et de quelle manière nouveaux
résultats aurélien pradié on en parlait
des députés de droite il est réélu dans
sa circonscription du lot aurélien
pradié numéro 2 dlr qui aura sans doute
beaucoup de réunions stratégiques dans
les semaines qui viennent pierre latry
on disait trois voire quatre blocs que
disaient les français aux fours il ne
voulait pas donner une majorité absolue
à emmanuel macron mais ne voulait pas la
donne et non plus à jean luc mélenchon
et encore moins peut-être à marine le
pen oui mais c'est ce qu'on avait dans
cette espèce de difficulté était déjà
dans dans les attentes oui c'est quelque
chose qui était déjà lors des élections
présidentielles et qu'on retrouve à
nouveau c'est à dire vraiment trois
blocs de taille à peu près équivalente
en terme de voix alors la part en terme
de sièges du fait de la du mode de
scrutin mais effectivement il n'avait
pas envie de donner une majorité à
emmanuel macron mais il avait encore
moins envie de la donner à la nuque
c'était aussi ça le problème de jean-luc
mélenchon et je pense aussi qu'il ya un
échec des manuels macron dans la
campagne qu'il a choisi de mener la
république en marche n'a pas essayé de
donner vraiment envie aux électeurs de
voter pour eux ils ont surtout joué sur
la carte de la manne dramatisation et
d'expliquer que l'extrême gauche ou
l'extrême droite on a entendu des mots
d'anarchistes de bolchévique qui
arrivera au pouvoir bientôt ils ont
jouer cette carte-là visiblement c'est
un échec or c'est un peu facile dans le
juger après mais ils n'ont pas donné
envie comme il avait réussi à le faire
il ya cinq ans ils n'ont pas réussi à
créer de mouvement et on voit le
résultat ce soir alors la retrouver à
présent que les monts perron pour de
nouveaux résultats de ce second tour des
élections législatives c'est avoue
clément mais brigitte et on commence
avec la guadeloupe où la secrétaire
d'état à la mer justine bénin et battu
41 3% vous le voyez elle est battue par
le divers gauche christian baptiste
allons maintenant dans les landes où le
socialiste boris vallot et telus
59,9 % victoire confortable maintenant
dans la manche philippe gosselin député
l est républicain est très largement
réélu 68 7% pour lui ensuite dans le
puy-de-dôme le président du groupe
communiste à l'assemblée nationale andré
chassaigne est là aussi largement réélu
69 4% allons maintenant en gironde où
c'est une candidate du rassemblement
national qui s'impose c'est une première
dans l'histoire de ce département edwige
dias valeur montante de ce parti c'était
une porte parole de la campagne de
marine le pen elle arrive en tête avec
58,7 % et enfin dans la première
circonscription du lot pour un résultat
qui intéresse les républicains aurélien
pradié se classe en tête largement 64,6
% il est réélu
merci clément perreault pour ces
nouveaux résultats martial foucault nous
a rejoint sur ce plateau bon soit vous
êtes directeur du cevipof
comment vous qualifieriez ces chiffres
ce soir et une petite majorité pour
ensemble de 224 sièges
j'espère ne pas répéter ce qui a déjà
été dit mais
l'interprétation première c'est toi tout
d'abord la grande difficulté quand même
à projeter cette assemblée nationale au
regard des rapports de force dans les
intentions de vote ce score très élevé
historique pour le rassemblement
national va nous obliger à comprendre qu
est ce qui a conduit des électeurs qui
avait le choix soit entre le
rassemblement national face ensemble au
rassemblement national face à la nuit
baisse à choisir le rassemblement
national pour qu'on comprenne s'il ya un
différentiel dans la mobilisation au
second tour est ce que ce sont des
électeurs qui se sont dit finalement
tout sauf emmanuel macron pendant que ça
a été une des uns des ressorts intimes
accroc oui puisque un front républicain
anti
que ce soit on a la confirmation qui
dans ce mode de scrutin très particulier
qui en des handicapés jusqu'à lors le
rassemblement national le front
républicain s'est totalement disloqué
voire même perdu dans dans les limbes de
cette vème république
et puis deuxième enseignement c'est que
on parlait depuis une semaine il y aura
t'il une majorité absolue ou relative en
fait je crois que ce soir c'est ni l'un
ni l'autre c'est tout seulement est ce
qu'il y aura une majorité tout court
pour bourgoin et en regardant peut-être
que c'est encore précoce parce que les
chiffres vont s'affiner au fil de la
soirée mais le cumul du nombre de sièges
ensemble et les républicains ne donne
pas forcément encore une majorité
absolue donc les difficultés vont être
très nombreuses pour demain ou dans les
prochaines heures pour définir est ce
qu'on parle d'un pacte d'une coalition
de gouvernement et toutes les
conséquences que ce contrat acte
coalition ces mots vont être prononcé
dans les jours qui viennent je vous
redonne la parole dans un instant mais
on va d'abord partir sur le terrain à
cahors avec stéphanie des pierres ou
c'est aurélien pradié le numéro deux des
républicains qui vient d'être réélu ce
soir
oui aurélien pradié est arrivé tout à
l'heure en 4l il a été réélu brillamment
avec 65 % des voix il est arrivé au
milieu de ses supporters et puis l'a
rapidement pris la parole il ne cachait
pas sa satisfaction et son émotion vous
le savez ici ce sont des terres de
gauche en 2017 il avait été élu par
surprise beaucoup avaient dit c'est une
anomalie et bien ce soir aurélien pradié
a dit vous voyez ce n'est pas une
anomalie quand on est député les
républicains dans le lot on peut gagner
il a remercié tous les lotois et
notamment ceux qui ne sont pas forcément
de sa couleur politique pas forcément de
droite qui avaient voté pour lui je vous
le rappelle il est réélu avec 65% des
voix pour un second mandat et puis il a
dit c'est le début d'une autre aventure
pour lui le député du lot et puis pour
le pays il n'a pas précisé plus mais on
sait que aurélien pradié peut désormais
avoir des ambitions nationales merci
stéphanie des pierres aurélien pradié
qui pourraient être tentés par la
présidence des républicains vous avez
entendu martial foucault jean garrigues
est ce qu on peut effectivement parler
d'un référendum anti macron ce soir oui
ça me parait ça me paraît assez clair de
toute manière lorsqu'il y a un président
sortant
l'élection présidentielle qui suit et
les élections législatives qui ont sont
toujours maintenant dans la foulée avec
l'élection présidentielle constitue
d'une certaine manière un référendum
pour ou contre le président d'autant
plus cela que je le répète on a quand
même deux blocs protestataires qui sont
qui a eu deux font presque la majorité
absolue d'ailleurs dès des votants donc
nous vous expliquer parce que c'est le
paradoxe quand même de la soirée les
français ont élu est assez simplement
emmanuel macron à la présidentielle bien
sûr un mois et demi plus tard il y a une
forme de deux fronts contre lui qu'est
ce qui s'est passé dans ce mois là non
mais à mes yeux fondamentalement c'est
la schizophrénie de la vie politique
française qui oscille en permanence
entre un principe de verticalité
d'autorité est un principe de
contre-pouvoir et d'horizontalité ça
c'est fondamentalement c'est l'historien
qui parle à mon sens c'est comme ça que
je lis ce qui s'est passé pour
conjoncturellement on voit très bien que
le emmanuel macron été incapable de
proposer après son élection un projet un
projet politique aux français et que
donc les élections législatives se sont
beaucoup jouer justement sur le rejet ou
pas de sa personne le lait le côté
président des riches le côté président d
élite two sakic excès de confiance mais
rien n'est véritablement dans l'esprit
beaucoup marcel martial foucault est ce
qu'on n'est pas là dans un piège qui a
été tendu par emmanuel macron qui se
retrouvent refermer sur lui c'est à dire
que les électeurs ont aussi évolué du et
en même temps et emmanuel macron à la
présidentielle et en même temps et bien
la gauche peut-être aux élections
législatives des contre-pouvoirs assez
fort en tout cas je pense que les
électeurs qui se sont mobilisés contre
et vénale macron ce soir ne voulait
certainement pas faire du en même temps
il je pense que jean guérilla raison
l'élection présidentielle n'oublions pas
que ce score du deuxième tour et un
secours n'ont pas forcément d'adhésion
antilles et à mes yeux de macron mais ça
veut dire puisque on l'évoqué tout alors
cette forme de front républicain qui
avait lui jouée ces différences étaient
une élection nationale là ce sont 570
cette élection me laisse entendre que
pour expliquer ce cette schizophrénie ou
cette incohérence entre le résultat
présidentielle initiative n'oublions pas
que depuis une dizaine d'années on
observe cette montée delà de l'absence
de confiance mais jouant ses vis-à-vis
de l'orgue représentants élus et ce soir
c'est une illustration que c'est pas
parce que emmanuel macron a été élu
président que les français se sentent
prisonniers des institutions qu'on
voudrait leur imposer une certaine
logique politique et institutionnelle
ils se sont saisis de ce qu'il révèle
depuis presque dix ans que ce niveau de
défiance alors je suis toujours prudent
parce que je considère que la défiance
n'est pas le contraire de l'absence de
confiance donc il faut être là je pense
que ce soit on a vraiment un phénomène
de défiance à l'endroit de l'exécutif et
que cette défiance elle peut se
manifester de plusieurs manières et
l'une de ses manières c'est pour ça que
je pense qu'il va falloir regarder
attentivement quel a été le comportement
vraiment des électeurs et du monde on
sait
leurs candidats préférés n'eut pas été
battu comment se sont comportés les
électeurs nu je pense qu'on ne peut pas
écarter l'hypothèse selon laquelle
beaucoup d'entre eux ont préféré voter
contre emmanuel macron ce qui veut dire
en votant rassemblement national sont le
mentionner vases communicants entre
donc des électeurs très politique qui
aurait fait des calculs politiques pour
faire battre non c'est pas un calcul
politique c'est de dire on a une offre
on a un candidat ensemble on a un
candidat rassemblement national on ne
veut pas qu emmanuel macron poursuivre
cette politique l'offre nous oblige en
quelque sorte à voter pour le candidat
qui empêcherait mais elle m'a compte de
gouverner facilement je vous donne la
parole dans un top et instant à charlène
bezina c'est une des énormes surprises
de la soirée le président de l'assemblée
nationale richard ferrand battu dans son
fief du finistère on va l'écouter
bien mesdames messieurs je viens de
prendre acte des résultats indiquant que
les électrices et des électeurs la 6e
circonscription du finistère ont choisi
d'élire député ma concurrente
tout d'abord remercier celles et ceux
qui se sont portés sur mon nom sur son
idée n'est que morvan ma suppléante et
je veux évidemment dressé mes
félicitations à celle qui l'emporté ce
soir est formé pour elle pour la france
et pour notre territoire des voeux de
plein succès
je vous remercie voilà des propos
recueillis par katia guidère à
châteaulin c'est énorme quand même
d'entendre c'est vrai car ferrand
il fait l'un des plus proches des
manuels macron il était là depuis le
début de cette aventure présidentielle
il est battu ce soir il faut rappeler
que ces voix là le baron puisqu'on aime
beaucoup cette expression sous la vème
république le baron de la macro ni celui
qui en a été un petit peu l'idéologue au
départ avec emmanuel macron avec rim
christophe avec gérard collomb
et le président de l'assemblée nationale
qui vient de terminer sa mandature donc
on est vraiment dans un symbole très
fort dans cette élimination l'émotion et
et on sent aussi la surprise la surprise
et moi ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
si on a en tout cas élu emmanuel macron
à la présidentielle il faut rappeler
quand même que la présidentielle elle
cristallise en deux tours ensuite
beaucoup un vote de rejet emmanuel
macron n'a pas été dupe d'ailleurs le
premier soit directement après son
élection tout le monde a dit mais il a
été mal élu ils ne représentent rien et
c est ça n'est pas complètement faux
emmanuel macron a été élu avec une
france très fracturée et il ne
représentait pas à lui seul une adhésion
à son projet et je crois que ce soir ce
qu'on nous dit c'est qu'on a élu
emmanuel macron mais pas la macro n'y
est pas finalement la république en
marche et donc on a élu emmanuel macron
qui restera le chef du bateau mais l'as
mâcon derrière ces personnalités si
proche du président qui se font
sanctionner ce soir gruber cage la mer
c'est à dire qu'on est on a fini une
certaine personnalisation du pouvoir on
n'a pas envie de lui donner finalement
le pouvoir absolu que donne la vème
république on a envie de lui signifier
que une nouvelle aventure est possible
en tout cas là la france est aujourd'hui
bien représentée par son assemblée
nationale alors que ont quitté souvent
les présidentielles avec des déceptions
comme ça je me souviens de françois
bayrou en 2007 qui avec le mode n arrive
à récupérer à peine 4 5 députés la même
chose pour le rassemblement national
lors de la dernière présidentielle
aujourd'hui l'assemblée nationale
représente complètement la fracture
française c'est à dire que on a un
président qui représente et bien
l'adhésion nini et l'assemblée nationale
elles représentent toutes les couleurs
de la france et il va bien falloir
arriver à gouverner avec toutes ses
couleurs et toutes ses négations
finalement puisqu'il ya de l'extrême qui
va rejeter les programmes pour certaines
raisons d'autres qui vont rejeter les
personnes en tant que tel donc ça va
être très difficile mais c'est aussi ce
que veulent les français en tout cas je
pense qu'on est dans dans ce climat et
même en france même dans l'union
européenne en général ya beaucoup de
défiance alors on va poursuivre le débat
en plateau dans quelques instants mais
nous partons dans le calvados à vire où
la première ministre joue son poste ce
soir hélène bonduelle est ce que vous
avez les résultats dans cette
circonscription
alors on a des résultats qui sont quasi
définitif pour l'instant c'est 99 % de
bulletins dépouillés mais en effet
elisabeth bornes la première ministre
serait réélu selon ces résultats
quasi-définitifs avec je vous donne les
chiffres qu'on a pour le moment
52,46 % pour la première ministre
elisabeth bornes et 47 54 % pour son
adversaire de la nuque noé gauchard
disait ici elisabeth bornes dans la
vième siècle
merci hélène bonduelle nous allons
maintenant retrouver marine le pen qui
s'exprime pour la première fois ce soir
après ces résultats le rn qui à 89
sièges mais c'est jean luc mélenchon
finalement qui est qu'il est doublé
également à l'assemblée la nuque qui à
149 sièges il s'exprime ce soir je vous
invite
vous vous faire une opinion définitive à
attendre avec patience
que les chiffres des grandes villes
remonte pour qu'on sache vraiment nous
en sommes
quoi qu'il en soit
nous observons une fois de plus nous
aurait été sous-estimée avant et moi
pendant
mais pour être
à la mesure du moment
même si nous n'avons pas de résultats
suffisamment défini pour pouvoir les
commenter utilement
voyons ce qui se présente
c'est une situation totalement inattendu
absolument inouïe la déroute du parti
présidentiel est totale et aucune
majorité
mais c'est plaisant
nous avons réussi
l'objectif politique que nous étions
donnés en moins d'un mois de faire
tomber celui qui avec autant d'arrogance
avait tendu le bras tout le pays pour
être élu sans qu'on sache pourquoi faire
la france
s'est exprimé et il faut le dire
insuffisamment le niveau de l'abstention
est encore beaucoup trop ce qui signifie
qu'une immense partie de la population
ne sait de quel côté se tourner
tant et si bien que les trois blocs qui
était apparu à la sortie de l'élection
présidentielle
continue à être voisins dans des
proportions quasi identique sans qu'on
sache à cette heure si la percée de la
nuque le place en première ou en
deuxième position
mais c'est au total est avant tout
l'échec électoral de la macro ni
c'est l'échec
plus grave
les sexes moral
de ces gens qui donnait des leçons à
tout le monde sans arrêt et qui se
prétendait le barrage à l'extrême droite
et que rôle pour principal résultat d'en
avoir renforcé des arrêts sur 65 face à
face entre la nuque
et le rassemblement national
les donneurs de leçons de la macro ni
ont été incapables de donner une
consigne claire dans 52 cas
ce qui les disqualifie me semble-t-il
dorénavant à faire de leçon morale pour
qui que ce soit
quel bon débarras
d'avoir vu après monsieur blanc caire
éliminé dès le premier tour
voir éjecter les baigneurs castaner
et l'injure yeuse nan shan à
vous tous
mon message ce soir une fois de plus est
un message de combat des opportunités
incroyables vont se présenter devant
vous et en particulier devant vous la
jeune génération qui est celle qui
appelle avec le plus de force à la
rupture avec ce monde et ses règles
d'organisation
des opportunités
parce que vous disposez d'un magnifique
outil de combat dont vous aviez été
privé pendant tant de temps cet outil
c'est la nuque ce sont ces
parlementaires
ouvriers ouvrière
salariés de plusieurs ordres de toutes
les régions de france
arrivant par dizaines sur les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale
le maquereau nine ne s'est pas seulement
mis en faillite lui même il a plongé le
pays dans une impasse et tout à l'heure
déjà nous avons entendu qu'il s'agissait
de dépasser les clivages
il n'y a aucun arrivage a dépassé avec
nous parce que nous ne sommes pas du
même monde nous visons pas les mêmes
objectifs nous n'avons pas les mêmes
valeurs nous croyons pas aux mêmes futur
et comme nous pensons qu'ils le savent
alors nous en concluons qu'il se prépare
à d'autres entend peut-être toujours est
il que si nous sommes à la fin de la
soirée la lutte acquis par diverses
manoeuvres on a déjà commencer par
retirer quasiment 21 députés d outre-mer
et à commencer par ceux de la réunion ou
six sièges sur sept sont emportés par
des députés qui pour la confiance un
gouvernement de la nuit
je veux vous dire
que toutes les possibilités sont dans
vos mains
quant à moi
je change de poste de combat mais mon
engagement et demeurera jusqu'à mon
dernier souffle dans les premiers de vos
rangs si vous le voulez bien
le bronze jaillissement
[Applaudissements]
oui le grand jaillissement de l'histoire
du plus profond de ce qu'est la france
des rébellions et des révolutions oui ce
grand jaillissement dorénavant un visage
le visage et notre collectif celui de
l'union populaire
les défis les plus inouïes vont
s'accumuler devant vous que ce soit le
changement climatique que ce soit la
grande crise financière
par quelques côté que vous voyez ce
monde finissant
c'est à chaque fois des réponses
fulgurante qu'il faudra apporter pas un
instant nous ne renonçons à l'ambition
d'être ceux qui gouvernent ce pays et
qu'il amène un autre horizon pas un
instant les salariés ne baisserons les
bras pas à l'instant les jeunes ne se
diront
fatigué de la lune
[Applaudissements]
ne doutez pas de vous même
ne cédez jamais à l'impatience
penser que chaque difficulté à deux
visages celui qui s'oppose à vous et
celui de l'opportunité qu'elle vous
propose
plus grands sont les bouleversements
plus grandes sont les opportunités
la france est une nation politique quand
bien même elle s'abstient beaucoup et
même quand elle le dit par son
abstention
ne méprisons jamais notre peuple
écoutons toujours avec attention tout ce
qu'il dit car danse la patience infinie
il a montré qu'il était capable de
trancher et de décider d'avancer et tel
est le mandat que vous avez ce soir
demain matin peut-être que vous vous
réveillerez avec lui une majorité de la
nuit par l'assemblée nationale
ou bien avec le premier groupe
aucun tripotage aucun arrangement
non nous privera de cette possibilité et
si ce n'est pas le cas alors vous
regarderez d'abord la puissance
formidable que vous avez accumulé vive
la france vive la république
maciel foucault on entend jean luc
mélenchon nous parler de déroute pour
emmanuel macron nous ne sommes pas du
même monde il revendique clairement la
victoire ce soir et promet une forme de
dégagisme finalement à l'assemblée
nationale mais puisque je trouve qui est
intéressant à excuser moi je trouve qui
est intéressant c'est en effet ce mot
nous ne sommes pas du même monde sait
qu'on voit vraiment qu'on va incarner
une opposition tout à fait original dans
sa nature oui la position très rare
mêlant chant employé des termes assez
étonnant là ce soir il a parlé du
gouvernement de la nuque donc laissé
entendre que il revendiquait à sa
manière la victoire laissant entendre
qu'il y ait encore une possibilité ce
soir ou utilisation éventuelle au fil
des chiffres que
nul soit le groupe qui pourrait
organiser articuler une coalition pour
gouverner et je pense que ce scénario
est celui qui a alimenté toute la
campagne no doubt la campagne électorale
et ce qui va provoquer quand même là
sérieux j'allais dire cafouillage du
côté de la majorité sortante pour voir
comment on arrive a indiqué je regarde
les chiffres ensemble est largement
devant la france insoumise la nuque sur
donne la parole dans un instant mais ils
se sont exprimés ensemble
jean luc mélenchon et marine le pen
peut-être il n'y a pas de hasard alors
marine le pen on va l'écouter à présent
c'est l'autre gagnante de la soirée
mesdames messieurs chers amis
au terme de cette longue séquence
électorale de mise en place des
institutions pour le quinquennat qui
vient le peuple s'est exprimé
surmontant l'obstacle d'un mode de
scrutin particulièrement injuste et
inadapté aux valeurs de notre temps il a
décidé d'envoyer un très puissant groupe
parlementaire de députés rassemblement
national à l'assemblée
[Applaudissements]
tu te cas ainsi un peu plus nationale ce
groupe sera de très loin le plus
nombreux de l'histoire de notre famille
politique
j'adresse toute ma gratitude aux
électeurs qui leur ont témoigné leur
confiance
cette confiance nous oblige nous avons
atteint les 3 objectifs que nous nous
étions fixés
faire des manuels macro un président
minoritaire de manière à préserver le
pays du règne d'un parti unique et d'un
président sans contrôle dans l'exercice
du pouvoir avec le risque que nous lui
connaissons d'en abuser pour suivre la
recomposition politique indispensable au
ressourcement démocratique et au seuil
du troisième millénaire pris en otage
par le mondialisme assumer le triomphe
de l' idée salvatrice de nation enfin de
constituer un groupe d'opposition
déterminant face aux des constructeurs
d'en haut les maquereaux nist et au des
constructeurs d'en bas cette extrême
gauche anti républicaine nous
incarnerons une opposition ferme c'est à
dire sans connivence mais une opposition
responsable
c'est à dire respectueuse des
institutions est toujours constructif
parce que notre seul et unique boussole
est l'intérêt de la france et du peuple
français
[Applaudissements]
ce nouveau groupe parlementaire national
et républicain aura à coeur dans
l'esprit de rassemblement national que
nous portons d'associer tous les élus et
mouvements politiques qui souhaitent
avec nous participer au redressement du
pays avec ses dizaines et ses dizaines
de députés de coeur et de conviction du
rassemblement national qui sont d'abord
des citoyens français soucieux du bien
public vous aurez la certitude de voir
défendu au parlement vos idées sur
l'immigration la sécurité le chômage la
justice fiscale et sociale
les territoires oubliés les citoyens
maltraités ou la démocratie bafouée
[Applaudissements]
les nouveaux visages
les nouveaux visages ce que vous allez
découvrir des visages rayonnants
d'enthousiasmé de vie sont l'avant-garde
de cette nouvelle élite politique qui
prendra la responsabilité du pays
lorsque l' aventure macro aura pris fin
au delà du groupe parlementaire nous
allons poursuivre le travail de
rassemblement des français ou sans un
grand mouvement populaire unifiant tous
les patriotes de droite et de gauche un
rassemblement national pour défendre le
pays face à un effondrement que nous
constatons chaque jour et quand les
français le déciderons d'engager le
redressement dans la france a urgemment
besoin j'appelle tous les français d'où
qu'ils viennent quelle que soit leur
origine quelle que soit leur situation
personnelle ou professionnelle à nous
rejoindre dans cette aventure prat
ternel et exaltante qui s'appelle la
france notre seule ambition est de
servir les français nous nous battons
pour eux pour nos enfants pour le pays
vive la république vive la france
voilà donc pour la première réaction de
marine le pen ce soir tout sourire un
très puissant groupe parlementaire à
l'assemblée nationale c'est vraiment
historique c'est vraiment un mode de
scrutin qui ne lui est pas favorable le
père est dépassé largement sinon
j'aimerais marie le pen ce soir d'autant
plus que le groupe de cairns 1804 1986
pardon les 35 députés était dû notamment
ce que tu impôt proportionnel là on a
vraiment on est dans le cadre du scrutin
majoritaire qui historiquement
défavorable au rassemblement national on
a un très très beau résultat mais qui
avait déjà été soulignée ici même au
premier tour la sécrétion plus forte et
voilà été et est spectaculaire
quand même assez clairement délimitées
on voit bien ce sont les zones
industrielles du nord et du nord-est et
puis le sud est qui sont d'ailleurs de
sensibilité seulement justement ma vie
au premier tour des les implantations en
tout cas parfois en ballottage favorable
ailleurs en faire une nationalisées
mais simplement il faut bien voir quand
même avec les deux discours qu'on
convient d'entendre on voit bien là
qu'on est dans le
l'exact opposé de ce qu'est la tradition
du débat parlementaire de ce que
pourrait être une vie parlementaire je
dirais apc c'est à dire qu' il n'est pas
question de transiger pour jean luc
mélenchon chine il parle même lui de
démantèlement d'être le pivot d'une
somme d'une sorte de majorité afin je ne
sais pas très bien ce qu'il skie ce
qu'il envisage parce que de toute
manière la nuque baisse à mon sens ça ne
va pas tarder en tout cas ce à
s'effriter pas sinon à se disloquer mai
et puis c'est pareil avec leurs
assemblées notion pas de concret qui
l'on garde à quoi va ressembler les
débats quoi vont ressembler les débats
et puis et puis à chaque à chaque texte
il faudra chercher une majorité dans le
karoo bas près groupe députés après
députés dans tous les groupes dans le
cas d'une majorité relative et en
l'absence d' usage du 49-3 puisqu'il est
maintenant limité et en plus de de toute
façon rejetée par la majorité des
français
la seule solution c'est de trouver des
majorités sur têt la géométrie variable
sur tel ou tel sur tel ou tel point à
moins de réussir une sorte de contrat de
gouvernement avec les républicains dans
les semaines qui viennent mais ça c'est
sait compter d'abord sur la capacité
d'une majorité ans enfin oui ensemble
plus les républicains ce qui peut être
possible mais aussi sur lui une certaine
homogénéité des républiques ce qui ce
qui là est quand même très sereine
martial foucault on voit que le
rassemblement national à 89 sièges ça en
fait le premier parti d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale si chacun
évidemment et composé par partie vous
prenez la france insoumise le ps europe
ecologie les verts le pc en termes de
sièges le rn 9 ans elle est fille seule
ça veut dire que la présidence de la
commission des finances pourrait revenir
à un député du rassemblement national
oui si ces chiffres se confirment parce
que je pense que l'écart entre la france
a soumises et le rn et est trop proche
pour dire ce soir le rn devient le
premier parti d'opposition
mais ça nous indique que deux choses
importantes en termes de culture
parlementaire sur la chaîne
parlementaire il faut parler des
cultures parlementaire premièrement on
va découvrir aussi que finalement cette
vème république est en train de se
remémorer une culture parlementaire
passé dans un système dont on dit qu'ils
ne cessent de se sur présidentialiser
siper présidentialiser lentement forte
percée ça c'est le revers de la médaille
voilà de cette hyper présidentiel est le
meilleur ou pour le pire parce que c'est
encore fois ci le pouvoir légiférer
c'est la fonction même des parlements
oui c'est le même débat que l'on a qu'on
parle du mode de scrutin on dit le fait
majoritaire 1 quand même protégé à
donner de la stabilité
certes mais au fond on est je pense que
la france n'est pas un peuple prêt à
cette culture parlementaire il n'y a pas
cette culture parlementaire dans le pays
et donc toutes les institutions ont
contribué à cette
hyperprésidentialisation mais deuxième
élément par rapport à la montée du et
rennes
on va découvrir comme des députés qui
ont quand je regardais le profil des
candidats absolument peu d'expérience en
politique presque aucun n'a eu un mandat
d'élu local donc ça va être
véritablement un ben je sais pas si ça
va être un bain de jouvence mais ça va
être un bain d'apprentissage pour le
moins très complexe pour un
rassemblement national qui va avoir un
rôle à jouer pour être au fond au coeur
de toutes les possibilités de motion de
défiance vis-à-vis de ce gouvernement
est ce que le rn va rester seuls isolés
et ne voudra pas se mêler à des
oppositions totalement contraires
notamment celle de la nuque ça c'est le
premier élément est plus il faut
expliquer que pour une motion de
défiance s'est tous les partis dits
d'opposition y compris des républicains
salies
compte que les votes positifs que les
votes positifs et puis un dernier
élément sur le sur le rn qui me semble
intéressant par rapport à la la vie de
cette législature effectivement est-ce
que emmanuel macron doivent considérer
si je dis bien si majuscule si le fn est
le premier parti d'opposition est qu
emmanuel macron souhaite faire un coup
politique avec un un gouvernement
totalement inédit sous la vème est-ce
qu'il acceptera d'aller jusqu'à demander
à des députés du rassemblement national
de participer à ce gouvernement ça je
pense que c'est probablement une ligne
jaune qu'il ne peut pas franchir au
regard de ce qu'a été l'histoire
d'emmanuel macron et il ne serait ce que
la dernière campagne présidentielle dans
une construction politique c'est chaque
contre les mêmes l'extrême droite les
nationalismes progressive contre
nationale inss était son voile à son
credo l'outil de 2010 à lille et un peu
plus de 21h ce soir merci à tous d'avoir
commenté ces premiers résultats de ce
second tour des élections législatives
dans un instant d'autres invités sur ce
plateau vont nous rejoindre mais nous
retrouvons tout de suite clément
perreault pour d'autres résultats oui
brigitte et on commence avec l'un des
résultats choc de cette soirée ça se
passe dans les alpes de haute provence
où christophe castaner donc le président
du groupe des députés en marche a été
battu 48 5% pour l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur il est devancé par le
candidat de la nuque les eaux
terre qui l'emportent donc avec 51 4%
des suffrages allons maintenant dans
l'ain où le ministre des solidarités
damien abad et confortablement réélu
57,8 % pour lui je vous rappelle que
c'est l'ancien président du groupe l'est
républicain à l'assemblée et qu'il a
rejoint le bloc présidentiel maintenant
allons dans l'aisne prendre des
nouvelles d'un candidat les républicains
il s'agit de julien dit mme jean a dit
que c'est un proche de xavier bertrand
il est confortablement réélu avec
58,1 % des voix une candidate lr à
nouveau une vice présidente de
l'assemblée nationale c'est annie
genevard dans l'est d'où elle est
également réélu assez confortablement
même très confortablement 72% des voix
donc pour annie genevard il est
également républicain il est également
vice-président de l'assemblée nationale
c'est marc le fur député les
républicains des côtes d'armor il est
lui aussi réélue 64 8% il devance le
candidat de la nuque antoine ravard qui
fait
35,1 pour cent en charente maritime
des nouvelles de l'une des figures de
l'assemblée nationale olivier falorni et
bien il est à nouveau réélu divers
gauche
66,1 coursan il devance son adversaire
de la nuque et pour terminer cette série
je vous propose d'aller en
seine-maritime voir les résultats
d'agnès firmin le bodo alors elle est
dans la majorité ensemble du parti
horizon c'est une proche d'edouard
philippe c'est une élue du havre elles
l'emportent avec 57 8% des voix et 6 2
coup de barre à dos merci beaucoup merci
à vous clément 21h04 bienvenue à tous
ceux qui nous rejoignent sur la chaîne
parlementaire grande soirée électorale
spéciale second tour des législatives et
des surprises il y en a un je vous
rappelle la principale information de la
soirée c'est que la coalition
présidentielle ensemble est loin très
loin ce soir de la majorité absolue je
vous présente nos nouveaux invités dans
un tout petit instant mais priorité au
résultat on part en gironde avec marion
becker vous êtes en mesure marion de
nous dire quel est le résultat pour le
rassemblement national
oui effectivement myriam en gironde le
rassemblement national à deux élus deux
députés les deux élus qui était en tête
au premier tour edwige diaz en la 11e
circonscription obtient 58 70 % des voix
le résultat est confirmé définitif et
puis grégoire de fournès dans la 5e
circonscription
obtiendrait lui 56% des voix ce sont
donc deux élus pour le rassemblement
national ici en gironde qui confirme la
percée de marine le pen déjà lors de la
présidentielle avec des scores ici très
haut pour le rassemblement national
merci marion becker on vous rappelle
évidemment les résultats ce soir avec
cette projection en nombre de sièges de
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée nationale est
un véritable coup de tonnerre puisque
ensemble n'obtient pas la majorité
absolue une majorité qui est très loin
pour la coalition présidentielle avec
224 un siège pour ensemble la nuque
recueil 149 sièges lr divers droite udi
78 sièges devant le rassemblement
national qui à 89 sièges et puis les
divers gauche 21 sièges nous sommes à
présent avec nos invités ici en plateau
vincent martini bonsoir merci nous avoir
rejoints vous êtes professeur de
sciences politiques à l'université de
nice et à l'école polytechnique et puis
pascal perrineau vous vous êtes
politologue professeur des universités
martial foucault vous êtes toujours avec
nous et pierre latry notre partenaire
ipsos au bras steria vous êtes également
avec nous ce soir pascal perrineau une
réaction coup de tonnerre comment vous
réagissez à ces chiffres ce soir coup de
tonnerre pas pour tous monde
d'abord premier point une érosion peu
commune du bloc majoritaire mais surtout
du parti majoritaire imaginez qu'en cinq
ans ils ont perdu perdu la moitié de
leurs effectifs
donc il faut ça vous donne tout de même
la dimension de la sanction qui s'est
exprimé lors des deux tours de ces
élections législatives deuxième leçon on
avait l'impression que tout se passait
autour du duo macron mélenchon
du côté de mélenchon si vous voulez si
la stratégie avait un sens si ce qu'il
disait était vrai c'est un échec c'est
un échec puisque sa stratégie de dire il
faut mais lire à matignon ça consistait
à voir une majorité relative ou absolue
la majorité relative il n'a pas la
majorité absolue il ne l'a pas donc
c'est un échec même si en effet la
montée la poussée en herbe du groupe et
les fit est significative troisième
élément qui me semblent majeur
les français les observateurs redécouvre
que la france c'est un pays à droite
s'est il ya eu la droitisation ça existe
on a parlé de la droitisation de la
république en marche tout au long des
années qui viennent de ceux de s'écouler
et en effet on voit dans les enquêtes
comment le centre de gravité de la macro
ni est passé du centre gauche vers le
centre droit les 89 députés en effet ou
90 ou 85
voilà bah ça traduit tout simplement ce
que l'on avait vu déjà au premier tour
la présidentielle et au second tour la
potentielle il fallait prendre au
sérieux le 42% de marine le pen ça
montrait que voilà il était dans une
logique de dynamique et ça montre aussi
que ça y est le rassemblement national
commence à avoir de véritables racines
locales et c'est le porte parole qu'on
le veuille ou non des fractures sociales
et territoriales en france c'est pas la
gauche de la gauche c'est pas la gauche
modérée le seul anachronisme
c'est pas et l'eire qui exprime ses
fractures c'est le rassemblement
national on le voit dans les terres dans
lequel ils sont élus pour vous s'il ya
un vainqueur ce soir c'est plutôt le
rassemblement national la gagnante c'est
marine le pen qui comptera 100 sièges
considérablement et vision c'est évident
et puis ce qui ne faut pas oublier c'est
la très bonne résilience du groupe et
l'air tout le monde disait le groupe ait
l'air va être marginalisés s'ils font
les 78 à 81 députés avec leurs alliés
udi c'est tout même une très bonne
résilience et on les avaient chassé par
la porte et ils peuvent très bien
revenir par la fenêtre parce que avec
220 députés qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que le président alors pascal perrineau
un résultat qui nous parvient ce soir
c'est la ministre brigitte bourguignon
ministre de la santé qui va très
certainement quitter le gouvernement
comme le veut la règle d'usagé
puisqu'elle est battue ce soit dans sa
circonscription du pas de calais
49,9 pour cent ça a dû se jouer à
quelques voix comme un petit peu partout
vincent martini oui c'est joue un petit
peu partout à quelques voix non je
voudrais revenir ce que disait pascal
perrineau parce qu'il parlait justement
un résultat relativement historique
c'est vrai pour le rassemblement
national surtout qu'on a pas vu venir ça
c'est intéressant parce qu'on pensait de
manière assez logique que le
rassemblement national quel que soit son
score aux élections présidentielles il
était condamnée à échouer dans un
scrutin majoritaire layher moi j'imagine
comme beaucoup de mes collègues disions
la même chose c'est à dire que bon bah
on observe l histoire le séquençage de
la vie politique française depuis 40 ans
et on constatait un effondrement du
rassemblement national même si on avait
déjà vu qu'au premier tour il avait
réalisé un score historique puisqu'il
avait progressé en nombre de voix si ce
n'est avec une forte abstention à
l'élection par les pénalise moi je
dirais quand même deux choses en
supplément la première c'est que certes
la france est de droite mais ya que la
moitié de la france qui a voté et on
sait quelle moitié n'a pas voté c'est
notamment toutes les jeunes générations
et pas seulement les 18 35 ans et que
les to de vote jusqu'à 49 ans sont très
faibles à 18 35 ans est évident c'est un
peu moins évident dans la tranche 40 35
40 devant mais ça veut quand même dire
qu'il ya une partie de la france qui
décide pour l'autre de manière
systématique et elle en a fait il ya un
clivage générationnel probablement sur
ces questions là deuxième élément c'est
la situation dans lequel se trouve
institutionnellement emmanuel macron qui
est là aussi sans précédent il ya un
précédent de gouvernement minoritaire en
france on la connaît c'est le
gouvernement rocard de 1988 et nous en
parlions de pascal perrineau tout à
l'heure il lui manquait et moins d'une
dizaine de voix pour atteindre la
majorité absolue a usé à foison du 49
voir s'il pouvait viser 9 3 aujourd'hui
non seulement il ne le peut pas mais en
plus il manque plus de 70 députés
presque 70 députés bon en fonction des
résultats définitifs qu'on obtiendra
dans la nuit et donc ça veut dire que
sans contrat de gouvernement
probablement et les républicains s'il le
souhaite et si ils arrivent à trouver
entend t on imagine qu'ils vont vendre
cher cette place là eh bien il n'y a pas
de majorité absolue possible et ça je
crois que c'est vraiment il faut
insister à quel point c'est ça l'a
vraiment très très grande surprise
gouvernable ou pas non c'est pas
forcément un gouverneur parce que tout
dépend de ce qui va se jouer demain
quelle main tendue va opérer le parti
présidentiel et la majorité
présidentielle vis-à-vis d'un groupe
rappelons le un horizon c'est déjà une
succursale de ce que les républicains ou
en tout cas les républicains deviennent
succursale de la majorité présidentielle
on voit comment on peut le dire mais si
on ajoute les députés horizons et les
députés de des républicains vous avez à
peu près 1 le groupe des républicains de
2010 justement à saint martin et on peut
réécouter peut-être olivier grégoire qui
a un porte parole du gouvernement et qui
réfléchit effectivement à la presse
regardez gouverner c'est s'exposer
gouverner c'est choisir disait bien
mieux que moi un grand homme politique
et choisir c'est souvent renoncer
renoncer cd se voit on a déçu un certain
nombre de français le message est clair
je rappelle néanmoins qu'à cette heure
nous sommes néanmoins en première place
c'est une fleur première place qui est
décevante mais vous allez devoir mais
c'est une première place vous allez
devoir composer aux regards posés à
trois avec ceux qui veulent faire
avancer le pays et faire avancer alors
qu'elle projetait déjà je m'attendais
c'est déjà demain tendu mais vers la fin
j'ai toujours été la main est tendue je
pense que on va déjà commencer par voir
quelle sera la carte nuitamment
voilà on va devoir composer et on attend
encore les résultats définitifs parce
que ça peut encore bouger la preuve nos
estimations sont un peu différente de
celle d'il ya une heure une heure et
quart pierre latry oui on le disait que
ça pouvait bouger donc on a
effectivement un petit mouvement avec
une remontée pour la majorité
présidentielle avec 230 sièges dans la
dernière estimation ipsos oprah steria
et un léger recul pour le râble au
rassemblement national qui serait autour
de 85 sièges
cela dit cela ne bouleverse pas les
équilibres commandes de tout à l'heure
qui restent à peu près les mêmes qu'à 20
heures alors comment gouverner il ya
l'exécutif et le législatif on s'attend
déjà un remaniement qui va être beaucoup
plus important que prévu que doit faire
emmanuel macron est-ce que la première
ministre elisabeth borne peut rester en
place à matignon déjà
c'est un c'est un choix qui appartient
au président de la république c'est lui
qui va faire ça l'appréciation de la
situation politique parce que si on
revient sur notre arithmétique il ya un
instant sur la possibilité pour emmanuel
macron d'avoir une majorité avec le
soutien des élèves ça sera certes une
majorité absolue mais très très faibles
et ont ses coûts au cours d'une
législature il y a toujours des députés
pour des raisons aux diverses qui vont
quitter la majorité et donc au fond pour
email macron l'enjeu c'est d'éviter de
se retrouver dans un an un an et demi
dans une situation de majorité relative
ensuite pour mêmes macron bat-il doit-il
va-t-il garder elisabeth board il faut
attendre l'ensemble des ministres c'est
quand même 14 ministres plus il y avait
d'autres dont on appris qu'elle a été
réélu qui sont en situation si vous
voulez si le nombre de ministres battus
ce soir dépasse les 3 4 c'est toi un
maniement consulte un mauvais signal
c'est une crise politique c'est ça nous
répond à quoi qu'en pense à ce qu'on
puisse pas encourager les politiques
n'arrivent pas à voile à avoir le
suffrage universel non mais ça c'est
l'effet domino magne c'est à dire
l'effet de la non campagne c'est-à-dire
aujourd'hui les ministres qui essayait
pour certains de se faire élire et
d'autres être élu pour la première fois
n'ont clairement pas eu la possibilité
d'installer un nouveau programme deux
quinquennats donc le ca il n'y avait pas
d'élément et puis ensuite pour email
mâcon quelle leçon quels enseignements
il doit tirer de cette impossibilité de
gouverner seul c'est aussi un grand
changement jusqu'à présent ils pouvaient
compter sur ses propres dires qu'il va
devoir apprendre la culture de compromis
culture du compromis je suis pas certain
que l'ensemble des députés aient l'air
soutiennent l'idée de construire un
pacte de gouvernement parce que au sein
d alerte ou le monde n'est pas d'accord
avec les positions prises par ces cas-là
remarquons qu'il y avait l'expérience ça
se décide en conseil stratégique quand
bureau national qui décide si on fait un
pacte de gouvernement au niveau d'un
appareil parce que il via le buzz ou pas
sont les votes qui reste individuelle
des députés et puis il ya les parties le
président et le principal concerné
surtout quand le président dans une
optique hyper présidentiel est devenu le
chef de la majorité il fait tout premier
ministre bon et c'est donc et avec
emmanuel macron qui cherchent une
nouvelle méthode mais qui ne l'a pas
encore trouvé cette fois ci va être
contraint à une nouvelle méthode ou
alors il dissout mais la sanction la
risque d'être ça pourrait être pire
encore les boîtes le scénar mais quelle
forme ça peut prendre ça veut dire qu
emmanuel macron va recevoir le chef des
républicains va lui proposer des choses
la semelle de crêpe consultations qu'il
peut y avoir toute une série de
consultations des différents présidents
particuliers de groupes ça sera dans
l'est dans les jours qui viennent on
verra comment tous ces députés vont se
répartir en groupe parce qu'apparemment
par exemple les communistes ne peuvent
pas avoir de groupe on va les aider
alors on verra qui est d'où ça vient et
on est assez reconnaissant vis-à-vis de
ceux qui vous ont rendu le service
d'avoir un groupe donc on verra comment
ça se passe et puis ensuite c'est la
fonction du chef de l'état est également
du premier ministre s'il veut exister ou
de la première ministre s'il veut
exister en tant que aussi un peu chef de
la majorité et bien voilà la macro ni
ensemble va discuter
sont des discussions qui mène à akwa un
accord de gouvernement on discute du
projet on discute du projet sur lequel
il pourrait y avoir une majorité voilà
c'est aux enfants et fort n'avoir effort
long terme moderne celle où finalement
on peut s'entendre c'est qu'on a fait
par exemple en allemagne on imagine que
la réforme des retraites va être central
dans ces discussions de coalition est ce
que la france a cette culture là et est
ce que notre président est capable de ça
alors ces deux questions un peu
différent tout mon jeu comme tous les
gens qui font de la science politique je
crois à la culture politique jusqu'à un
certain point c'est un je pense aussi
que les situations font que on s'adapte
ajustements aux événements et à ce titre
là je pense la france a pas moins la
culture qu'ailleurs elle a moins
d'expérience ici le faire la fête quand
même dans des temps
pas si lointain que ça
dans la 4ème plus gras troisième
république pendant quand même ce plus
d'une centaine d'années la france a été
une république parlementaire certes
émaillée de vente d'instabilité du
mouvement présidentiel mais en tout cas
depuis la 5ème république elle n'en a
plus l'expérience là il va falloir que
l'on re découvre quelque chose d'assez
nouveau par rapport à ce que disait
pascal perrineau justement sur la façon
dont ça peut se faire il ya plusieurs
choses qui vont aussi rentrer en ligne
de compte et une des enjeux très
importants c'est qui va être le premier
parti d'opposition j'entendais tout à
l'heure que vos invités évoquer cette
question mais c'est une question très
importante parce que depuis 2008 le
responsable du principal parti
d'opposition on peut envoyer un de ses
membres à la tête de la commission des
finances jusqu'à présent il était
presque acquis que ce soit un des partis
de la nuque probablement la france qui
n'est pas le cas ce soit aujourd'hui si
vos résultats restent les mêmes ça
voudrait dire que le rassemblement
national aurait la présidence de la
commune alors il faut penser à lefaux
qu'au juste parce que l'adulte à boujan
sur là on est à 85 sièges pour le
rassemblement national et vous êtes
toujours à 3 pour la france en 81 on est
très proche de toute manière ça c'est
une évidence mais en tous les cas de
figure par rapport au contrat de
gouvernement là et je voudrais vraiment
insister sur ce que disait marcel
foucault il a totalement raison on fait
comme si c'était un acquis qu'il y
aurait un contrat de gouvernement très
facile à trouver que les républicains
mais les républicains vous le savez sont
en crise ouverte depuis des années sur
leur ligne ils sont pas deux mais
justement à quand on entend ça et vous
marcel foucault vous nous disiez que ça
pouvait être compliqué d'avoir cette
coalition qu'elle pouvait être même très
fragile ça veut dire que c'est quoi les
scénarios comment on gouverne demain et
est ce que finalement on va pas avoir 5
ans d'immobilisme
c'est un risque sérieux c'est un risque
sérieux parce que même s'il ya un
contrat de gouvernement et je ne peux
pas aujourd'hui et ce soit en tant qu'on
n'a pas la vraiment les chiffres très
précis de nombre de députés on peut
imaginer tous les scénarios évidemment
il y aura un appel du pied d' emmanuel
macron auprès d'un certain nombre de
députés élus quels que soient leurs
appartenances partisanes on peut
imaginer ce scénario
ensuite je pense qu'on va rentrer
pendant cinq années durant lesquelles le
pouvoir législatif la fabrique de la loi
va se faire on l'a dit tout à l'heure à
géométrie variable il ya des projets sur
lesquels il sera très simple d'avoir un
consensus sur des questions de société
ou certaines des orientations peut-être
économique qui vient un peu terrible et
d'autre
seront des sujets très conflictuelle et
j'ai moi même confie t elle au sens
polarisant du terme et dont mais c'est
impossible la logique quand même de la
vème république qui va être un peu
remise en cause oui je ne suis pas tout
à fait d'accord en tout cas le parlement
redevient le coeur des pouvoirs
attendait remontons à l'esprit des
origines c'est à dire en 59 ans 50 9 le
général de gaulle et président de la
république n'y a pas de majorité de 59
le parti gaulliste n'a absolument pas de
majorité absolue et donc il va gouverner
avec qui il va gouverner avec les
démocrates-chrétiens avec les
socialistes y avait des ministres
socialistes n'en gouvernement debré avec
les radicaux avec les indépendants 1
qu'elle en attendait ça ressemble un peu
à d'union nationale ce que vous décrivez
non parce qu'il n'y avait pas les
communistes parce qu'il est pas
mitterrand parce qu'il n'y avait pas
pierre mendès-france par exemple un donc
ça n'était ce n'était pas rien mais vous
voyez et c'était de gaulle c'était de
gaulle et en 62 en effet les destins ont
du verre et la du verger j'allais dire
aux diverger s'est amusé à ce que vous
dites c'était de gaulle de gaulle a
gouverné par référendum est-ce que vous
on peut imaginer que au cours de la
prochaine est saturé y ait davantage de
référendum et pourquoi pas sur les
retraites qui était déjà une proposition
de françois bayrou pendant la campagne
présidentielle la difficulté des usages
des référendum c'est lorsque vous avez
une très grande légitimité politique
sert que les gens vous font confiance
comme ça a été le cas du général de
gaulle dont parce que parce que parler
pascal perrineau bah là vous prenez pas
trop de risques et encore vous rappelez
vous quand ça c'est fini pour de gaulle
en 69 il a perdu sur ce fonds n'est pas
obligée d'engager sa responsable avait
un capital politique déjà très affaiblie
comme c'est le cas des modèles macron
avec un pays très clivé sur sa personne
en engager des référendum c'est vraiment
prendre le risque de les perdre à coup
sûr sur des projets geste américains
pourront enfin tous savaient très bien
que quand on fait un référendum sur un
projet les français répondent pas
forcément sur le projet de la même
manière que jacques chirac n'a pas
démissionné après l'échec de la
constitution affaiblit gyan on peut
considérer que c'est vraiment la fin de
son deuxième quinquennat
donc c'est pas une porte de sortie c'est
pas une porte de sortie très aisée pour
emmanuel macron n'imagine pas en tout
cas qui pourraient l'utiliser et on va
accueillir à nouveau clément pernot
avant de reprendre cette cette
discussion pour les estimations de notre
partenaire ipsos sopra steria les choses
sont en train de bouger le visage de la
nouvelle assemblée en nombre de sièges
d'abord voilà je vous propose ni rien
maintenant de nous plonger dans le
visage que pourrait avoir le nouvel
hémicycle c'est à partir des estimations
de notre partenaire ipsos vous voyez
cette affiche cet hémicycle s'afficher
devant moi le groupe le plus important
c'est en violet le groupe ensemble
l'ancienne majorité présidentielle 230
députés il en avait trois cent quarante
six c'est donc une baisse est très
importante pour la majorité
présidentielle qui est très loin de la
majorité absolue qui je vous le rappelle
était à 289 sièges le deuxième groupe le
plus important c'est celui de la nuque
avec 149 député jusqu'ici il y avait une
soixantaine de députés de gauche dans
l'hémicycle ensuite on trouve l érudit
et divers droite avec 76 députés il en
avait 119 c'est une baisse mais on peut
dire que la droite ce soir tout de même
limite la casse enfin une entrée très
importante de députés du rassemblement
national dans l'hémicycle ils seraient
85 selon nos estimations
jusqu'ici ils n'étaient que 8 clément
est ce que vous êtes en mesure de nous
donner maintenant le rapport de force au
sein de chaque alliance alors on va
commencer avec le groupe ensemble et ses
230 sièges là c'est la république en
marche des manuels macron qui a le plus
de sièges 158 députés ensuite on
retrouve le modem de françois bayrou
avec 45 sièges ensuite le parti horizon
d'edouard philippe 27 sièges
et pour la nuit et pour la nuque le
premier groupe vous allez le voir c'est
la france insoumise avec 81 3 sièges
c'est une progression très
impressionnante jusqu'ici il n'y avait
que 17 députés insoumis dans l'hémicycle
ensuite on retrouve europe ecologie les
verts avec 27 députés puis des
socialistes qui serait 26 jusqu'ici ils
étaient 28 c'est donc un chiffre stable
à pareil pour le parti communiste qui
compterait 13 députés jusqu'à
aujourd'hui il n'en comptait 15
latrille on voit que les choses évoluent
d'heure en heure de là à changer le
rapport de force général vous une petite
annonce marc nom de macron n'aura pas la
majorité absolue c'est certain en
revanche ça aura un impact effectivement
on l'a dit sur la présidence de la
commission des finances puisque ça peut
évoluer entre la france soumise erasmo
mentionnait alors est ce que c'est une
règle constitutionnelle ou est ce que
c'est un usage c'est un usage voilà mais
c'est un usage vous les yeux nicolas
sarkozy qui l'avait alors quand ça
s'installe c'est très difficile de
revenir dessus parce que ça va bien les
oppositions passion ce soit 10 url de
cette présidence ça va être le tollé on
va accuser véritablement la majorité a
dans les faits c'est très propre
impossible de ne pas réserver au premier
gros d'opposition on a un tel qu il est
d usage je crois qu'il faut préserver
les usages c'est pas parce que le
principal parti d'opposition vous
déplaît profondément que vous devez le
priver de ce qui est devenu changer les
règles de l'art et un usage des mots
creux ce qu'on avait compris et c'était
que dans l'hypothèse où danube à arriver
en tête était le premier parti
d'opposition
emmanuel macron se réservait le droit de
choisir partie par partie et donc
pourquoi pas donner la présidence à un
socialiste ou un communiste valérie
rabault si elle est réélue ce soir
connaît bien les finances mais là les
choses changent avec le rassemblement
national qui devient la première force
politique
d'opposition en tête oui il ya plusieurs
points qui vont rendre cette cette scène
et ce moment très très très utiles et
pour nous de la matière première pour
comprendre certains comportements
politiques tout d'abord il faut rappeler
que ces issues de la révision des
conditions de 2008 hees a entraîné un
changement du règlement de l'assemblée
nationale en 2009 et que dit ce
règlement une chose très très simple
c'est que la présidence de la commission
des finances et est accordé aux groupes
d'opposition
on ne précise pas le premier le deuxième
le troisième est donc la pratique lusage
a consisté à donner au principal groupe
de surinterpréter moment
il ya un vote il y à un vote pour cette
présidence et la pratique et non pas le
règlement la pratique conduisait à ce
que la majorité ne participe pas à ce
vote mais ce n'est pas obligatoire donc
on peut tout à fait imaginer que les
députés de la majorité décide de
participer à ce vote sauf que comme vous
est-ce que ça créerait une crise
institutionnelle ou en tout cas une
crise politique à l'assemblée nationale
non parce que d'une certaine manière le
règlement ne l'interdît pas le règlement
ne l'interdît pas et si on dit que ce
soir c'est un chambardement total au
palais bourbon alors les pratiques
peuvent elles aussi accompagner ce
chambardement vincent martini ya
effectivement le poste de la présidence
de la commission des finances mais il ya
aussi la questure il ya aussi des
vice-présidences tout cela pourrait
revenir à des députés du rassemblement
national sa veux dire que le
rassemblement national qui n'était pas
présent à l'assemblée nationale aurait
beaucoup beaucoup de pouvoir demain dans
cette oui mais là encore appartement
parle d'usagé et surtout il faut prendre
en compte un deuxième élément c'est que
le parti qui est en compétition que leur
absence nationale là et les filles est
en est inséré dans une coalition à ce
titre-là cette coalition peut se serrer
les coudes pour obtenir un certain
nombre de députés on n'a pas la fille
toute seule 1 alors que l'assemblée
nationale mais si chacun a son groupe
après à l'assemblée nationale vous votez
en sa tombe devient résidence quand on
sait que l'expérience montre que le
groupe est né fille s'est emparée de
tous les leviers de pouvoir possible à
l'assemblée nationale on les a vus
travailler dans des commissions dans
tête des munitions d'information poser
des questions beaucoup moins le
rassemblement national est ce qu'il
pourrait laisser ce pouvoir de côté et
être dans l'opposition va dire théâtrale
sachant que voilà il ya déjà 17 députés
el fitr est formé et qui veulent
utiliser ce pouvoir là est ce que est ce
que c'est au fond la balle est dans leur
camp à eux au rassemblement national
enfin ce qui est sûr c'est que l'arrivée
massive de députés du rassemblement
national sa veux dire qu'il y aura une
arrivée massive de députés rn novices
pour la plupart d'entre eux ils sont
quasiment tous prime aux élus il faut se
rappeler qu'en 1986 quand y en avait une
quarantaine une grande partie venaient
d'autres partis que le front national à
l'époque donc il y avait des gens qui
avaient une forme d'expérience là c'est
pas le cas du tout en même temps je
pense que je serais surpris que la
direction du rassemblement national
n'est pas anticipé ce qu'on est en train
de dire et ne soit pas le rôle en train
de parler en train de réfléchir à ce qui
va se passer dans les prochains en tout
cas c'est marine le pen qui sera la
présidente de ce groupe à l'assemblée
nationale contrairement joli conte -
longchamp qui a décidé de ne pas se de
ne pas se représenter
c'est une rampe de lancement elle qui
avait pour l'instant laissé entendre
qu'elle pourrait ne pas rempiler pour
2022 oui bien sûr où on voit bien que la
période d'hésitation qui a été celle de
marine le pen juste après sa défaite du
second tour de la présidentielle
jusqu'aux législatives où il avait
tellement intégré les schémas qu'elle
disait au fond balle président aura sa
majorité c'est pas la peine on fera du
témoignage là ils font plus que du
témoignage donc ça l'a ramené à un
certain principe de réalité qu'est la
réalité du moment de l'instant de la
conjoncture et bien sûr elle peut
devenir maintenant la principale
représentante de l'opposition alors que
quelque part depuis des semaines et des
semaines jean-luc mélenchon l'avait
totalement privé de ce rôle jean luc
mélenchon ne sera pas l'assemblée
nationale donc pour marine le pen si l
on peut lui faire confiance si elle gère
bien ce groupe important de 80 et
quelques députés c'est à nouveau oui une
rampe de lancement et attention à un
personnel parlementaire qui donnerait la
pression de priver de l'essentiel de ses
prérogatives issus du texte ou de l'usaj
qui tenteraient de priver le
rassemblement national de cela une fois
plus ça mettra le rassemblement national
dans la position de victime et dieu sait
s'ils rassemblement national sait à
merveille on retourner le stigmate
puisque effectivement les élèves ont 76
sièges il en avait une centaine sous la
précédente législature et aurélien par
des le secrétaire général des
républicains
été triomphalement réélu ce soir vous
êtes à ses côtés stéphane et des pierres
à cahors dans le lot
aurélien pradié vous avez été réélu avec
65% des voix vous avez réussi votre
second paris pour faire élire député de
droite dans une circonscription plutôt à
gauche faire réélire en vérité ce qui
était le plus difficile oui c'est un je
pense que ce qui s'est passé dans l'eau
c'est une vraie leçon d'abord un succès
de participation les lotoises et les
toits sont beaucoup aller aux urnes je
pense qu'on a mené une campagne ici qui
a intéressé nos concitoyens et puis un
score massif 65% quasiment 25% c'était
inespéré dans une terre qui
politiquement est une terre de
reconquête il ya une première élection
certains pensaient que c'était une
erreur de l'histoire aujourd'hui on est
en train d'écrire l'histoire dans ce
département mais je pense que les leçons
d'une droite populaire qui réussit dans
un département comme le nôtre sont des
leçons qu'on peut exporter au niveau
national est ce que vous êtes candidat à
la présidence du groupe l'est
républicain ou au parti des républicains
d'abord ce soir je suis député à nouveau
député en faire une étape après l'autre
une haie après l'autre question c'est
pas les postes mais si votre question
est de savoir s'il nous faut refonder
totalement la droite et si ma génération
et les uns les autres on y prendra notre
part évidemment je peux dire que je
reviens à l'assemblée nationale dès
mardi absolument déterminé à ce que ma
famille politique soit rénovée du sol au
plafond du sol au plafond le groupe
ensemble la majorité présidentielle n'a
pas de majorité ce soir qu'est-ce que ça
va changer et rassembler ça va changer
le fonctionnement même de l'assemblée
nationale manuel maquereau a joué avec
le feu depuis cinq ans cette situation
c'est sa situation c'est lui qui l'a
provoqué et alternativement il a cherché
à se sauver la peau politique en jouant
avec l'extrême droite avec l'extrême
gauche bien voilà désormais il à
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche
massivement à l'assemblée nationale
qu'il gère cette situation qu'il a créé
lui-même quel va être le rôle des
républicains est ce que vous pouvez être
pivot on a entendu avant le second tour
avant le premier des gens des
républicains dire il faudrait se co se
coaliser avec emmanuel macron gouverner
avec la majorité non non non non et non
et si certains veulent le faire pendant
être brutal qu'il se barre et qu'ils y
aillent mais ça suffit on va pas
reproduire là dans les cinq ans qui
viennent ce que nous avons pu vivre les
mois dernier donc les choses sont
claires dès la semaine prochaine on
reconstruit une famille politique de la
droite républicaine indépendante et
libre et aucun pacte possible évidemment
sur chacun des textes on feront jour à
notre rôle de défendre les françaises et
les français
c'est certainement pas le moment d'aller
pactiser avec emmanuel macron il faut
sortir de ces logiques là qui ont pourri
non seulement les républicains depuis
cinq ans mais on pourrit notre vie
démocratique mais est-ce que vous
pourrez avoir un rôle groupe l'est
républicain était le premier groupe
d'opposition désormais vous êtes le
troisième groupe vous serez derrière la
nu derrière le rassemblement national
vous ne pourrez pas vous faire entendre
est ce que vous pensez vraiment que
lannux et leur assemblée nationale sont
capables de défendre les français non
ils sont capables de hurler sens capable
de faire du bruit dans l'émission en
tout cas ils seront assez nombreux pour
être plus important que vous à
l'assemblée oui ils seront beaucoup plus
nombreux pour faire beaucoup plus de
bruit mais nous ne sommes pas des
hurleurs nous sommes partis de
gouvernement à reconstruire à rebâtir et
et nous ferons la différence la
différence entre ceux qui font du
spectacle à l'assemblée nationale ce qui
bordaient liseron notre démocratie est
ce comme nous qui voulons tracer une
voie un chemin d'une droite populaire
ici nous avons parlé des sujets qui
concernent les français durant ma
campagne j'ai parlé de mon handicap je
parle d'écologie j'ai parlé de tous ces
sujets dans la droite ne parle plus
depuis des années car désormais il va
falloir que la droite en parle et
qu'elle se rebaptise tout vous dire je
trouve que c'est une aventure
enthousiasmante
merci beaucoup d'avoir été à nos côtés
voilà aurélien pradié extrêmement clair
ce soir surtout pas d'alliance ou de
contrat de gouvernement avec emmanuel
macron à ceux qui seraient tentés je
cite qu'ils y aillent et qu'ils se
barrent le message est très clair oui
c'est ce qu'on était en train de dire
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que on a on
part du principe que c'est évident que l
air pactisent ray avec la majorité
présidentielle en réalité on voit bien
qu'en tout cas il y aura et des
divisions très forte au sein des
républicains ou peut-être même pas de
division un refus aussi clair que celui
et aurélien pradié n'est pas sur la
ligne wauquiez
il faut imaginer ce que va penser eric
ciotti est ce que vont penser laurent
wauquiez que c'était de cette alliance
qui pourrait être impossible donc on
pourrait se retrouver en situation quand
même de ce qu'on appelle ailleurs un
parlement suspendu c'est à dire une
incapacité à trouver une majorité quelle
qu'elle soit et en effet des majorités
d'un moment à un autre mais ce qui est
intéressant ce que disait à la fin
aurélien pradié c'est quand même l'échec
aussi des manuels macron il faut bien le
souligner quand même sur emmanuel macron
était lui en 2017 et réélu en disant il
faut qu'on fasse barrage à l'extrême
droite pour commencer et puis ensuite ce
qu'il a appelé l'extrême gauche après on
peut discuter titulature dans le cas de
la nuque mais en tout cas c'est un échec
total puisque l'extra matt n'a jamais
été aussi fort dans ce pays il faut
quand même le répéter martial foucault
on a vu une opposition constructive yves
des républicains pendant cinq ans est ce
qu'aujourd'hui ils peuvent refuser un
accord de gouvernement trouver des
alliances sur certains textes on sait
que typiquement sur le pouvoir d'achat
ou sur les retraites leurs avis sont
parfois très proches
les déclarations de rien pradier pour
moi sont à lire en termes de survie du
parti des républicains cette décision si
elle était confirmée pour tous les
députés élus les républicains de ne pas
participer à une aventure
gouvernementale avec avec emmanuel
macron c'est une question tout
simplement contrairement au parti
socialiste il ya cinq ans de survie pour
les républicains il a raison c'est vrai
que la survie des lrg de cette alliance
rejoint la république en marche c'est la
fin du parti c'est la fin du parti ni
c'est aussi un peu la fin de la
république en marche non il ya quand
même deux cents 200 seront acceptables
c'est peut-être la fin la fin d'une
histoire
république en marche derrière emmanuel
macron on se pose des questions est-ce
que la république en marche peut
survivre à emmanuel macron dans dans
cinq ans on a bien vu que pendant cinq
ans ce parti politique était quand même
absent absent dans le débat le chef de
la république en marche n'a pas
participer finalement à cette doctrine
de ses caisses que le maquereau nisme
mais je reviens sur les ailes à ercis et
l'air décidé de ne pas participer un non
ferme à 7 à ce gouvernement ça veut dire
aussi que contrairement à ce que l'on
disait au lendemain des élections
présidentielles avec ce score valérie
pécresse on est près de 80 députés c'est
pas rien à 80 députés donc ça veut dire
que ce parti quand on voit 80 députés
l'air 82,5 député est reine et 83
députés elle est fille finalement ces
trois groupes équivalent qui sont en
train déjà de se projeter sur les
prochaines échéances électorales et
participer à une aventure
gouvernementale serait une manière
finalement de scier la branche sur
laquelle emmanuel macron voudrait
installer les textes où le président ne
peut pas se représenter
ce qui évidemment compliquer encore plus
la donne on va repartir du côté de
clément pérou pour une nouvelle série de
résultats c'est à vous que les manceaux
myriam et je vous propose d'abord de
nous concentrer sur les résultats de
plusieurs ministres on commence avec
brigitte bourguignon regarder la
ministre de la santé est battu pour un
souffle 49 9% des voix dans la
circonscription dans la sixième
circonscription du pas de calais ça
c'est vraiment jouer à quelques voix
près maintenant allons dans l'ardèche
voir pour le ministre du travail olivier
dussopt opte lui par contre est réélu
député
58,8 % des voix un autre ministre cette
fois marc fesneau le ministre de
l'agriculture dans la première
circonscription du loir et cher il est
lui aussi réélue 56 4% pour marc fesneau
maintenant allons voir deux candidats du
rassemblement national d'abord marine le
pen ancienne candidate à l'élection
présidentielle largement réélu dans le
pas de calais 61% des voix toujours dans
le pas de calais le député sortant et
rennes bruno bilde est réélu 56 2% des
voix il devance le candidat de la nuque
jérôme darras et pour finir trois
candidats de la nuque d'abord en seine
maritime le communiste sébastien jumel
est réélu il obtient 57 8% des voix dans
sa circonscription de dieppe ensuite en
seine-et-marne olivier faur le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste passe
largement 64 4% des voix il est réélu
enfin dans le tarn et garonne valérie
rabault socialiste de la nuque elle
était la présidente du groupe socialiste
à l'assemblée nationale eh bien elle est
réélue
58,2 % des voix pour m merci clément
perreault pour ces nouveaux résultats
nous partons tout de suite dans le
calvados en normandie où se trouve
hélène bonduelle chez la première
ministre hellène vous avez des résultats
définitifs maintenant
exactement maintenant on le sait
isabelle borne la première ministre est
donc élu ce soir vous le savez c'était
un enjeu important parce qu'elle
risquait de perdre sa place à matignon
mais le score est assez serrée 1 52 46 %
pour elisabeth bornes 47 54 % pour son
adversaire de la nuque noé gauchard le
score est assez serré dans une terre
pourtant macro nist l'ancien député
public en marche en 2007 avait été élu
avec 14 points de plus mais le pari est
gagné ce soir pour elisabeth bunton
bornes pardon dans cette circonscription
c'est donc son suppléant tout à l'heure
qui s'est exprimé devant les militants
nous disent on est en disant militant
maintenant il y a du boulot même si nous
avons gagné puisque vous le savez c'est
lui qui prendra le siège de député à
l'assemblée nationale elisabeth borne à
paris qui ne sera pas présente ce soir
physiquement à vire mais qui a choisi de
s'exprimer en visioconférence dans la
soirée face à ses militants
merci hélène hélène bonduelle depuis
vire dans le calvados où elisabeth
bornes ce soir c'est la première
ministre elle n'est pas dans son dans
son fief normand elle a été réélue
certes elle devrait déjà à l'heure qu'il
est il est 21h30 9 avr pris la parole
depuis depuis matignon on peut s'étonner
cela déjà ce qu'elle est affaiblie
une visioconférence avec ses militants
gaëtan elle gagne gagne mais enfin c'est
un score court 1 pour une femme première
ministre face à un candidat qui était
dans plus à atout jeune candidat de la
nuque donc ça n'est pas un score
formidable et d'autre part la première
ministre et comme toute la macro ni elle
a dû recevoir un coup sur la tête
et son absence jusqu'à maintenant sur
les ondes montre qu' il ya un peu de
désordre dans la capacité et sur quelle
ligne 1 les étoiles de la macro ni vont
intervenir ce soir parce qu'il doit y
avoir déjà entre eux un véritable débat
on imagine effectivement qu'elisabeth
bornes et sans doute en contact avec
emmanuel macron pour caler son
intervention est envisagé effectivement
l'avenir vincent martini wii dont
évidemment je pars me disait par exemple
thaler est ce qu'il ya une chance qu'ils
les bêtes bornes de sa de la place ça me
semble quand même assez difficile
d'autant plus s'il n'y a pas de contrat
de gouvernement à venir pour l air dans
les jours et les semaines qui viennent
a priori comme sacrifier sabres ministre
aussi rapidement ça serait quand même
acte est comme un aveu d'échec pour
emmanuel macron donc probablement ils
sont en train de réfléchir à ce qu'ils
vont faire une prise de parole du chef
de l'état est inimaginable ce soir
on déteste parler sous dans l'urgence
donc et puis en plus c'est vrai que ce
serait pas logique institutionnelle la
chef de la majorité parlementaire c'est
elle et zabeth bornes c'est tout à fait
légitime soit elle qui s'exprime
emmanuel macron pourrait s'exprimer dans
les jours qui viennent probablement mais
on sait aussi qu'il aime encore une fois
prendre le temps ne pas être pressé par
les événements allez on va partir à
présent dans l'essonne c'est un match
extrêmement serré dont on attend
impatiemment le résultat les amendes un
gars va vous êtes là où amélie de
montchalin essaye d'être réélu ce soir
absolument avis de gros temps ici à
massy je vous parle de l'orage qui
gronde mais également de la situation de
la ministre amélie de montchalin si elle
veut rester au gouvernement il faut
qu'elle gagne cette circonscription elle
était en retard au premier tour et la
situation s'annonce compliquée au second
nous n'avons pas encore de résultats
définitifs ici mais sachez que son
concurrent le l'ancien député socialiste
candidat de la nuque jérôme guedj lui a
annoncé sur les réseaux sociaux être en
tête sur une partie du dépouillement
dépouillement donc pas encore
définitives prise de parole de celle qui
fera sera peut-être encore ministre pour
quelques heures ou alors ce sera la fin
pour l disi 22 heures environ merci à
mon égard à nos partants dans le val de
marne à présent où se trouve marc au
pommier marco roxana maracineanu
l'ancien ministre des sports était en
ballottage défavorable au premier tour
effectivement brigitte et ici on attend
toujours impatiemment les résultats dans
cette septième circonscription du val de
marne il faut dire que les bureaux de
vote ont fermé tard à 20 heures qui va
remporter donc ce duel entre rachel kéké
candidate de la nuque et roxana
maracineanu l'ancien ministre des sports
d'emmanuel macron sur le papier les jeux
les sur le papier les jeux s'annoncent
serrées et selon quelques indiscrétions
et bien effectivement le duel serait bel
et bien serré on a quelques remontées
pour l'instant mais on reviendra vers
vous quand on aura des résultats un peu
plus clair merci beaucoup marco pommier
on attend paris aussi les résultats
paris clément bonne et stanislas guérini
mais d'abord on va partir à drancy en
seine saint denis où le sortant
s'appelle jean christophe lagarde il
tient à être réélu mais c'est difficile
il est en ballottage défavorable face à
rachel garrido vous suivez tout cela
pour lcp l'école akouédo
oui mais pour l'instant pas de résultats
définitifs encore il est un petit peu
tôt parce que je vous rappelle qu'en
seine saint denis comme dans les autres
grandes villes les bureaux de vote ont
fermé à 20 heures le dépouillement s'est
donc terminée tard ici on attend donc
les remontées des autres bureaux de vote
du département et les candidats je peux
vous le dire qu'il suivre la situation
de très près puisque le scrutin
s'annonce très serré un d'un côté le
sortant jean christophe lagarde 20 ans
en tant que député dans cette
circonscription en ballottage
défavorable
raquel garrido la candidate de la nuque
ce qui espère bien lui ravir son siège à
l'assemblée résultats dans quelques
dizaines de minutes on l'espère
merci nicolas quad ou pascal perrineau
il ya un paradoxe quand même ce soir
c'est qu'elisabeth borne est réélu et
que finalement ce serait peut-être plus
la personne de la situation pour
présider d'ériger en tout cas ce
gouvernement
alors que certains ministres battus vont
vont partir en effet le gouvernement et
la macro ni est tout de même très
largement endommagé ce soir
déjà c'était une force politique qui en
dehors du président n'avait pas les
premiers rôles évident mais alors là ils
sont tombés au champ d'honneur déjà donc
ils sont très démuni certainement mais
ensuite tout dépend de la discussion qui
doit avoir lieu en ce moment entre le
président et la première ministre quelle
stratégie va être suivi
pas d'accord par exemple avec un groupe
du type elle est rude et bien il va
falloir à ce moment-là dégager des
majorités d'idées ça demande un premier
ministre ou une première ministre qui
soit extrêmement politique qui ai
l'habitude en effet du jeu parlementaire
et de la confection patiente de majorité
ça demande du temps sa demande de
l'entregent assad bayrou par exemple
culture parlementaire un françois bayrou
il connaît ils connaissent
madame bornes c'est pas sa spécialité
mais parfois les néophytes se met avec
talent à des métiers à des métiers
nouveaux et si ça n'est pas la majorité
d'idées on peut gouverner pendant un
certain temps avec des majorités d'idées
successives selon le centre de gravité
des projets de loi la nature du budget
c'est pourquoi pas eh bien il faudra
tout de même pensé un jour ou l'autre
si on évite la dissolution à une
cohabitation
relative plus stable avec un groupe
parce qu'on va pas aller chercher
mettons ils sont à 230 c'est tout même
très loin des 289 mais avec qui et c'est
ta valise y ont fait ce qu'on entendait
à coller à l'air mais ça se voyait pas
en tout cas rapproché sa majorité elle
est rude et y ait une fraction des l'air
avec les udi et le centre avec des
divers gauche voyez il n'y a pas
simplement là ma chronique qui peut être
et de droite et de gauche il peut y en
avoir d'autres aussi qui peuvent être de
droite et de gauche et se dire voilà on
va on va donner un coup de main et on va
monnayer au cas par cas ou avec un
accord un alan saltiel débauchages
individuels mais vous n'allez pas
débouché presque 60 personnes c'est
n'est pas possible le débauchage année
ils n'y arriveront pas ça c'est sûr
c'est pas la peine de commencer
ses
partitions texte on est là ce soir à
dire mais mon dieu négocier mais quand
monsieur choï scholz le celui qui va
devenir chancelier allemand patron du
spd se met à négocier avec les verts au
mondial et c'est à peu près la même
famille il négocie avec les libéraux les
libéraux croyez moi ça n'a rien de ceci
est une sculpture à la demande que nous
n'avons encore pascal perrineau d'accord
et mais jeudi il ya des circonstances où
la culture du compromis il faut
l'acquérir à 16h00 désordre le plus
total vincent martinez au fond on peut
regarder ce qui s'est passé à gauche
pendant pendant ces législatives cette
coalition alors qu'elle était peut-être
purement électorales mais en tout cas il
ya eu la tentative de se mettre d'accord
sur un certain nombre de sujets avec
énormément de nuances et elles sont de
taille c'est ça qui peut se passer
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron va recevoir
à l'elysée un certain nombre de
personnalités des chefs de parti la
droite pour négocier sur un peu projet
précis bâle a priori c'est ce qu'il va
faire oui en tout cas c'est ce que
j'imagine que c'est conseil général lui
dire de faire s'il n'a pas bu ma bulle
idée c'est à dire que dans les jours qui
viennent l'idée c'est qu'est ce qu'on
peut et est-ce qu'on peut former ou pas
une majorité absolue à ce stade je pense
que c'est très difficile à dire lui-même
ne le sait pas c'est pour ça que pascal
perrineau l'a dit tout à l'heure il va
opérer une série de consultations il va
même probablement recevoir les leaders
de chaque groupe parlementaire y compris
dans la nuque baisse pour discuter avec
eux de l'état du pays et de se trouver
une solution par le haut comme doit le
faire le chef de l'état garant des
institutions
donc ça s'est réveillée tour projet
réforme pas réforme l'âge de la retraite
la
délégation générale c'est qu'est ce que
vous êtes prêts à voter en général est
ce qu on pourrait travailler ensemble à
mon avis l'entretenir et la coalition à
l'allemande c'est vraiment très précis
oui absolument mais je crois qu'en
france ne sera pas exactement comme ça
par exemple je pense que l'entretien que
jean luc mélenchon si c'est lui qui
devait être choisi pour être force
d'opposition serait assez rapide
l'entretien que marine le pen
probablement également en revanche
vraiment y ait des entretiens qui vont
ceux qui vont se prolonger un peu plus
christian jacob vient de s'exprimer et
dit que il ferme la porte à tout pacte
de gouvernement ça veut dire que la
coalition avec les républicains semblent
à ce stade très très compromis mais
c'est très mal parti ça c'est sûr elle
attend encore une fois on est dans une
situation tout à fait nouvelle je répète
d'une forme de parlement suspendu dans
lequel on ne sait pas comment ça va se
passer et vous parlez de la culture
politique française il faut remonter
bien loin en arrière pour pouvoir
trouver une situation identique cette
situation elle fait qu'effectivement on
ne pourra pas gouverner tel convoi
l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui s'il
faut chercher des négocier ce faire des
négociations chercher des accords sur
chaque texte on va avoir quand même un
élan réformateur qui va être très très
limité et finalement une france qui va
se réformer à à pas lents
on a connu cela un deux présidents ont
eu
deux septennats qualifier deux
septennats
d'immobilisme de d'une période perdu
l'intérêt des réactions et pour autant
on n'était pas dans une situation
d'absence de majorité mais situation de
cohabitation pour pour les deux
je reviens un instant quand même sur les
scénarios à venir
imaginons que tous les toutes les
formations politiques
finalement claque la porte à l'idée même
d'un pacte de gouvernement ça veut pas
dire pour autant que le président la
république ne peut pas trouver une
majorité ni relative ou absolue une
majorité pour avancer sur un certain
nombre de textes mais qu'est ce qui va
se passer moi je pense qu'il faut
regarder aussi de l'autre côté est ce
que la coalition d opposition un sens
politique est-ce que systématiquement le
rassemblement national voudra se joindre
à la à la nuque pour s'opposer à
l'assemblée vous allez
la france sa sélection nationale ont
voté contre par exemple sanitaires c'est
une situation qui peut être
instrumentalisé politiquement consistant
à dire vous voyez finalement ce pays
serait polarisé entre eux les radicalité
contre le progressisme le populisme
contre une forme de social démocratie et
quand vous parliez tout à l'heure de
cette absence de culture du compromis
d'une certaine manière quand on voit la
composition des groupes même si mes
ailes macron consulte beaucoup des chefs
de partis je suis pas certain qu'il
arrive à imposer à l'ensemble d'entre
eux l'idée que le pays va sortir de
l'immobilisme par une réinvention de la
social démocratie avec une culture du
compromis ça je crois qu'on est un stade
en 2022 ou cette idée du compromis c'est
l'antithèse de ce qu'on observe depuis
la campagne présidentielle
et cette campagne nous cette non
campagne législative pascal perrineau
emmanuel macron a lancé le conseil
national de la refondation idée pour
l'instant qui devrait se concrétiser au
lendemain de ces législatives est ce que
c'est une bonne idée aujourd'hui
elle a encore tout son sens et est ce
qu'elle peut permettre de mettre autour
de la table tous tous ces partis qui
finalement ne peuvent pas s'entendre
aujourd'hui écoutez moi j'ai exprimé un
certain scepticisme par rapport à cette
proposition pour plusieurs raisons
première raison il faut faire attention
quand on manie des symboles aussi fort
que le cnr conseil national de la
résistance faut être à la hauteur de ce
qui a été une institution comme le cnr
deuxièmement il faut bien voir que si
vous voulez ça fait parti d'un aspect du
président de la république qui considère
qu'un des moyens de répondre à la crise
de la démocratie représentative
c'est de développer de multiples
initiatives de démocratie consultative
ou participative alors on a eu le grand
débat national
on a eu la convention sur le
réchauffement climatique et maintenant
on a le cener pourquoi pas sachant que
la démocratie participative n'a jamais
été la réponse que l'on croit miracle à
la crise de la démocratie représentative
et d'autre part faut pas avoir une
utilisation politique de la démocratie
participative
or quand vous regardez le grand débat
national la convention le moins qu'on
puisse dire ça a servi avant tout à
faire de la communication présidentielle
ça n'a pas été de véritables expériences
de démocratie participative
non parce que le président de la
république au delà de ce que vous
considérez j'imagine un peu comme un
outil de communication voire un gadget
considère que nous sommes à une période
comparable à celle de l'après guerre où
il faut tout reconstruire il ya quand
même une guerre aux portes de l'europe
il ya quand même le réchauffement
climatique et l'inflation qui touche le
porte monnaie de tous les français dans
un contexte comme celui là vous parlez
de coalition est-ce qu'il est imaginable
te parler d'union nationale est ce qu
est ce que c est ce que c'est foutu
folie ou est-ce que ça correspond voilà
le cnr après tout cette période existait
mais est ce que vous avez entendu ces
sujets pendant la campagne j'ai pas
entendu des propositions extrêmement
engageant
mobilisatrice pour se dire qu
effectivement tout est à reconstruire et
que la république en marche ou la
coalition ensemble à une série a
simplement de propositions parce que on
peut être dans le récit certes parfois
d'ailleurs quand on est dans le récit on
ne sait plus si on est dans le politique
ou d'algues ou de la communication mais
ensuite il ya une demande très forte de
pouvoir décliner en proposition avec un
échéancier sans rentrer dans des
promesses aussi nombreuses et parfois
très détaillée de partis politiques mais
il n'y a pas eu cela donc évidemment le
résultat des secouristes hâtives c'est
une demi surprise par rapport au fait
que des électeurs se sont mobilisés
contre et mâcon considérant que ces
propositions on peut les retrouver de ci
de là dans des déclarations ou des
grandes des grands moments de
communication mais ça ne fait pas ça ne
fait pas un programme et puisqu'on
parlait du cnrc nerfs c'est un programme
c'est un vrai programme justement de
sortir deux du conseil national de la
refondation avec une sorte de programme
commun est une sorte de gouvernement
d'union vous en pensez quoi c'est
improbable en réalité là c'est pas une
question de culture particulièrement
française c'est juste que la nature même
des coalitions ou des groupes qui
aujourd'hui rentrer à l'assemblée en
grand nombre ont été seuls d'une
opposition frontale au président de la
république ils ont aussi des arguments
pour le faire puisque le président a
rappelé que leur a pas fait de cadeau ni
aux uns ni aux autres et qu' ils sont
sûrs justement dit d un antagonisme
auprès du rassemblement national pour
une logique anti système qui fait que je
vois pas comment il pourrait participer
même avec une série de votes à des
formes d'émergence de consensus
nationaux et dans le cas de la coalition
de la nuque par l'idée justement qu'il
fallait sanctionner par un troisième
tour qui s'est pas révélée tél la
majorité présidentielle donc c'est quand
même assez difficile d'imaginer qu'en
quelques jours on passe à cet élément là
tout simplement pour des raisons de
cohérence vis-à-vis des électeurs les
députés ils sont pas complètement
indépendant des gens qui les ont portés
aux responsabilités auront en tout cas
au parlement donc ils vont être un peu
obligé d'en tenir compte marcel foucault
oui un autre point aussi on a beaucoup
parlé des institutions on a quand même
renversé ou inverser le calendrier
électoral on a un mode de scrutin
majoritaire qui était censé assurer la
stabilité sous la vème et on se retrouve
2022 avec ces modifications ces
changements et qui nous obligent à
imaginer échafauder des scénarios de
gouvernement n'a
d'armes parlementaire on a le 49-3 même
s'il est limité aujourd'hui on a le
l'article 44 pour le vote bloqué il ya
la possibilité de faire des décrets est
ce qu'on peut imaginer qu emmanuel
macron qui est quand même réformateur
c'est le dernier quinquennat donc il va
vouloir laisser une trace dans
l'histoire est ce qu'on peut imaginer
qu'il ira à marche forcée
s'il veut le pays dans la rue avec ses
instruments je pense qu'il va peut-être
y réfléchir deux fois avant de les
dégainer le parlement vient d'être élu
il ne peut pas se mettre par
l'utilisation de toutes les armes de ce
qu'on appelle le parlementarisme
rationnalisé dur qu'on a fortement
limité en réformant l'article 49 alinéa
3 il ne peut pas j'allais dire
violé les majorités au parlement et donc
c'est l'immobilisme qui guette
finalement les cinq prochaines années y
avoir sur le terme d'un contrat il peut
y avoir l'élaboration de majorités
d'idées puisque en effet la logique du
compromis parlementaire quand on regarde
les premières réactions semblent pas
être le scénario le plus probable il
peut on peut essayer de fonctionner on
verra combien de temps ça fonctionne
avec des majorités d'idées et des
contrats d'objectifs clairs sur lequel
on peut dégager des majorités d'idées
successives et pas forcément avec les
mêmes forces à chaque fois on va
s'arrêter là on sent que les jours voilà
qui viennent vont être déterminants on
va suivre les consultations à l'elysée
en attendant 22 heures on nous donne cet
horaire pour une première prise de
parole de de la première ministre
elisabeth bornes réélu bien bien
silencieuse jusqu'à présent ce soir
merci infiniment martial foucault
vincent martini vous restez avec nous
pascal perrineau ainsi que ainsi que
pierre latry il y bientôt 22 heures
merci à vous de nous avoir accompagnés
merci brigitte merci mejia je vais vous
quitter pour une émission commune
effectivement sur france info tv vous
pouvez rester sur lcp entre 11h et mimi
n'offrons antenne commune avec des
invités politiques mais pour l'heure et
bien nous retrouvons clément perreault
pour de nouveaux résultats oui on
commence justement avec isabelle borne à
la première ministre qui devrait donc
bientôt s'exprimer elle est élue dans la
seconde circonscription la 6e
circonscription pardon du calvados 52 4%
ce n'est pas une large victoire mais sa
passe pour elisabeth bornes au contraire
de richard ferrand regarder dans la
sixième circonscription du finistère
49,1 % le président de l'assemblée
nationale est donc battu ce soir c'est
l'une des grosses surprises vraiment de
cette soirée allons maintenant dans
l'oise pour voir les résultats et d'eric
woerth 54 3% pour lui ça se passe dans
la 4e circonscription je vous rappelle
qu'eric woerth était député les
républicains et qu'il est passé avec
ensemble il est donc réélu ce soir
toujours dans l'oise mais cette fois
dans la 2e circonscription
c'est un candidat du rassemblement
national l'ancien journaliste philippe
ballard qui s'imposent assez largement
55 8% des voix il devance il devance la
candidate d'horizon chanèze erban
44,1 % maintenant dans le nord un autre
candidat du rassemblement national qui
s'imposent ce soir c'était le député
sortant sébastien chenu proche de marine
le pen
57,1 pour cent dans le nord toujours la
circonscription voisine d'ailleurs des
nouvelles d'un ancien candidat à
l'élection présidentielle le communiste
fabien roussel il est réélu 54 5% pour
lui il de vente le candidat et rennes
guillaume lors 4 45 5% et pour terminer
dans le pas de calais pierre henri
dumont dlr s'impose avec 55 points 8 %
il devance le candidat du rassemblement
national
merci infiniment clément perreault
bienvenue à tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent
21h59 sur lcp soirée spéciale et les
élections législatives second tour
décryptage et analyse avec de nouveaux
d'invités que je vous présente dans un
instant mais je vous rappelle
l'information principale de la soirée
c'est un séisme électoral la majorité la
coalition présidentielle ensemble est
loin très loin d'atteindre la majorité
absolue ce soir avec 230 sièges selon
nos estimations ipsos sopra steria 149
pour la nuque de jean luc mélenchon 76
pour les républicains et des idées vert
à droite et 85 c'est un résultat très
important ce soir 85 sièges pour le
rassemblement national vous le voyez nos
envoyés spéciaux sont toujours fidèles
au poste on va les voir sur le terrain
nous sommes ce soir à bordeaux en
gironde en bretagne dans le lot et
garonne ou encore en ile-de-france dans
l'essonne en seine-saint-denis où dans
le val de marne je vous donne la parole
à tous nos envoyés spéciaux dès que vous
allez des résultats frais à nous
communiquer bonsoir roland cayrol pour
juin ravi de vous accueillir pour ce
second tour est politologue et expert
des sondages experts de la vie politique
depuis des années pascal perrineau est
resté avec nous professeur des
universités également politologue yves
thréard bonsoir on a hâte de vous
entendre ce soir éditorialiste au figaro
et catherine tricot merci de nous
retrouver ce soir sur lcp vous êtes la
directrice des éditions regarde nous
avait écoutés fort forcément vous avez
regardé de près les résultats fait sept
ans et isme c'est un coup de tonnerre
personne n'avait vu venir ce scénario ce
soir istres r écoutez si elle ses
fidèles au tempérament des français
parce que ce sont les anciens qui votent
à c'est pas donc les français ils sont
encore dans le dégagisme le dégagisme
qu'avait commencé en 2017 et les
français ont cette particularité c'est
de nous surprendre de scrutin en scrutin
c'est pas nouveau c'est depuis la nuit
des temps la surprise est de taille mais
la surprise est de taille comme la
surprise était de taille quand le
président m'a kron a été élu il ya cinq
ans comment vous comprenez ce qui s'est
passé c'est bien c'est très simple des
français sondés mécontents permanent
mais permanent et je trouve que
scrutin reflète assez bien le
quinquennal qu'on vient de vivre
quinquennat qui était chahuté qui a été
extrêmement chahutée les français il ya
eu l'épisode des gilets jaunes qui a
duré plus d'un an qui était quand même
l'expression d'un mécontentement d'une
colère sourde donc on n'arrivait pas et
que personne d'ailleurs n'a réussi à
décrypter vraiment tant elle était
diffuse après vous avez le problème des
retraites enfin la réforme des retraites
qui m'a montré que dans ce pays faire
une réforme c'était au combien compliqué
surtout quand cette réforme je dois le
dire est quand même assez mal expliquée
et elle l'était et puis après il ya eu
la crise sanitaire la crise sanitaire
qui s'est bien terminée mais
souvenez-vous la première année de la
crise ça a quand même été une succession
de ratés avec les masques avec conflit
n'est pas confiné ce qu'on devait
se faire vacciner ou pas ça a été
compliqué tout ça fait et tout ça pour
vous dire que on arrive là et j'oubliais
une non campagne qui a été orchestrée
par le président de la république karim
estimé que ça pouvait passer comme ça eh
bien les français non il faut qu'il
s'exprime et quand il s'exprime il
s'exprime pas comme on voudrait qu'il
s'exprime parce que normalement ce soir
vous devriez avoir une très forte
poussée en faveur de la nuque baisse
c'est pas le cas c'est le rassemblement
national contre toute attente si les
chiffres se confirment qui finalement va
être la grosse surprise de la soirée
troisième remarque si vous me le
permettez très court on n'arrête pas de
pester depuis pas mal de temps sur ce
mode de scrutin qui n'est pas qui
empêche une représentativité correcte de
la
population nationale est ce que font la
gênerait en temps de rassemblement
national pesté ce soir contre le contre
le mode de scrutin je doute qu'ils le
fassent alors je vous donne un autre
résultat avant de vous entendre parce
que j'ai hâte de vous entendre déjà sur
ce qui s'est passé avant de comprendre
comment emmanuel macron peut sortir de
ce qui pourrait être une forme d'impasse
politique ce soit patrick mignola a raté
la marche de peu de l'assemblée
nationale il est battu avec
49,1 % des voix dans sa circonscription
de savoie catherine tricot on poursuit
ce tour de table
comment comprenez vous ce qui s'est
passé ce soir c'est une demi surprise
puisque on savait avant le scrutin que
plus de 60% des français ne souhaitait
pas qu emmanuel macron et la majorité
absolue est donc en fait dans chaque
circuit chaque élection localement il y
avait deux bulletins de vote et
finalement ça s'est traduit par une
défaite souvent plus souvent qu'attendu
des candidats ce qui était du camp macro
nhien c'est à dire que quand on était
devant le choix les électeurs ils n'ont
pas soutenu emmanuel macron puisque ils
étaient majoritaires à la marconi disons
plutôt de gauche qui est davantage
sanctionnés dans l'est alors voilà et
c'est le deuxième point c'est le
deuxième a connu de tous ils sont tous
sanctionnés n'ont enfin je veux dire là
c'est je pense qu'ils prennent ils ont
ils prennent cher là on vient de voir
que c'était le c'est vrai l'élu du modem
président du réseau des
socialistes qui avaient enfin parce que
des images ont offert en christophe
castaner tout à fait les leaders qui
étaient connus mais parce qu'ils étaient
ceux qui venaient d'une histoire
politique
ils se prennent cher mais ce qui aussi
est notoire c'est qu'on a voulu pendant
cette campagne de tracer un trait
d'égalité entre la gauche réunie autour
de la nuque ps et l'extrême droite en 10
ans et les extrêmes et bien finalement
ça a produit son effet c'est à dire que
quand il ya eu des duels par exemple
entre la nuque ps et l'extrême droite
contrairement à ce qui était attendu
c'est bien souvent l'extrême droite qui
est sorti gagnant pourquoi parce que
notamment les électeurs aient l'air ont
fait le choix contre la nièce d'aller
soutenir le rn et marine le pen ce soir
si vous avez entendu sa déclaration
qu'est ce qu'elle dit elle dit la
recomposition est en cours c'est à dire
qu elle l est en train de prendre les
habits de zemmour c'est à dire que après
que mélenchon qui avait rejeté l'idée
d'union de la gauche
devant son résultat réussi à mettre tout
le monde dans
on
aura droit bien sûr elle est en train de
tenter de faire la même chose est en
tout cas de faire de d'assurer une
recomposition et elle bénéficie en ce
sens de ce qui vient de se passer c'est
à dire ce trait d'égalité entre la
gauche et l'extrême droite qui lui a été
profitable roland cayrol qu'est ce qui
s'est passé selon vous ce soir votre
analyse il s'est passé du clac une
claque quand même à se boit pas
prévisible
macron lui même a pris une claque et
c'est lui il a depuis trois semaines mal
gérée la campagne donc cette son échec
c'est son échec alors pourquoi
mon hypothèse ça va pas faire plaisir à
catherine mon hypothèse c'est que heu
mélenchon a été tellement présent cette
campagne
les médias ont tellement valoriser la
nuit baisse que un certain nombre
d'électeurs se sont dit non à sare
et il ya eu un coup de barre à droite
coup de barre à droite qui a profité aux
républicains et le rassemblement
national on a assisté réellement d'une
semaine à l'autre déjà le rassemblement
national avait marqué des points
incroyables dans un premier tour de
dénis jeambar plus de 2 millions 300
mille voix supplémentaire passée de 13 à
19% c'est une chose qu'il n'avait jamais
fait mais qu'on s'était dit or c'est pas
le problème de l'élection le problème
c'est la nuit place peyneau la nuque
baisse n'a pas marché elle ne fait pas
beaucoup mieux qu'eux elle fait même
moins bien que la gauche divisée avant
qu'il existe la nuque baisse donc le
problème c'est le coup de barre à droite
un vrai coup de barre à droite de
l'électorat à mon avis du à cette
omniprésence médiatique et politique de
la nuit baisse ça veut dire que les
reports selon vous les reports des
républicains très clairement non pas
forcément fonctionner très clairement
les larges pour cela je suis d'accord
ils ont plutôt choisi le camp de la
droite voire de l'extrême droite
lorsqu'il avait le choix ça veut dire ce
que aujourd'hui on est devant la
nécessité de la continuation de la
recomposition politique il n'y a pas
d'impasse dans une démocratie
parlementaire il n'y a pas d'impasse ya
forcément toujours des solutions comment
vous voyez les choses sont les scénarii
diesel à 50 y a qu'à regarder le min sik
la seule majorité possible et que l'âge
majorité sortante
s'entendre avec tout ou partie de la
droite république alors je sais bien
vous avez entendu christian jacob ce
soir voilà j'étais si j'étais christian
jacob je l'aurais même claqué plus
violemment encore ça s'appelle faire
monter les enchères
donc laissons monter les enchères et
voyons ce qui va se passer il n'y a pas
cinquante solutions jeu là à vrai dire
je ne dis pas ce que je souhaite moi
comme citoyen ça n'a aucune importance
mais comme observateur je ne vois pas
d'autre solution que celle là pascal
perrineau c'est intéressant cette cette
analyse au fond le pays alors je mets
des guillemets a pris peur face à la
dynamique où là nous
passons voilà son poids médiatique son
poing au siège c'est ça qui s'est passé
là la france se réveille de droite et de
droite de la droite aussi puisqu'on
comprend une forme de recomposition
possible la fameuse union des droites
écoutez ovale rdr est mort des filons
les dernières semaines vous êtes un
électeur de centre-droit de droite ou de
droite radicale ça vous fait une drôle
d'impression vous l impression qu on ne
parle jamais de vous c'est sans arrêt
macron mélenchon mélenchon macro 1,7 est
extrêmement imprudent cette affaire et
là il ya eu dans les urnes une vengeance
de c2c de ses électeurs deuxièmement si
vous voulez ce qui s'est passé avec le
phénomène mélenchon les excès également
de jean luc mélenchon fait que tout même
à gauche il s'est passé quelque chose
c'est pas le retour de l'union de la
gauche auquel on assiste avec la nuque
c'est le ralliement de toute une série
d'appareils de gauche pc ps europe
écologie les verts à la gauche radicale
lyon la gauche jusqu'à maintenant ça
s'arrêtait au pc ça n'allait pas plus
loin
donc il ya eu une radicalisation à
gauche comment voulez vous qu'ils aient
pas eu de radicalisation a droit en vous
un sens qu'il y est d'ailleurs d'accord
d'appareil parce que l r contrairement
au ps n'a pas passé un accord avec la
droite radicale et je crois qu'il y a eu
un phénomène véritablement de
radicalisation à gauche et de radier
l'organisation a donc très intéressante
analyse on va la poursuivre dans l'idée
de se demander que faire comment
dépasser ce qui n'est pas une impasse
d'après roland cayrol on va regarder
d'abord jean françois copé il a tweeté
ce soir et il explique que ça fait
longtemps depuis des semaines qu'il
répète qu'un pacte de gouvernement est
vital entre emmanuel macron et les
républicains a fait buter contre la
montée des extrêmes l'extrême gauche
comme l'extrême droite sont des dangers
absolue pour la france il incarne l'un
et l'autre violence tension et
sectarisation et on va voir ce que et
sectarisme pardonnez moi et on va voir
ce que ce que répond en quelque sorte
christian jacob le patron des
républicains
l'ailer ont obtenu de très bons
résultats ce second tour puisque nous
sommes dans la fourchette haute de
toutes les les prévisions qui est qui
était fait depuis depuis une semaine
nous serons vraisemblablement plus de
plus de 60 plus de 60 députés c'est un
échec
cinglant pour emmanuel macron qui pèle
le cynisme qui était qui a été le sien
d'avoir en permanence
instrumentaliser les instrumentaliser
les extrêmes pour ce qui nous concerne
ce qui concerne les républicains nous
avons fait campagne dans l'opposition
nous sommes dans l'opposition et nous
resterons dans l'opposition les choses
sont très claires ce sera comme nous
l'avons toujours fait une opposition
constructive mais une vraie opposition à
emmanuel macron qui aura tout détruit
son quinquennat aura été un échec total
et c'est ce qui amène ce résultat
aujourd'hui est très rare quand on
écoute ses deux hommes il ya deux lignes
finalement ce soir christian jacob qui
ferme la porte au moins officiellement
et jean françois copé qu'il ouvre en dix
ans négocions sur une coalition est ce
qu'on peut s'attendre à une forme de
chine de réflexion de réflexion les
têtes d'affiché du paysage politique de
ces derniers mois de ces dernières
années sont absentes de de l'assemblée
nationale puisque
monsieur la plupart des têtes d'affiché
de la majorité présidentielle ont été
battus et sa référente et chaque terrien
castaner mignola tout ça monsieur bayrou
n'est pas l'assemblée nationale monsieur
philippe n'est pas l'assemblée nationale
monsieur copé n'est pas l'assemblée
nationale monsieur jacob ne sera plus à
l'assemblée nationale et monsieur jacob
va même prendre sa retraite politique
donc ça va sa parole n'a qu'une valeur
tout à fait politique relative que le
respect que je lui dois aurélien pradié
qu'on a entendu qui vise la présidence
bien sûr
article 1 qui vise matignon il s'appelle
jean françois copé je n'ai pas la
confidence que ce qui est évident c'est
que depuis depuis longtemps il a flairé
le coup il a très bien vu qu' il n'y
aurait qu'une majorité relative aux
précédents haïk avait longtemps que
gerland serait compliqué que la france
deviendrait quasi ingouvernable et que
dit copé il dit mais si il veut
gouverner sans s'appuyer sur les
extrêmes ce qui serait quand même
d'ailleurs assez particulier il va avoir
besoin de nous et donc il va y avoir à
l'intérieur des républicains vous allez
avoir l'école près et l'école wauquiez
qui va évidemment pas sortir du bois
avant de nombreux mois parce qu'il va
attendre de voir comment tout ça ce dès
c'est quand ça se décante et puis vous
avez un homme qui est libre de parole
qui est libre d'actes qui s'appelle
jean-françois copé qui a été un peu
considérée plus rien à perdre s'il est
considéré par ses petits camarades du
des républicains alors que c'est un
champion est pour vous qu elisabeth
bornes ne peut pas rester à matignon je
n'ai pas dit ça peut-être on va voir ce
qu'elle fait il faut pour ça qu'elle
assume d'être la patronne de la majorité
c'est pas simple sauf évidemment avoir
entendu c'est ce que je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit
précédemment et notamment par pascal
perrineau dans l'heure qui précède c'est
qu'il faut être politique dans une
situation comme ça il faut faire de la
politique et c'est ce que disent c'est
ce que faisait parfaitement rocard quand
il était à la tête d'une majorité
relative en 1900 qui a été moins -
qu'appliquer bien moins compliqué que
que celle-ci catherine tricot comment
vous voyez les choses d'un point de vue
politique on y avoir un remaniement dans
la dizaine de jours qui viennent bon je
suis d'accord avec vous je pense qu
elisabeth bande ne paraît pas être
complètement la personnalité haddock
dans cette situation on avait voulu une
techno un peu sans odeur et sans saveur
politique mais pour conduire quelque
chose qui normalement devait rouler bon
ben ça va pas du tout rouler et je pense
qu'il va falloir imaginer une autre
solution moi ce qui me semble ce qui
vaille en effet y avoir une grosse
question du côté des nerfs sur la façon
de se sortir de cette situation et il ya
deux propositions qui sont sur la table
jean françois copé moi je pense qu'il
est en fait dans la droite ligne de
nicolas sarkozy quand sarkozy proposait
finalement intacte à emmanuel macron qui
était une au pea qui était une au pea de
la droite sur la république en marche en
disant bon ben finalement c'est c'est
nous qui allons prendre le lead
politique et on va clarifier les choses
et c'est la république en marche et le
nouveau nom de la droite bon ça
s'appellera plus les républicains mais
finalement comme et change de nom tout
le temps et ça s'appellera la république
en marche tous les trois ans à change de
nom ça sera à nouveau changement de nom
donc moi je pense qu'en effet qu'ils
avaient y avoir un débat stratégique à
l'intérieur de la droite pour savoir si
on maintient les républicains ou si on
fait une opé assure la république en
marche en perdition ça c'est une
question mais la deuxième question qui
est quand même beaucoup plus complexe à
mon avis et qui a pas de majorité
politique le pays ce n'est pas
simplement l'assemblée nationale qui a
un problème aux usa déjà mais ça se
confirme c'est à dire que là moi ce soir
par exemple ce qui me semble acquis je
ne vois pas comment une réforme des
retraites à 65 ans peut s'envisager il
n'y a pas du tout de possibilités
politiques ni à l'assemblée ni dans le
pays pour une telle réforme alors on va
vous entendre roland cayrol parce que
j'ai hâte de vous entendre sur ce sur ce
point qu'elle remaniement elisabeth
bornes un premier ministre de droit pas
de droite mais d'abord priorité aux
résultats avec une nouvelle série avec
clément pernot oui on commence en savoie
avec le président du groupe modem à
l'assemblée nationale patrick mignola
qui est donc battu c'est une des grosses
informations de cette soirée
49,1 % pour patrick mignola ensuite
allons en ille-et-vilaine florian
bacheliers premier questeur et député de
la république en marche et battu 42 %
des voix défaite cinglante pour florian
bacheliers ensuite à londres dans la
somme voir le score de françois ruffin
un des ténors de la france insoumise il
est assez largement réélu député
61% des voix donc pour françois ruffin
maintenant dans les pyrénées atlantiques
c'est un cas un peu particulier david
habib député sortant socialiste qui
n'avait pas fait partie de l'accord de
la nuque il s'est présenté en dissidence
pari gagnant pour david habib et
largement 66 5% pour lui maintenant dans
le pas de calais emmanuel blé riz est
élu député du rassemblement national il
était déjà élu mais dans une autre
circonscription il à changer de
circonscription mais il reste donc
députés 55 7% pour lui dans cette
circonscription proche de la ville
d'arras enfin toujours pour le
rassemblement national allons en moselle
avec la victoire de laurent jacot bélie
qui rentrent donc à l'assemblée
nationale c'est un des cadres du parti
52,4 % contre une candidate de la
françafrique merci infiniment clément
perreault roland cayrol la parole est à
vous comment vous voyez au fond cette
coalition avec la droite
franchement je n'en sais rien
parce que je ne lis pas dans le marc de
café et encore moins dans les stratégies
du président de la république doit lui
maintenant conduire une vraie stratégie
politique il a hésité beaucoup sur une
conduite à tenir depuis trois semaines
il a hésité sur la conduite de la fin de
campagne présidentielle il a hésité
entre les deux tours des législatives
je pense que ça lui a coûté
et je pense qu'il peut être à lui
maintenant de savoir où il veut aller et
je ne sais pas où il veut aller moi je
vois l'art et meetic l'arithmétique me
paraît être avec une assemblée tels que
il a pas beaucoup de choix qui lui faut
arriver à conquérir dans une majorité
nouvelle sur sa droite
peu importe ce que individuellement on
en pense ici les uns et les autres ça me
paraît une donnée alors est-ce qu'il
faut sacrifier elisabeth board pas
forcément pas forcément c'est une
occasion d'un profil politique c'est des
questions qui va être à l'assemblée en
permanence à discuter avec chacun des
groupes avec des députés
individuellement oui oui pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
faille absolument passer
la frontière de 2 d'un groupe qui grèce
quand même le groupe domine au nom de
l'assemblée nationale il ya une
légitimité dans le centre de gravité bas
ce que plus vers la droite ou le
versement gravité c'est parfois
également premier ministre pouvez vous
dire je suis quand même le groupe le
plus important de l'assemblée nationale
il est logique dans la logique
institutionnelle à la 5e il est logique
que la première ministre le premier
ministre soit quelqu'un issu de ses
rangs en revanche il faut faire une
composition du gouvernement et un
programme de travail parlementaire qui
agréent a suffisamment de députés de
droite pour qu'une entente soit possible
je crois pas je croyais déjà pas la
semaine dernière qu'on ferait la
retraite à 65 ans et à 64 j'ai déjà dit
que c'était évident on renoncerait à
l'âge légal un changement de l'âge légal
de la retraite je vais pas
le contraire cette semaine c'est encore
plus clair il y aura pas ça et tout le
monde le sait et m'accrocher à mon avis
depuis plusieurs semaines donc
il va falloir applique son propre
programme de et maintenant on discute on
discute avec les syndicats on discute
notamment avec la cfdt sur la retraite
qui a comme l'un des positions assez
ferme en ce moment on discute avec le
mouvement associatif avec les partis
politiques et avec les possibles alliés
de droite et je crois que voilà tout est
maintenant à faire de finesse politique
et sa solidité les enjeux de cette
élection là on entre dans moi je pense
pas que les mères panique mais je ne
pense pas qu'ils aient eu des
politiciens je pense qu'il ya eu une
politisation à sa manière qui est une
manière qui n'a pas été acceptée par la
majorité des français et donc il faut
prendre acte de sa et il faut en effet
repolitiser autrement alors je vous
donne les nouvelles estimations de notre
partenaire ipsos sopra steria le groupe
ensemble totaliserait 234 sièges alors
il ne faut pas se fier au tableau que
vous voyez là puisque ce sont des
estimations qui évoluent dans dans la
soirée donc le la majorité absolue est
toujours loin mais un peu moins loin à
55 sièges je viens de faire la
différence il va falloir quand même
n'est trouvé pascal perrineau alors
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire on a compris que voilà
c'est le début des grandes consultations
les états-majors la droite c'est le seul
scénario possible rien ne pourra se
faire sans les 55 alors ils sont ce soir
75 donc on peut trouver 55 républicain
il va falloir le trouver sur un contrat
de gouvernement ou au cas par cas alors
on peut imaginer la solution d'un
contrat de gouvernement sur lequel on
arrive à dégager
un ensemble d'accords qui amène 1,55
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup 1 mais
enfin regarder un pronom les résultats
76 républicain udi et centristes 21
divers gauche mais ce sont des gens qui
voient là macron je sais pas c'est pas
l'ennemi de classe
gauche s'est beaucoup énervé le
divers-gauche et beaucoup de filtres
amara qui sont plutôt proches oui mais
aussi des socialistes qui ont reflué bas
mais à bout mais y en a mais on convient
de parler de monsieur habib bien
présente à lui 4-4 diverses entre 12
autres voiliers c'est aussi ça c'est ces
gens qui voient la nation l'art dont la
radicalité donc vous nous d'exprimer
quelque chose de beau large que d'aller
gouverner gouverner à droite yves
thréard
c'est complètement il est dit on a on
n'a jamais vu une situation pareille non
mais
il est plutôt facilement oui se fait
sanctionner mais extrêmement durement
aux législatives il se fait sanctionner
par les deux extrêmes même si
effectivement je sois c'est la victoire
du rassemblement national mais si vous
voulez
on sentait que ce pays quand même était
il est quand même très difficile à
prévoir
il faut pas oublier quand même et 54 %
d'abstentionnistes aux siens sur
l'histoire n'a pas les langues vont
évidemment s'exprimer pendant le
quinquennat d'une façon ou d'une autre
dans la rue ou d'un mais est-ce que
c'est l'homme de la situation emmanuel
macron d'une coalition vous n'avez qui
gouverne seul vous avez la vitalité du
pouvoir est ce que il sait il saura
faire la fonction fait l'homme et les
circonstances font l'homme
je viens qui ont les vues jupiter il va
être obligé de se terrer vulcain vous
avez vu le 15 celui qui fait les
alliages et ben il va être obligé de
faire des alliages et tout comme madame
banque je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
roland ne naisse prison pas son procès
avant que ça commence elle peut très
bien se révéler être une femme justement
de compromis 22h30 la majorité ne s'est
pas encore exprimé ce souhait mais c'est
parce que c'est pas simple justement est
donc le président de la république peut
très bien trouver
une façon de gouverner ou une autre il
ya aussi quelque chose qu'on a oublié
c'est de gouverner par référendum alors
que proposent les retraites c'est aussi
une solution l'appel au peuple l'appel
au peuple pas uniquement sur les
retraites parce qu'on ne parle que des
retraites mais ça peut être aussi une
grande réforme qui porte sur l'écologie
le développement durable à une solution
qui dans le contexte extrêmement risqué
aussi mais évidemment mais gouverner
c'est un risque et il a eu même avec une
majorité écrasante
rendez vous compte qu'il a gouverné de
façon relativement paisible pendant un
an sur ces 52 qu'à cannes à un an la
première année où il a réussi d'ailleurs
à faire passer de réforme me semble-t-il
essentielles sur le code du travail et
sur la fiscalité le reste du temps son
son quinquennat n'a pas du tout
ressembler à ce qu'il souhaitait donc
faut faire attention peut-être qu'il
peut faire passer des réformes
michel rocard avait fait passer des
réformes à l'époque certes il y avait le
49-3 qui était une arme facile d'usagé
ils avaient moins besoin est-ce qu'on va
je crois qu'on est des plus faibles si
vous voulez trop il ya plusieurs
solutions la halle et plusieurs
solutions on va continuer à essayer de
réfléchir à cette recomposition comment
composer avec qui la droite les divers
gauche mais priorité au résultat une
nouvelle série avec les mon père beau
tout de suite pardonnez moi j'appelle
clément perreault qui va nous montrer le
nouveau visage de l'hémicycle avec nos
estimations
ipsos oprah steria réactualisé
exactement je vous propose maintenant de
découvrir quel pourrait être le visage
du nouvel hémicycle selon les toutes
dernières estimations actualisées de
notre partenaire ipsos vous voyez le
groupe le plus important et s'affiche en
violet c'est le groupe ensemble de la
majorité présidentielle 234 députés on
est très loin de la majorité absolue qui
serait à 289 sièges je vous rappelle que
lors de la précédente mandature il avait
trois cent quarante six députés c'est
donc une baisse considérable ensuite
vient la nuque à gauche vous le voyez en
rouge 141 députés là aussi là par contre
c'est une belle progression il avait
jusqu'ici une soixantaine de députés si
on prenait toutes les tendances de
gauche ensuite pour la droite
républicains et udi aurait 75 députés il
en avait 119 on peut dire que ce soir la
droite limite la casse enfin entrée
fracassante de très nombreux députés
rassemblement national regarder ce
chiffre il est encore en train
d'augmenter désormais on a une
projection à 90 députés du rassemblement
national je vous rappelle que lors de la
mandature précédente
ils n'étaient que huit ça veut dire que
ce soir d'après les estimations ipsos et
le rassemblement national qui est le
premier la première force politique
d'opposition est là et le détail peut
être clément pardonnez moi je l'oubliais
le détail par we are alliance myriam de
rentrer d'abord dans les détails du
groupe ensemble qui aurait donc je vous
le rappelle 234 députés là ce sont les
députés l'arrêt mende emmanuel macron le
parti des manuels macron qui seraient
les plus nombreux 162 député ensuite le
modem de françois bayrou 45 députés et
enfin horizon le nouveau parti des lois
philippe compterait 27 députés regardons
maintenant dans le détail le groupe de
la gauche unie le groupe tenue place et
la france insoumise qui serait en tête
avec 79 députés c'est important c'est
moins que le rassemblement national qui
je vous le rappelle aurait 90 députés
ensuite les écologistes et les
socialistes auraient chacun 25 députés
pour terminer les communistes auraient
12 sièges dans l'hémicycle merci
infiniment clément pernot pour ses
résultats affinés au sein même de chaque
bloc 4 entre nous je voulais faire un
petit commentaire sur cette
décomposition pas ce qu'elle est sans sa
petite importance parce que le premier
groupe d'opposition va avoir la
commission des finances à l'assemblée
nationale alors on en a parlé déjà là ce
qui n'est pas sans que j'y reviendrai
jamais non plus rassemblement national
si on respecte ce règlement c'est à
l'oreille c'est à dire c'est pour
tourner ce que j'allais dire que
j'allais dire c'est que c'est pas dans
le règlement mais c'est maintenant
acquis comme traditionnelles usage
depuis depuis nicolas sarkozy mais c'est
pas nécessairement le groupe le
majoritaire le groupe d'opposition de
l'abus fort oui c'est ce que je fais ce
que je veux dire c'est du règlement dit
que cette affaire devait être un groupe
qui s'est déclarée de bougies sont
d'accord donc ce que vous avez raison ça
pourrait l'ouvrir aux élèves ce qui
voudrait dire qu'il ne serait pas qui ne
serait pas énorme et et orl mais moi ce
que je voulais vous dire c'est qu'il ya
un détail dans le la répartition c'est
que les 21 je revienne sur notre
discussion tout à l'heure avec pascal
perrineau c'est que les 21 qui sont
divers gauche sont largement des
ultramarins qui ont eu le soutien de la
nuque mais c'est qu'ils disent qu'ils
vont être du côté de la nuque baisse
donc dans cela il y aura un certain
nombre d'entre eux qui possiblement
peuvent même renforcer le groupe elle
est fille pour lui permettre d'être le
premier groupe d'opposition qui au
pourrait avoir la commission des
finances à l'assemblée nationale
oui j'y tiens parce que j'ai été à les
rg texte je pense que dans la
crédibilisation avant la gaule la
présidence est très important et que ça
ne revienne pas au rassemblement
national ça me paraît vraiment très
important et par ailleurs je pense que
ça crédibiliserait las nubes qui amène
un procès en tout cas quoi on entend
l'argument fort habré aussi et qu' il
faut un vote il faut un vote pour
désigner élire d'une certaine manière le
président de la commission des finances
et alors ça c'est s'est ouvert mais
normalement la majorité ne participe pas
à ce vote ça n'est pas décrit c'est un
usage
peut-on imaginer
voilà un scénario où le président de la
commission des finances qui gère le
budget de l'état qui fait voter le
budget puisse être
de la france à son bide ou du
rassemblement national
c'était tout
permet tout cela mais politiquement
politiquement dès l'instant que celui
qui serait élu serait membre d'un groupe
qui se seraient déclarés d'opposition ça
correspond au règlement après tout
problème de discussion parce qu'elle
perd c'est vrai que jusqu'à maintenant
c'est parmi les interrompt la première
ministre a pris la parole on va
l'écouter tous ensemble ce soir la
situation est inédite
jamais l'assemblée nationale n'a connu
une telle configuration sous la vème
république
cette situation constitue un risque pour
notre pays au vu des défis que nous
avons à affronter
tant sur le plan national qu'à l'échelle
internationale
mais ce vote nous devons le respecter et
en tirer les conséquences
en tant que force centrale dans cette
nouvelle assemblée nous devons assumer
une responsabilité particulière
nous travaillerons dès demain à
construire une majorité d'actions
il n'y a pas d'alternative à ce
rassemblement pour garantir à notre pays
la stabilité et conduire les réformes
nécessaires
les sensibilités multiples devront être
associés et les bons compromis bâti afin
d'agir au service de la france
les français nous appelle à nous
rassembler pour le pays
depuis des semaines le gouvernement est
au travail et prend les mesures
nécessaires pour protéger chacun
demain nous devons amplifier et
accélérer notre action au service de
tous les français
dès cet été nous voulons prendre des
mesures fortes et concrètes
pour le pouvoir d'achat nous voulons
continuer à vous protéger et assurer
votre sécurité
au delà je suis certaine que nous
pouvons nous rassembler largement pour
le plein emploi
pour une transition écologique
ambitieuse
pour l'égalité des chances pour l'école
et la santé pour notre souveraineté
industrielles énergétiques et agricoles
avec le président de la république nous
allons oeuvrer dans le dialogue à
l'ecoute des françaises et des français
et de toutes les forces vives partout et
dans tous les territoires
j'ai confiance dans notre pays
confiance en chacun de nous et en notre
esprit de responsabilité
nous avons tout pour réussir et c'est
ensemble que nous y parviendrons
vive la république et vive la france
voilà trois minutes montre en main
d'allocutions de la première ministre
c'est un des fils ces résultats sont un
défi sur le plan national et
international construire une majorité
d'actions sans donner trop de détails
les mots de compromis à bâtir sont
prononcés avec les sensibilités
multiples associés sans dire lesquelles
que comprenez vous de ce discours ce
soir écoutez elle a ouvert la boîte à
mort elle a mis quelques mots
les uns derrière les autres et puis elle
nous sert un discours qui j'aurais pu
prononcer que vous auriez pu prononcer
et qui n'a pas une grande originalité ne
savent pas pour l'un que je peux
comprendre ça vient il faut d'abord il
faut tous ces résultats soit définitif
ça va se compter à l'unité près là
maintenant parce que justement
précisément c'est un peu compliqué donc
le discours devant la borne ne m'étonne
pas du tout mais c'est un discours qui
ne nous apporte rien du tout on sait
qu'ils veulent réformer cet été très
bien mais réformer cet été et faire un
plan par exemple pour le pouvoir d'achat
c'est différent si vous faites un plan
avec une loupe ce qu'est un
rassemblement national qui représentent
à eux deux quelque pas loin de 300
députés que avec une opposition
des deux qui fait 120 quoi vous est donc
c'est très compliqué donc on va voir ce
qui va se passer ici n'est que dès cet
été sur le pouvoir d'achat vous avez
deux grosses forces politiques qui
veulent bloquer les prix
il va y avoir ce débat il peut y avoir
des solutions alternatives au projet
qu'on connaît dont on connaît les grands
risques gouvernement sur lequel aussi là
pour le coup où il peut y avoir une
unité de vues entre la majorité
présidentielle et les républicains je
pense que les recettes qui seraient
impliqués qui ne déplairont fortement et
aux arènes et alan ubs ce sont des
recettes qui peuvent trouver en commun
qui ne passe pas du tout justement par
le blocage des prix qui passe pas du
tout par une espèce de tva et qui passe
par des mesures extrêmement ciblée
éventuellement des distribution de
chèques des populations très modeste sur
le social quand on regarde le pouvoir
d'achat c'est quand même une question
aussi très sociale on retrouve le
clivage gauche droite c'est à dire que
vous avez trois forces à l'assemblée 4
avec les républicains mais dans
l'hémicycle on va se retrouver avec un
clivage gauche droite madame le pen dit
à peu près sûr beaucoup de choses non
sur beaucoup de sujets économiques à des
recettes et des formules des
formulations qui ce rsa comparable à
celle de la de l'année pèse attention
n'en déplaise à la ducasse n'est pas ce
qu'elle aimerait bien discret sauf qu'il
ne se distingue pas ils disent à peu
près la même chose sur ces questions la
rn et elle est fille sont plutôt en
ligne face à un bloc de droits drm
d'extrader pas de gauche mais est ce que
c'est pas ça qui est en train de se
jouer lors le bon vieux clivage
gauche-droite texte après mais non mais
non mais non parce que les il faudra
regarder les chiffres
il a été dit là fut un mouvement de
demain un peu exagéré notre ami frère en
dix ans la nuque baisse et rassemblement
national ça fait 300 députés nous ça
fait 2 120 ça fait une minorité or comme
utiliser l'autre jadis vous avez
politiquement tort parce que vous êtes
juridiquement minoritaires et c'est
comme ça qu'on compte les voix dans un
parlement donc je pense que même dans un
débat sur le pouvoir d'achat la minorité
n'impose partait solution la majorité si
majorité il y a donc voilà je ne crois
pas qu'on revienne à des vieux clivages
que certains regrettent déjà on veut on
en est aux clivages actuels qui ont été
réaffirmés fortement par cette élection
d'aujourd'hui mais qui laisse à mon avis
du chant à la politique précisément et
sur ce pouvoir sur cette histoire de
pouvoir d'achat il me semble qu'en effet
les positions du gouvernement sortant et
des républicains voir
quelques amendements venue de l'année
pèse et du rassemblement national
peuvent faire une vraie vraie majorité
au sein du parlement je crois que c'est
à ce genre de choses qu'il faut
peut-être se prépare yves thréard avant
de partir sur le terrain entre
nicollette quad ou à drancy je sais que
vous vous êtes pressé est très attendu
un dernier mot comme envoyée la semaine
des manuels macron ça fait une semaine
extrêmement chargé certes intéressant de
voir toutes les rendez vous qui va avoir
été obligé de recevoir à mon avis toutes
les forces politiques les leaders de
chacune des forces politiques ça va être
intéressant de voir aussi au sein de la
majorité le rôle que vont jouer et
françois bayrou et edouard philippe
parce que faux pas on n'a pas beaucoup
parlé d'eux mais ils apportent à la
majorité est précisément sa majorité
parce que sans eux le président de la
république se retrouve à la tête d'un
parti qui doivent renaissance faire le
calcul mais
qui n'est pas aussi de vivre son rêve de
matignon ou rêve de matignon et son rêve
est en train de prendre du volume
merci infiniment il thréard on part à
drancy tout de suite rejoindre nicolas
quad ou vous avez le résultat à nous
communiquer le sortant jean christophe
lagarde lui dei s'accrochait à son siège
des résultats provisoires je crois
absolument brigitte ans c'est une petite
révolution qui s'annonce ici puisque ce
serait donc un rack m garrido qui
emporterait ce scrutin avec 53% des
suffrages exprimés elle devance donc
jean christophe lagarde qui requérait
47% des voix et c'est lui qui a annoncé
sa défaite sur twitter voilà au delà de
l'enjeu local c'est la nuque qui réussit
son pari en rappelant les douze
circonscription de seine-saint-denis de
son côté jean christophe lagarde perd sa
place au palais bourbon au profit de
raquel garrido il place qu'il occupait
depuis près de 20 ans merci infiniment
nicolas quad ou en duplex de drancy pour
ce résultat il ya des films tricot grand
chelem en seine saint denis pour la
france insoumise oui on va 7 euros je
dirais on revient à une situation que
les plus anciens peuvent se souvenir
c'est à dire que les années 80 quand le
parti communiste faisait grand chelem en
seine-saint-denis alors que la rolande
bobigny notables et notamment la
circonscription de bobigny mais c'était
dans les années 80 c'était comme ça et
et lui d y avait réussi à mettre un coin
dans cette sur représentation du parti
communiste et puis le parti socialiste
également été rentrés dans la danse pour
pour défaire le parti communiste de son
de son fief historique et là je pense
que c'est quand même un coup très dur
pour lui dis parce que c'était quand
même l'entrée de l'ue dei en région
parisienne et en france
koech avait conduit jean christophe
lagarde -la le fait qu'ils soient des
faits et qu'ils seront défaits dans
d'autres services clés dans d'autres
circonscriptions pour lui dit je pense
que c'est quelque chose en effet qui va
qui va peser lourd et moi qui ne me
surprend pas parce que c'est quand même
beau billet est une ville très populaire
et le score de jean luc mélenchon en
seine saint denis c'est un score
phénoménal c'est un corps boulet de
canon il n'avait plus de 50 % en
seine-saint-denis ce qui doit attention
forte jeudi à l'élection présidentielle
au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle le résultat de jean luc
mélenchon préparer finalement le
résultat de la nuit alors parlons un peu
justement de jean luc mélenchon qui ne
sera pas dans cette arène du palais
bourbon quelle erreur non quelle erreur
de ne pas être représenté dans ses
positions non bah oui alors je vous
laisse répondre et puis vous réagirez à
ma came le tricot roland perrin oui
qu'est ce que vous voulez logiquement
le chef d'une coalition qui l'a porté
avec le talent les excès qu'on sait
aller doit y être quoi je dois dire que
j'ai du mal j'ai entendu ce qu'il a dit
il est train pour marseille les matches
moi j'arrive pas j'arrive pas à
comprendre ça il devrait y être il y ait
pas c'est un choix
à mon avis de temps en temps il va le
regretter
à scania et non parce que tout même
l'enjeu c'est de savoir qui sera la
figure la plus parlante de l'opposition
marine le pen c'est clair elle va être à
la tête d'un groupe énorme de 90 députés
elle va pouvoir refaire le handicap qui
s'était creusé tout de même de manière
vertigineuse alors que à la
présidentielle le principal parti
d'opposition celle rassemblement
national et en quelques semaines tout ça
avait été défait par le coup de com
phénoménal de jean-luc mélenchon et la
voilà à la fois le score en baisse par
rapport aux attentes de la nuque plus le
choix personnel de jean luc mélenchon
remettent sous les feux de la rampe
marine le pen alors justement
transition toute trouvée va prendre la
direction d'hénin beaumont nous attend
claire sergent ce soir de la rédaction
de france info bonsoir clair vous êtes
dans le fief de marine le pen réélu haut
la main ce soir quelles sont les
ambitions de la patronne du
rassemblement national désormais forte
d'un groupe qui pourrait aller jusqu'à
90 députés
et bien quand elle s'est exprimée il ya
à peu près deux heures ici devant des
militants en joie elle a remercié les
français qui ont a décidé d'envoyer un
très puissant groupe de parlementaires
rassemblement national à l'assemblée
puis elle nous a affirmé vouloir bâtir
une opposition forte et constructive et
elle a ajouté on ne va pas faire du
bruit pour rien tacle direct à la france
insoumise et à la nuque qui a emporté de
nombreux à député également elle avait
appelé à faire barrage contre la
nouvelle a aussi adressé ce tacle à
emmanuel macron pour lui et le président
se retrouve sans contrôle dans
l'exercice du pouvoir puisqu'il n'a pas
de majorité absolue
et puis pour d'autres élus du
rassemblement national à présent ce soir
comme steeve briois le maire à d'hénin
beaumont et bien c'est l'opportunité de
prouver que le rassemblement national et
crédible il nous disait on va prouver
qu'on sait travailler qu'on sait être
sérieux qu'on peut être force de
proposition le rassemblement national et
qui n'exclut pas de demander à la
présidence de la commission et des
finances poste important poste
stratégique à l'assemblée nationale un
élu du rassemblement national nous
disait depuis qu'on a ces résultats
depuis que connaissez résultat que
personne n'attendait eh bien on va être
gourmand merci clair clair sergent
depuis hénin beaumont catherine tricot
pascal perrineau finalement voilà on est
on est tous énormément surpris ce soir
personne n'a vu venir cet ancrage local
cette progression importante du
rassemblement national dans les
territoires le scrutin majoritaire n'est
plus un obstacle oui et c'est surtout
elle sort de ses terres c'est à dire qu'
elle n'est plus simplement dans le quart
nord-est et puis le pourtour
méditerranéen où nous disons même l'arc
méditerranéen c'est vraiment compléter
et puis on la voit on la voit apparaître
un peu partout entrée en est tout à
l'heure on parler de la position de jean
luc mélenchon je pense qu'en effet il
n'avait probablement pas anticiper
qu'elle puisse arriver avec un tel
résultat à l'assemblée nationale ça je
pense que ce n'était que ça ne faisait
pas partie de ses ses perspectives de
ses prévisions et qui pouvait penser que
ça pouvait se produire c'est à dire en
fait ce qui s'est passé entre les deux
tours là je reviens pas sur ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur ce trait
d'égalité
tressé entre passé entre la nuque et et
le front national
les autres gâteaux mais ce que je
faisais spécialiste national parce que
je voulais dire aussi sur le choix de
jean-luc mélenchon puisque c'était ça le
point toyal heures c'est que ça va être
aussi l'occasion de faire monter encore
des personnalités nouvelles au sein de
la new baisse dans les différents
groupes en général si on est je pense
qu'il ya une nouvelle génération d'abord
sont des gens jeunes qui vont être
qu'ils vont arriver à l'assemblée
nationale et on a vu déjà dans le
précédent mandat ils étaient peu
nombreux mais a vraiment des figures
qu'ils se sont imposés au plan national
matile panneaux adrien catena rufin
clémentine autain enfin ce sont des gens
que maintenant on a repéré et je pense
que le pari de jean luc mélenchon c'est
de continuer d'un passage de relais oui
je pense que candidat à genève annonce
que je dise en 2022 landéda faut aussi
avoir des gens avec soin et que là en
l'occurrence d'état voir une équipe
c'est vrai qu'il a construit il a
construit et il a travaillé avec ce
court ce n'est pas forcément contre lui
c'est aux conditions l assemblée
nationale ça peut porter une une
perspective politique qui peut ne pas
durer cinq ans voilà ce jour et 2027 on
corrige a évidemment donné l'un d'eux
s'est passé las calles pérenno
expliquez-nous ce vote ce vote
rassemblement national qui gagne du
terrain qui s'ancre territorialement on
a le sentiment en font qu'à chaque fois
on le sous-estiment on sous estime aussi
mansion
bien sûr est devenu un vote d'adhésion
si de plus en plus oui de plus en plus
il ya aussi de la protestation comme si
vous la la france est soumise il ya du
rejet et puis à l'adhésion c'est pas la
seule force politique qui joue sur ce
mixte adhésion et projets non je crois
qu'il ya plusieurs facteurs il ya
d'abord le fait tout de même ces
élections législatives viennent après
une élection présidentielle qui a été
aussi bien au premier tour qu'au second
tour marqué par une dynamique
impressionnante de la présidente du
rassemblement national certes elle est
battue et battu très nettement mais vous
rendez compte 42 % des suffrages
exprimés c'est toi même pas n'importe
quoi et donc il ya un effet d'onde sur
l'élection qui a suivi les élections
législatives aussi bien au premier tour
c'était la dynamique la plus forte par
rapport à 2010 sept coups second tour ou
là vraiment très peu de gens
s'attendaient à ce qu'ils flirtent
presque avec les 100 députés ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est
quelque chose de beaucoup plus longue
haleine ce parti en particulier depuis
une dizaine d'années devient le vecteur
privilégié des couches populaires
des fractures sociales territoriales que
connaît le pays vous regardez par
exemple cette impressionnante
par rapport au front national première
période c'était l'arc méditerranéen ça
ils l'ont gardé mais c'est plus leurs
zones de force maintenant c'est toute
une zone qui va du doubs au pas de
calais et qui va de la normandie à la
lorraine 1 et ce sont des terres tout
marquée par de grandes difficultés c'est
des terres de la désindustrialisation
quand vous regardez des scores qu'ils
font dans l'aisne dans la somme dans le
pas-de-calais très souvent d'ailleurs
dans des terres qui étaient des terres
de gauche c'est tout à fait
impressionnant et là vous avez en effet
un nombre extrêmement important
d'ouvriers d'employés qui utilisent si
vous voulez le vote fn comme porte
parole de leurs angoisses ils ont été
déçus par la gauche déçue par la droite
déçus par le et de droite et de gauche
et il ya aussi une volonté dans ces
couches populaires de se dire ça on n'a
pas essayé sans qu'il soit faut pas
croire qu'ils croient dans toutes les
vertus du programme de marine le pen
mais voilà avec marine le pen on va
exprimer notre désarroi et on va
contribuer à renverser la table c'est
tout cela qui fait le vote fn est pris
maintenant parce que là je regardais la
nationalisation jusqu'à maintenant tu si
vous voulez tout le grand ouest de la
france 1 toute la façade occidentale de
la france était rétive vraiment au front
au front national est au rassemblement
national parce que c'est une france qui
va bien qui est optimiste sur l'avenir
qui est marquée par de grandes
métropoles dynamique etc et là vous
voyez dans la gironde la 11e de la
gironde le score de madame diaz est tout
à fait tout à fait impressionnant dans
le loir et cher dans le loir et cher
dans la troisième il emporte une
circonscription dans le lot ray dans le
tarn dans le tarn et garonne dans la
voyez là ça veut dire véritablement que
ça devient c'était le front national
n'était pas un front vraiment nationale
le rassemblement national devient
et pourtant on a vu des candidats
inexpérimentés novice dans cette
campagne des législatives le parti et
renflouer financièrement et d'autant
plus avec 90 députés il faut il faut
rester prudent mais ce sont les
estimations de notre partenaire il va se
professionnaliser il va sans crédit et
puis qu'est ce que vous voulez il subit
le même sort que toutes les
organisations politiques c'est à dire
que dans ces élections législatives on a
vu disparaître définitivement je crois
les baronnies les fiefs individuel
les par tous les dissidents se sont
cassé la figure les étiquettes
politiques contre la nationalisation ça
veut dire ça aussi ça veut dire
politisation national partout
équivalente rêver du roi swazi un
courrier manuel maquereau a commis
l'erreur pendant cinq ans de ne pas
construire le malraux nisme jura
véritable parti après effective le croit
le croire une fois qu'ils les barils à
billy lapinous navarre construit ni une
organisation partisane ni un semblant de
construction idéologique très exactement
où ils aient été négligés cela je crois
que sa formation sa façon d'entrer en
politique sa façon de voir la politique
à travers le prisme qu'il a eu du parti
socialiste défendeur des histoires qu'il
a vécu au parlement un certain goût du
jour la matiz men aventure j'aurais
tellement ça je crois pas tellement ça
je crois que c'est plutôt une réticence
idéologique et politique dans le sens d'
expérience d'élu jusqu'à ce qu'ils
soient loués mais ça ils ont été
beaucoup des comme ça
pragmatisme et des du pragmatisme sert
de s'imaginer qu'on va régler les
problèmes comme dans une entreprise où
il faut être efficace mais un pays un
corps social c'est pas simplement les
c'est pas simplement d' activer des
leviers
et de mettre des nausées etc et je crois
que là il n'a pas il ne comprend pas ce
qui est assez étrange parce quand même
il a une formation de philosophe aussi
mais il ne comprend il ne comprend pas
ce que c'est que l'idéologie stade r en
fait le fait que chacun a besoin de se
représenter lui son pays est là et le
monde dans une perspective qui lui donne
sens il n'a jamais donner sens à son
action alors il reste une dizaine de
minutes avant notre antenne commune avec
france info moi j'aimerais comprendre ce
qui peut se passer les les prochains
jours on a compris que les consultations
vont commencer pour essayer de trouver
des majorités à l'assemblée nationale
mais il va y avoir l'exécutif
on ne connaît pas encore le sort de
certains ministres qui se présente à
paris mais ils sont en difficulté
stanislas guérini clément bonne amélie
de montchalin dans dans les sols bombe
au mieux parti que les autres et vous
avez des proche parmi les proches on les
appelle même les grognards christophe
castaner battu ce soir richard ferrand
battu ce soir c'est un homme plus isolé
que jamais aujourd'hui emmanuel macron
comment peut-il se sent tout récent les
sens les siens sans son adn de départ il
va devoir tout changer il va devoir
changer assez profondément à la fois son
mode de fonctionnement mais il l'appelle
de ses voeux il faut qu'il croit ce
qu'il dit la fameuse nouvelle méthode un
donc voilà il faut qu'il mette en oeuvre
en effet une nouvelle méthode l'ancien
nouvelle méthode a montré ses limites ça
c'est le premier point deuxième point
faut qu'ils acceptent milliers contraint
un partage au delà de la république en
marche avec d'abord le premier cercle de
ses alliés horizon agir le modem qui est
un groupe tout de même important et avec
les fortes personnalités qu'il y a du
moins à horizon et au modem et puis
qu'ils construisent un tout à l'heure il
veut très rare parlait de vulcain qu'ils
construisent comme vulcain un alliage
politique à l'heure où bien relativement
permanence c'est une forme d'accord de
gouvernement relativement classique de
logique de compromis et c'est
relativement raisonnable voilà le faire
le faire
ou bien des alliages temporaire
successifs ce qu'on appelait jadis les
fameuses majorité d'idées un voile à
penser qu'il peut s'appuyer sur un
edouard philippe pour aller sonder les
républicains puisque c'était 7 et son
rouge au départ je trouvais les balles
trail les sébastien lecornu léger ram
lerman en prenez le maire edouard
philippe il est dit et au président de
la république pour les années qui
viennent c'est pas il va pas s'il a une
popularité c'est parce qu'il a été
premier ministre qu'il a des vertus pour
demain mais il peut pas les mettre en
cause en ayant l'air d'un traître dans
les trois ans qui viennent donc son
avenir est pour après pour les trois ans
qui viennent il sera évidemment un de
ceux qui vont jouer et comme engrais
dans un match mais on verra cela dans le
détail jeu je vous redonne la parole
catherine tricot dans un instant mais
d'abord de nouveaux résultats avec vous
clément oui on commence avec le nord et
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin qui est réélu assez largement
57 5% pour lui face à les skis mortreux
qui fait 42 4% un autre ministre qui va
sans doute avoir un rôle important
olivier veyrat ancien ministre de la
santé maintenant il est chargé des
relations avec le parlement et ça risque
d'être un poste effectivement très
important 55 5% dans l'isère pour
olivier ferrand qui est donc réélu
député maintenant les nouvelles de
francs cristers le ministre délégué
chargé du commerce extérieur
il est en tête dans la seine et marne
avec 53 2% des voix il est donc réélu
maintenant dans la somme une ancienne
ministre cette fois de la transition
écologique barbara pont qui dit eh bien
elle est réélue vous le voyez
53,1 % face à une candidate de la nuque
maintenant dans le haut-rhin 5e
circonscription olivier becht c'est le
président du groupe agir ensemble à
l'assemblée
beau score pour lui
64,6 % il est réélu député maintenant
dans le var lors la valette c'était
l'une des porte-parole de marine le pen
lors de la campagne présidentielle elle
est désormais porte parole officiel du
rassemblement national c'est une figure
montante du parti
51,6 % ça passe pour elle face à ange
musso qui était le candidat du parti
horizon toujours côté rassemblement
national emmanuel mais ménard qui est
une apparente et rn qu'il ne fait pas
partie du parti excusez moi je vois
qu'en fait c'est le résultat de valérie
rabault pour la nuque c'était l'ancienne
présidente du groupe socialiste à ça se
passe dans le tarn-et-garonne 58 2% pour
valérie rabault qui est donc réélu
clément amélie de montchanin et elle
battu aurait élu direction l'essonne à
massy elle demande un gala vous avez le
résultat
oui exactement ici on a eu les
illustrations du coup de tonnerre on l'a
eue dehors avec le climat et puis aussi
le coup de tonnerre pour la majorité
ameline montchalin ministre a été battu
ici aller au premier étage de cet espace
à l est avec ses militants qu'ils
applaudissent elle devrait descendre
dans quelques minutes pour parler aux
journalistes la ministre connaît la
règle elle va devoir quitter le
gouvernement c'est jérôme guedj député
ancien député socialiste qui est élu
dans cette sixième circonscription de
l'essonne merci infiniment examonde à
gabat c'est une bérézina pour la macro
ni ce soir 4e tricot après amélie
dimanche à l'ats christophe castaner
richard ferrand patrick mignola oui
c'est une bérézina oui il ya beaucoup de
tête d'affiche qui sont battus et je
pense même le fait qu'ils aient été
peut-être des têtes d'affiché a
contribué à les faire battre à mon avis
il ya castaner je pense qu'ils payent le
bilan de la sphère gilet jaune fin de sa
gestion à l'intérieur des manifestations
de gilet jaune face à na fonctionner les
figuras oui je crois que ce président je
pense qu'il ya deux il ya de ça
oui c'est ça mais en même temps je veux
dire que tu comptes quand vous avez un
tel résultat globalement bien qu'un et
qui tombe donc ça y est énorme et là on
verra à paris comment résiste clément
bonnet stanislas guérini ça veut dire
qu'il va falloir trouver une nouvelle
ministre de la transition écologique
c'est un portefeuille essentiel sous la
houlette du la première ministre on l'a
vu c'était l'ont déjà pour
l'accouchement du coup faire de même en
born là je ne sais pas si ça va être
aussi long ça sera difficile de
s'accorder autant de semaines avant
d'accoucher d'un gouvernement parce que
faut pas que j'allais dire voilà pas que
ça dure ça urge ça urge et le fait
justement qu'il y ait eu c'est très long
degré d'attentes
cette absence de campagne certainement
contribué à ce relatif effacement de la
majorité présents il s'appelle comment
ce que traverse emmanuel macron
concrètement est ce que c'est une crise
politique on verra sur les 15 ministres
combien sont battus combien sont réélus
mais il va falloir remaniée
politiquement parce qu'il n'a pas de
majorité il va faire remanier parce
qu'il faut trouver des remplaçants aux
ministres battus c'est compliqué mais
c'est très clairement une véritable
crise politique
et qui ne peut se résoudre que par des
décisions est solide les ronds selon la
sp clément bonne annonce sa victoire à
parcourir j'avais lu que lui et est élu
en arrivant ici mais bon il ya quelques
exceptions mais c'est clair que le
gouvernement doit être profondément
remaniée qui doit y avoir du sang
nouveau et comme ça ajoute à ça la
discussion sur les nouveaux entrants qui
pourraient politiquement permettre une
majorité il est évident qu'il faut que
ça ait le plus vite possible parce que
ça a trop duré ses compositions de
gouvernement mais on voit bien qu'on est
devant un sacré problème pour le chef de
m c'est lui qui est aux manettes
téléphone l'a décidé sous la pression
pour conclure 4-1 trikorfo qui descend
de son piédestal et puis qu'il a est de
penser qu' il est le maître des horloges
maintenant il faut décider faut agir et
il va falloir qu'ils tranchent aussi
entre ses discours contradictoires entre
le moment où il fait de l'appel du pied
aux électeurs de jean luc mélenchon et
mais bon on va suivre ça dans le détail
sur la chaîne parlementaire bien
évidemment merci infiniment merci pour
vos analyses la soirée électorale
continue sur lcp en partenariat avec
france info antenne commune jusqu'à
minuit un immense merci à toutes les
équipes de rcp derrière la caméra et son
croyez-moi nombreuses à brigitte boucher
et louis laforge prennent la main dans
un tout instant n'a bougé par était le
soir et se poursuit sur france info
canal 27 mais aussi sur l'antenne de lcp
sur le canal 13 de la tnt une fin de
soirée que nous partageons comme
dimanche dernier avec nos confrères de
la chaîne le monteur pour soir doji
bouffer bonsoir louis bonsoir a tous
très heureuse de vous retrouver pour
cette émission commune à nos deux
rédactions durant laquelle nous allons
bien sûr revenir sur les principaux
résultats et l'information de cette
soirée la coalition présidentielle qui
rate la majorité absolue et qui se
retrouvent avec une petite majorité
relative et grâce à nos deux chaînes
bien nous sommes présents un peu partout
en france dans les circonscriptions clés
du territoire vous allez également
entendre les principales déclarations
des responsables politiques ce soir ceux
qui ont gagné et ceux qui ont permis et
pour tous les résultats circonscription
par circonscription et les projections
en terme de sièges est bien notre
partenaire ipsos sopra et steria nous
accompagne pour ces législatives avec
des estimations qui sont encore à fine
et elle ce soir est avec nous sur ce
plateau et en duplex également pour
réagir aux résultats et parler de la
suite du quinquennat plusieurs invités
le premier qui est arrivé et on lui dit
merci david amiel bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes vous avez été conseillé d' emmanuel
macron vous êtes candidat aux
législatives dans la 13e circonscription
de paris est ce que vous connaissez
votre résultat ce soir les derniers
bureaux de vote sont en train d'être
dépouillé mais selon toutes les
premières estimations je serai élu avec
une nette avance eh bien on verra la
confirmation tout à l'heure aurélien
pradié est également avec nous en duplex
depuis cahors dans le lot avec les
moyens techniques de stéphanie des
pierres alors avant de commencer ce
débat avec nos invités dans un instant
eh bien nous vous proposons de découvrir
la projection de la future assemblée
avec vous clément perreault depuis le
studio dès le cp au coeur de l'assemblée
nationale clément est ce que vous pouvez
nous donner les projections en terme de
sièges on va les voir qui s'affiche en
tout cas à l'écran avec ensemble avec le
pour la majorité présidentielle
cette estimation d'un autre partenaire
et sopra et steria
234 sièges suivie de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale 141
députés en troisième position et c'est
l'une des surprises de cette soirée l'un
des enseignements l'arrivée en force du
rassemblement national créditée de 90
sièges 75 pour les républicains lui dit
et les divers droite et d'autres sièges
répartis pour entre d'autres partis dont
les étiquettes sont différentes des
précédents partis cités david amiel la
majorité absolue est ratée c'est un
échec ce soir pour la majorité va si
bien sûr une grande déception faisait
campagne pour obtenir la majorité
absolue vous l'avez dit elle n'est pas
atteindre selon toutes les estimations
dont on dispose à cette heure donc bien
entendu c'est une c'est une déception
c'est une claque est quand même assez
forte quand on regarde par rapport au
chiffre de 2017 vous étiez à 350 députés
avec la majorité le modem et là vous
êtes à
234 ça veut dire quand même un
affaiblissement considérable c'est un
vote sanction je crois que l'hémicycle
le reflète aussi l'état de la société
française on avait vu au moment de
l'élection présidentielle on a vu ces
dernières années on a un pays qui est
profondément divisée avec des très
nombreuses fractures l'extrême gauche de
jean luc mélenchon avait d'ailleurs déjà
réalisé 22 % des voix si ma mémoire est
bonne au premier tour de la
présidentielle le rassemblement national
s'était hissé au second tour où il avait
réalisé 42% et donc de nombreux députés
de la nuit ps autour de jean luc
mélenchon du rassemblement national soit
présent c'est au fond le reflet de ceux
là et on n'est qu'en plus des fonctions
vous ne faites pas autocritique bas bien
sûr que si qu'il faut faire une
autocritique bien j'espère que les
français nous ont adressé un message de
soir clairement bien sûr ils ont envoyé
d'ailleurs beaucoup de messages et
d'abord tous ceux qui ne sont pas allés
voter qui envoie un message à l'ensemble
de la classe politique ça va c'est
valable pour notre camp c'est valable
pour l'ensemble des autres il y a les
français qui ont voté pour le
rassemblement national qui ont exprimé
un message ceux qui ont voté pour la
nuque mais son nom a exprimé un autre et
donc on a cette société fracturée qui va
falloir dans les prochaines années
rassembler pour agir est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas victimes à votre tour d'une
forme de dégagisme
je crois qu'il y avait peut-être une
forme de dégagisme mais je crois que
plus profondément que ça il y a vraiment
cette société est fracturée d'ailleurs
le président la république avait été
réélu au moment de l'élection
présidentielle on a ce soir les
candidats de la majorité présidentielle
qui arrive en tête par rapport aux
autres forces politiques et pour autant
un paysage qui est très éclaté à l'image
d'une france qui elle-même est très
éclaté certains avaient parlé de
l'archipel français pour décrire cette
société je crois qu'on voit cet archipel
politique ce soir et dont c'est
évidemment une tâche immense dans les
années à venir pour rassembler la
société une tâche qui va se poser pour
la majorité présidentielle pour ces
parlementaires et aux fonds pour
l'ensemble de ceux qui s'engagent dans
la vie politique française nous a
rejoints sur le plateau aurélie trouvé
bonsoir être candidate nuque de la 9e
circonscription de seine-saint-denis
même question vous avez lors résultats
depuis sa conception oui je suis élu à
69% merci de venir nous voir
après avoir fêté cette victoire
j'imagine avec avec vos camarades de
militant nous sommes également en duplex
avec aurélien pradié bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous des vainqueurs ce soir
sur ce plateau et en duplex puisque vous
êtes le député sortant et l'air du lot
est réélu mais pour prolonger la
discussion avec david amiel voulait l
air sont sont prêts à travailler avec le
camp d'emmanuel macron dans cette
nouvelle assemblée ou pas
si la question est de savoir si on va se
rallier à emmanuel macron pardon mais la
réponse est claire nette et précise nom
et la situation que ce monsieur semblait
dénoncé en étant très peinés de voir le
pays fracturé depuis cinq ans peut-être
qu'il serait bon de s'interroger sur qui
l'a fracturée excusez moi mais je l'aï
quand même moins fort qu'on met un peu
les pieds dans le plat on n'a jamais eu
un rassemblement national aussi fort on
n'avait jamais eu l'extrême gauche aussi
forte et je pense qu emmanuel macron il
ya largement contribué par le projet de
société qui est le sien par sa manière
de gouverner et de s'adresser aux
françaises et aux français j'ai été
frappé durant ces deux mois de campagne
ici dans le lot où j'ai été très
largement réélu de voir des français
blessé profondément blessés dans leur
dignité dans leur existence de citoyens
dans leur vie quotidienne et donc c'est
ce chemin que nous avons à rebâtir mois
les bidouillages de savoir si on sera
une force d'appoint ou pas pardon mais
ça ne m'intéresse pas ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que demain nous défendions les
français à l'assemblée nationale nous le
ferons en fonction des textes on prendra
nos positions de vote mais il est pas
question qu on aille faire une perfusion
à emmanuel macron c'est à lui de gérer
ce que jean françois copé en direct sur
internet républicaine je vous pose la
question parce que jean françois copé
pardonnez-moi aurélien pradié c'est un
peu compliqué évidemment nous sommes en
distance mais jean françois copé sur
france 2 tout à l'heure parler d'un
pacte de gouvernement donc il n'y a pas
une seule voix au sein des républiques
et bien je vais je vais vous répondre
très clairement
non il n'y a pas une seule et si jean
françois copé veut tenter une aventure
avec emmanuel macron qu'ils se dépêchent
de le faire je veux dire ça suffit
pardonnez moi mais ça commence à bien
faire on a passé cinq ans à essayer de
vivre ensemble y compris quand les uns
les autres voulaient prendre des chemins
extrêmement différents on va se
retrouver la semaine prochaine
se poser sereinement et on va se dire
voilà chacun veut tenter une aventure si
jean-françois copé veut tenter une
aventure avec emmanuel macron qu'il
l'attend et si d'autres veulent tenter
une aventure avec le rassemblement
national qui l'attend moi je ne tenterai
ni l'une ni l'autre et je ne serai pas
le seul d'ailleurs ici il nous faut
rebâtir une droite républicaine n
dépendantes qui ne se vend ni à emmanuel
macron ni au rassemblement national nous
seront quelques-uns de quelques
aventuriers à le faire croyez moi on le
fera on a l'âge pour le faire on a du
temps devant nous aurélien pradié est ce
que vous craignez pas une explosion des
républicains avec ceux qui
souhaiteraient un accord de gouvernement
se mettre d'accord sur un certain nombre
de réformes avec la nouvelle majorité et
puis ceux qui comme vous dites la porte
finalement est grande ouverte pour ceux
qui souhaitent partir et qui ne
souhaitent pas que les républicains
restent seuls
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je craigne
de plus que ce qui s'est passé depuis
plusieurs mois on a une candidate
résidentiel qui a fait moins de 5% on a
aujourd'hui un groupe politique qui est
très affaibli on est quelques-uns à se
sauver dans des terres de gauche je suis
élu dans une terre de gauche ça veut
dire quelque chose tout ça est donc qu
est ce que vous les jeux craignent de
plus que ça enfin vous savez quand vous
avez passé tout c'est toutes ces flammes
politique vous avez plus peur de grand
chose mais nous on n'a plus peur de
grand chose ce qui me fait peur
aujourd'hui c'est l'état de notre pays
c'est l'état de notre démocratie c'est
l'état notre assemblée nationale c'est
pas l'état des républicains ou l'état du
parti socialiste tout ça c'est pas le
sujet et donc si demain il nous faut
tous posé à plat et rebâtir quelque
chose de nouveau il nous faut avoir le
courage de le faire donc non ça me fait
pas peur je vais même vous dire dans la
période aussi grave que nous connaissons
pour notre pays je trouve que c'est
enthousiasmant c'est enthousiasmant de
se dire nous seront quelques-uns à tenir
bon pour que les français et d'autres
choix que macro ou les extrêmes on va
vous retrouver dans un tout petit
instant aurélien pradié vous restez bien
sûr en duplex avec nous mais nous
prenons tout de suite la direction de
l'assemblée nationale le studio dès le
cp qui se trouve au coeur de ce
parlement pour retrouver clément
perreault clément vous êtes en mesure de
nous donner le détail des forces
politiques au sein de chaque alliance ce
soir
oui brigitte et c'est grâce aux
estimations de notre partenaire ipsos ce
sont les dernières estimations je vais
effectivement rentrer dans les détails
des deux grands blocs qui désormais est
bien constitue le nouveau visage de
l'hémicycle le premier blog vous le
voyez apparaître devant moi en violet
c'est le bloc ensemble les députés qui
soutiennent emmanuel macron ils sont 230
4 et dans ce bloc le groupe le plus
important c'est la république en marche
qui aurait 162 sièges ensuite on a le
modem de françois bayrou avec 45 sièges
puis horizon le nouveau parti des loirs
philippe qui aurait 27 députés ensuite
plongeons-nous maintenant dans le groupe
de la gauche unie la nuque elle est de
couleur rouge là c'est la france
insoumise qui aurait le groupe le plus
important avec 79 députés un détail mais
c'est important c'est moins que le
rassemblement national qui aurait 90
députés donc elle est fille ne serait
pas le premier groupe d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale ce serait ce soir
le rassemblement national ensuite on
voit europe ecologie les verts et le
parti socialiste
chacun 25 députés et puis le parti
communiste contre lui 12 sièges à
l'assemblée nationale
aurait dû trouver je rappelle que vous
êtes candidate élue députée donc nuque
de la 9e circonscription de
seine-saint-denis on vient de voir la
répartition au sein de ce nouvel
hémicycle et au sein de la nuque avec la
france insoumise qui bien à la majorité
des sièges de cette nouvelle alliance de
gauche néanmoins vous n'imaginiez pas
une victoire un peu plus importante pour
votre camp c'est moi la première
réaction que nous avons c'est quand même
un sentiment de victoire dans le sens où
nous passons de 64 députés issus des
forces de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale à trois fois plus
quasiment par rapport à la situation
prescience qui montre que nous avons
soulevé un immense espoir autour de ces
de ce programme de cette nouvelle
alliance large qui est une étape réussie
et nous allons continuer le combat nous
allons amplifier ce combat c'est ce que
nous annonçons ce soir
ciel l'élection est terminée je joue le
brésil mais nous allons l'envié air dans
une cohabitation vous souhaitiez être le
premier groupe d'opposition ce sont deux
pari perdu quand même pour nous allons
l'amplifier d'abord dans l'assemblée
nationale vous avez vu tout le travail
qui a été fait à 64 députés excusez moi
mais là trois fois plus et bien nous
allons mener véritablement ce combat
nous passons d'une force de résistance
quelque part à une force d'alternative
et de propositions et puis c'est vrai
que aujourd'hui il faut déplorer le
score du rassemblement national qui pour
moi est à mettre sur le compte de la
macro ni et des 50 des manuels macron
qui nous avait promis de faire barrage
au rassemblent la nationale le résultat
ce soir c'est que pour la première fois
depuis 36 ans nous avons un groupe à
l'assemblée nationale du rassemblement
national et nous voyons aussi la
responsabilité que nous avons à proposer
une sortie progressiste de une
alternative pardon progressiste par
rapport à la macro ni et qu'ils soient
sur un programme qui réponde
véritablement aux immenses enjeux
écologiques sociaux et démocratiques
autour de nos 650 mesures communes il y
trouvez vous mettez en cause l'ancienne
majorité présidentielle david amiel vous
avez une part de responsabilité dans la
montée dans ce record historique sous la
vème république du rassemblement
national de l'extrême droite en france
ça fait très longtemps que le
rassemblement national augmente son
score élection après élection on l'avait
vu en 2012 on l'avait revu en 2017 on
l'a revu cette année en 2022 donc c'est
une montée constante de la force
d'extrême droite qu'on observait
d'ailleurs dans de très nombreux pays on
a vu ce qui s'était passé aux états unis
avec l'élection donald trump on a vu ce
qui s'est passé au royaume uni avec le
brésil on a vu ce qu'il s'est passé en
un nombre de pays d'europe de l'est donc
emmanuel macron n'y est pour rien il ya
mais au-delà de ça il ya des difficultés
très profondes auxquels nos démocraties
occidentales font face la france avait
pendant très longtemps un chômage de
masse on a souffert pendant de très
nombreuses années de la
désindustrialisation un rapport à la
mondialisation qui oblige à repenser
beaucoup de choses pour ne donner que
ces quelques et promet de réconcilier
les français avec la vie politique on
voit que l'abstention est très hot vous
aviez promis de faire reculer le
rassemblement national n'a jamais été
aussi haut il revient à l'assemblée
nationale après 36 pour ça est ce que ce
n'est pas votre échec mais ce n'est pas
que notre échec mais bien sûr qu'on
porte une part de responsabilité dans
cet échec comme l'ensemble des forces
politiques qui sont présentes à
l'assemblée aujourd'hui si les français
avaient préféré voter pour la france un
soumises ou pour les républicains plutôt
que pour le rassemblement national il
l'aurait fait on aurait pas aujourd'hui
c'est l'échec personnel emmanuel macron
également ce soir je repars sur un échec
personnel c'est un échec collectif qui
s'applique évidemment la majorité
présentielle mais qui s'applique à
l'ensemble des forces politiques et moi
je suis inquiet ce soir quand j'entends
les déclarations des uns et des autres
au fond se projetait déjà pour les cinq
prochaines années monsieur pradier
disait qu'il avait le temps je crois que
c'était la formule que vous avez employé
moi je crois que le pays n'a pas le
temps et que face au défi du pouvoir
d'achat avec la crise ukrainienne et ses
retombées sur l'inflation face aux défis
de la transition écologique face à
l'urgence de renforcer la lutte contre
l'insécurité il va falloir qu'on trouve
ici et maintenant nous sommes à
aurélien pradié là c'est à l'ensemble
des parlementaires pour ça que je citais
également madame qui est qui est élu
avec la nièce l'ensemble des
parlementaires sont des élus la nation
avant d'être des représentants de leur
parti politique quel qu'il soit et il va
falloir dans les mois qui viennent que
l'on puisse trouver les voies et moyens
chacun de pouvoir contribuer à répondre
à ces urgences qui se posent aux
français on ne peut pas attendre cinq
ans et quand je vois certains croire
qu'ils sont encore en campagne voir déjà
en campagne pour 2027 ça m'inquiète
depuis cahors aurélien pradié a envie de
vous répondre que tu dit vous auriez mme
pradier à david amiel qui vous invite à
participer à un futur gouvernement en
tout cas à voter à voter les textes
souhaité par la majorité
écoutez je ne le connais pas ce monsieur
mais ce qu'il dit est très sympathique
pour vous dire je comprends rien de ce
qu'il a pu expliquer depuis quelques
minutes pardon d'être aussi brutale mais
parce que vraiment on est à mille lieues
de ce que nos concitoyens peuvent
peuvent attendre la situation politique
du moment elle est de la responsabilité
exclusive des manuels macron elles mêmes
il et à son cynisme politique qui a joué
avec les allumettes du front national
depuis des mois qui a joué avec les
allumettes de jean luc mélenchon depuis
des semaines qu'il a fait c'est emmanuel
macron pour tenter de sauver sa peau
politique est donc aujourd'hui c'est à
vous d'assumer cette responsabilité là
quand je dis que j'avais du temps que
nous avions du temps c'est pas seulement
pour les réformes nous avons du temps
pour rebâtir une démocratie dans notre
pays est aujourd'hui ce qui m'inquiète
profondément c'est que le laval ce qu'il
va être existé entre les extrêmes ne
servira pas notre démocratie et je suis
convaincu que nos concitoyens qui
sincèrement par désespoir par blessures
profondes dans leur quotidien ont voté
pour l'extrême droite ou l'extrême
gauche ne s'y retrouveront pas dans les
semaines et dans les mois qui viennent
laventure d'emmanuel macron je ne veux
pas la partager non pas parce que je
n'aime pas emmanuel macron c'est pas le
propos non pas parce que j'ai un réflexe
sectaire c'est pas le sujet mais parce
que son aventure politique c'est pas la
mienne sa vision de la société ce n'est
pas la mienne et je refuse d'avoir à
choisir entre les extrêmes et emmanuel
macron le projet de société d'emmanuel
macro est un projet profondément injuste
un projet que j'ai trouvé toujours
arrogant et méprisant à l'égard des
françaises et des français c'est ça qui
me pose un vrai problème mais au
réchauffement sera dira l'un donné moi
de vous coucher de savoir si son projet
si vous m'entendez et ce n'est pas le
mien aurélien pradié pendant cinq ans
vous avez voté quand même avec la
majorité un certain nombre de textes est
ce que cette opposition constructive là
elle n'est pas incompréhensible ce soit
par rapport aux propos que vous tenez
mais j'ai voté un somme de texte j y en
a aussi beaucoup que je n'ai pas voté et
je n'ai pas fait en tenant des comptes
numériques c'est pas parce que vous
votez plus de textes contre que vous
êtes meilleurs opposants que que lorsque
vous en voter tout ça n'a pas de sens et
puis il se trouve que depuis cinq ans à
l'assemblée nationale nous avons été
nombreux chez les républicains à faire
du vrai boulot est ce qu'il y vous
connaissez un seul texte de loi qui
était portée et qui était votée par la
france est soumise est-ce que vous en
connaissez un seul dont ils auraient été
à l'initiative pas un seul la loi sur
les violences conjugales qui est ce
qu'il apportait ni le gouvernement ni
les insoumis c'est nous qui l'avons
portée c'est moi qui les portait et donc
ceux qui depuis cinq ans concrètement au
delà des hurlements se sont battus pour
changer la vie des français c'est nous
je dis simplement que nous avons besoin
de temps pour rebâtir tous à rebâtir une
droite populaire qui parle d'écologie
qui parle de dignité qui parle de
salaires qui parle de toutes ces
questions qui aujourd'hui ont été jetés
en pâture dans le débat public c'est ça
que je dis et il faudra le reconstruire
il faudra un peu de temps pour le faire
mais c'est salutaire parce que un effet
nous avons des réformes à mener dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent mais
nous avons aussi une nouvelle échéance
démocratique dans quelques années et il
n'est pas question que la pièce tombe du
mauvais côté c'est à dire du côté des
extrêmes qui pour moi ne représente pas
les valeurs républicaines auxquelles je
suis attaché c'est cette bataille
tyrolien marie les grands durant cinq
ans merci d'avoir été avec nous à 6
depuis le département du lot vous qui
êtes réélu député l'air ce soir lors
labalette bonsoir merci de nous avoir
rejoints sur le plateau de france info
vous êtes vous aussi élu ce soir député
rassemblement national de la deuxième
circonscription du du var vous êtes une
des porte parole du rassemblement
national crédité donc ce soir aux
alentours de
85 90 même siège 90 sièges selon les
dernières estimations de l'ipsos oprah
steria
qu'allez-vous en faire de ces 90 sièges
une opposition constructive bien sûr
déjà j'ai une pensée émue quand même
pour tous les les adhérents les
militants les gens qui votent pour le
rassemblement national depuis si
longtemps sans que cela ne porte ses
fruits et là ce soir il ya quand même
une vague on voit là la fin du plafond
de verre on voit la fin du front
républicain parce que c'est quand même
un énorme score 1 dimanche dernier sur
les plateaux personne n'eut pu imaginer
que nous en soyons là ce soir donc on
sera évidemment la seule opposition
constructive vous savez quand nubes a
appelé à voter emmanuel macron contre
nous vous imaginez bien qu'on a du mal à
penser qu'ils vont être une opposition
constructive ils sont en fait deux faces
de la même pièce il sur la béquille l'un
de l'autre alors ça y est rude un peu en
disant qu'ils sont contre la retraite à
65 ans il n'empêche qu'au moment de
voter au second tour des élections
présidentielles
ils l'ont fait donc ils ont telli celui
qui voudrait maintenant nous faire
croire qu'ils vont en position basse
octiv ça veut dire que vous êtes prête
comme le rassemblement national est prêt
à voter des textes proposés par la
majorité mais vous savez que c'est
exactement ce que nous faisons déjà à la
j'en ai la municipalité ne croyez
surtout pas que nous opposons à
l'opposition qu'elle avait montrées
pendant cinq ans à l'assemblée nationale
mais vous savez bien que si vous savez
bien qu'il ya des amendements qui
avaient été votées après des vous des
lois entière ou n'avaient pas été votés
mais typiquement à la région je pense
qu'on doit voter 80% des textes de la
majorité donc le dogmatisme n'est pas de
notre côté madame et je peux vous
assurer que nous sommes rennes la région
la majorité de droite non mais et mais
elle n'est pas de ma famille politique
et ce qui n'empêche évidemment enfin il
ne l'est plus vous savez à la région
paca par exemple savait bien qu'elle ait
passé à l'ère où m et ça nous empêche
pas quand une décision est délibération
va pour l'intérêt des français
évidemment que nous la voulons nous ne
sommes pas dogmatiques nous aimerions
que nos ennemis politiques en face en
fassent autant aurélie trouvé je ne sais
pas si vous faites partie des ennemis
politiques de l'or la valette mais quand
elle dit lors la balle est une bête vous
êtes une béquille d'emmanuel bacrot je
rassure tout le monde nous sommes la
première force d'opposition aujourd'hui
à la macro ni à la droite qui
effectivement sans doute peut-être qui
aura une alliance entre l air et l rmc
clarifiera les choses c'est à dire que
eh bien il s'agit de la droite
effectivement il ya effectivement ce
deuxième pole à l'extrême droite je
dirais l'extrême droite l'extrême
libéralisme voilà deux poles et nous
nous voulons expliquer au volant sont
extrêmement nous voulons je vais y
arriver et nous voulons effectivement
être cette force alternative qui
répondent aux immenses défis écologiques
sociaux démocratiques nous sommes les
seuls à nous battre par exemple pour la
hausse du smic à 1500 euros net nous
sommes les seuls à nous battre sur la
retraite à 60 ans avec 40 annuités et
sans la d'exa effet sommes nous seuls
emmanuel bach nous on n'a jamais appelé
à une macro mais par contre nous avons
dit pas une seule voie pour le
rassemblement national et nous nous
avons été très clairs il est vrai que
vous avez profité effectivement du fait
que dans 50 circonscriptions il ya eu un
flou sur la position des candidats en
marche par rapport à vous et ça vous
effectivement que vous revendiquez la
place de premier opposant dia sur europe
1 il suffit de regarder les chiffres
nous avons près de 200 députés dans la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale nous sommes bien cédé seulement
83 pour l'apprendre contre 14 is more je
laisse à près de 200 députés je le
rappelle nous avons et nous sommes allés
à ces élections sous l'étiquette du ps
et d'ailleurs ça a été accepté par voilà
par par le tribunal nous savons le
slogan est l'étiquette nubes nous
n'avons 650 mesure en commun nous avons
un parlement que je préside de la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale nous sommes une force unie qui
va permettre d'être la première force
d'opposition c'est ça les résultats ce
soit avec un renouvellement et nous
sommes les seuls à pouvoir nous en
prévaloir un renouvellement du personnel
politique massif avec des gens venus de
toute la société jusqu'à et je le salue
je viens d'apprendre l'élection de
rachel kéké qui a mené une lutte contre
une multinationale 22 mois de grève en
temps on va parler de sa victoire donc
dans quelques instants lors la valette
parce que au rassemblement national il y
a aussi des nouveaux arrivés en
politique et puis un tout petit mot
quand vous dites que nous nous avons
bénéficié d'un flou mais est-ce que vous
pouvez vous mettre dans la tête que
quand le peuple vote le peuple gagnent
et qu'il ya des gens qui adhèrent à
notre bouche pas à notre projet combien
marine le pen at-elle fait des lecteurs
au deuxième tour de la présidentielle
treize millions 3 donc excusez moi mais
de parler comme ça de ces gens là c'est
méprisant cet arrogant excusez moi mais
là c'est le peuple qui rentre à
l'assemblée nationale où marine le pen
va prendre évidemment la tête de ce
groupe et nous allons pouvoir former
évidemment un groupe souverainiste
populaire république a dit daniel quand
vous voyez ces deux oppositions autour
de vous est ce que vous vous dites
l'assemblée sera très difficile à
diriger et le parti va devenir
ingouvernable
donc je crois que la france est
confrontée à une épreuve de vérité qui
faisait jusque là dans d'autres pays
européens où on est habitué à avoir au
sein des assemblées une diversité de
forces politiques qui peuvent trouver
des compromis sur des sur des mesures
pour faire avancer le pays se trouve que
dans le système de la vème république
jusque là ça ne fonctionnait pas et donc
nous sommes confrontés à cette nécessité
de forger une nouvelle culture et je
crois que quel que soit les camps quels
que soient les les parlementaires ils
sont tout sauf en confronté à ce choix
entre oeuvres et pour leur parti ou vrai
pour leur pays et moi ce qui me frappe
eu beaucoup dans les retours de ce soir
c'est qu'on voit des personnes qui
représentent des forces qui sont quand
même minoritaire avec la majorité
présidentielle
nous sommes en tête de l'ensemble des
forces politiques n'ont pas la majorité
absolue et j'en conviens
non nous sommes en tête et je vois des
percées 50 mais je vois au revoir je
vois beauté vauré flandre est difficile
à jean voit beaucoup qui font encore
moins de voix encore moins de
parlementaires qui 1 se félicitent de
leur victoire qui n'a pas lieu ce soir
de se projette dans les combats futurs
en 2027 11 ans complètement l'impasse
sur la nécessité que la france aura
affronté dans les cinq prochaines années
et c'est ça qui m'inquiète effectivement
ce soir en tous les cas je ne sais pas
si tout le monde a gagné mais en tout
cas la situation est inédite pour la
première ministre elisabeth bornes qui a
été réélu élue elle dans le calvados
mais qui qualifie en tirant les
enseignements de ce second tour de la
situation inédite ce soit en écoute
elisabeth dans jamais l'assemblée
nationale n'a connu une telle
configuration sous la vème république
cette situation constitue un risque pour
notre pays au vu des défis que nous
avons à affronter
tant sur le plan national qu'à l'échelle
internationale
mais ce vote nous devons le respecter et
en tirer les conséquences
et nous prenons à présent la direction
du finistère à châteaulin où se trouve
notre envoyé spécial kathia gilder c'est
le fief de richard ferrand qui rate sa
réélection ce soir c'est le président de
l'assemblée nationale
oui effectivement la candidate de
l'union de la gauche a créé la surprise
ici en l'emportant avec 52 85 % des voix
la victoire s'est jouée 1 800 voix
d'écart richard ferrand a pris acte de
sa défaite peu après 20h et féliciter sa
concurrente dans une déclaration
lapidaire ce soir c'est un symbole qui
est tombé richard ferrand a été l'un des
tout premiers parlementaires à avoir
rejoint emmanuel macron dès 2016 et bien
c'est une socialiste qui l'a battu
melanie thomas 37 ans elle a milité à
ses côtés quand ils étaient ensemble au
parti socialiste aujourd'hui c'est donc
elle qui a réussi à remobiliser les
électeurs de gauche ceux là même qui
avaient voté richard ferrand en 2012
c'est donc comme un retour aux sources
ici sur cette terre du centre finistère
qui a été à gauche pendant près de 35
ans voilà le merci beaucoup le président
de l'assemblée nationale
battue battu également la ministre de la
transition écologique band et arrive
vous avez suivi ce scrutin dans cette
circonscription de l'essonne c'est une
figure du gouvernement qui est battu ce
soir
exactement louis on la savait en danger
c'est désormais confirmé un coup dur
pour amélie de montchalin la ministre de
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires qui a été battu
dans cette sixième circonscription de
l'essonne son concurrent et est candidat
de l'union de la gauche jérôme guedj a
revendiqué et clamer sa victoire bien
avant que les résultats définitifs tombe
il devance donc amélie de montchalin
avec 53 36 % ont des voix contre
46,62 4 l'écart est beaucoup plus gros
seins qu'au premier tour elle était
l'une des trois membres du gouvernement
en ballottage défavorable numéro 5 du
protocole gouvernementale a pris la
parole il y à quelques minutes après
nous avoir annoncé une prise de parole
imminente il vient d il ya déjà un peu
plus d'une heure elle a annoncé prendre
acte de cette victoire de son adversaire
jérôme guedj amélie de montchalin
ministre de la transition écologique
depuis un mois devra donc démissionner
et quitter le gouvernement c'est la
règle impitoyable instauré par l'elysée
en 2007 par nicolas sarkozy un bien
triste cadeau d'anniversaire louis car
la ministre de la transition écologique
fête aujourd'hui ses 37 ans voilà quinze
ministres qui étaient présents au second
tour certains sont élus florent boutet
d'autres et bien sont battus oui moi
mais bien d'en parler amélie de
montchanin c'est la troisième membre du
gouvernement qui ce soir est battu et
qui va donc démissionner elle acquit et
rejoint ici dans cette case brigitte
bourguignon la ministre de la santé qui
échoue dans sa circonscription du nord
face à un candidat et rennes et justine
bénin la secrétaire d'état à la mer qui
elle a perdu en guadeloupe sinon les
autres membres du gouvernement qui sont
dans des circonscriptions urbaines dans
les résultats nous parviennent et bien
olivier vers ont été lus en isère il ya
une banque privée elle est élue avec
plus de 60% un dea voit dans les
yvelines clément bonnet c'était une des
attentes et bien dans sa circonscription
parisienne où c'était très serré il
était lui tout comme stanislas guérini
dans le nord de paris aucun souci pour
olivier grégoire dans le 15e
arrondissement on rappelle pour mémoire
qu'elisabeth bornes et les autres
membres du gouvernement avaient déjà été
élus ou réélus on avait obtenu leurs
résultats restent les autres figures de
la république en marché de la majorité
christophe castaner poids lourd un
puisqu'il est le président sortant de
l'assemblée de du groupe lrm à
l'assemblée nationale il est battu ce
soir dans sa circonscription des alpes
de haute provence avec un peu moins de
49 % des suffrages autre président d'un
groupe de la majorité patrick mignola
président du groupe modem sortant battu
aussi lui aussi ce soir dans sa
circonscription de savoie avec 49 2%
face à son concurrent de la nuque et
puis il y à aussi ce résultat façade de
cet ancien ministre des sports roxana
maracineanu qui ce soir échoue face à
rachel kick et dans le val de marne elle
a seulement 49 7% des voix et c'est donc
sa concurrente de la nuque qui
l'emportent sur cette circonscription
merci florent bouter david amiel
remaniement s'impose quand on voit ces
chiffres et ces résultats puisque trois
ministres sont battus est-ce que ce
remaniement il doit être un petit peu
plus large que prévu un petit peu plus
large que celui là tout simplement parce
qu'il faut tenir compte des résultats et
de la sévère défaite que vous prenez ce
soir je n'ai pas d'information
particulière a donné là dessus la
première ministre le président de la
république auront auront cette charge
dans l'est dans les jours qui viennent -
avant je voudrais avoir une pensée quand
même pour ceux qui ont été abattus je
pense à richard ferrand à christophe
castaner une pensée évidemment amicales
sont pour moi des des compagnons de
lutte mais au delà de ça ce sont des
personnes qui n'ont comme il y en a dans
de très nombreux partis ont consacré
leur vie à se battre pour l'intérêt
général pour ce qu'il croit juste pour
la france qui se confronte au suffrage
universel à les convaincre les électeurs
je crois que quelles que soient nos
sensibilités politiques ça mérite un
profond respect et donc avec beaucoup
d'émotion je verrai si cette pensée pour
elisabeth borne peut rester à son poste
on va avoir besoin d'une première
ministre très politique avec une
assemblée qui sera très politique elle
aussi avec beaucoup de pouvoir est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est la personne de
la situation a déjà elisabeth bord n'a
eu le courage aussi de se présenter
devant le suffrage universel pour la
première fois dans ce contexte difficile
elle a été élue dans le calvados et ça
aussi je crois que c'est une une
démarche très importante les ministres
n'y sont pas obligées d'ailleurs
maintenant toute l'histoire de la vème
république des ministres sous françois
mitterrand sous le général de gaulle ou
sous jacques chirac qui ont fait le
choix de ne pas se présenter je crois
que le choix qui a été fait par
elisabeth borrel et extrêmement
courageux et très loin d'ailleurs des
caricatures qu'on peut faire belle il
est 23h30 sur france info merci d'être
avec nous on va retourner en direct de
lcp au coeur de l'assemblée nationale
avec clément perreault qui m'ont vous
allez nous nous rappeler la projection
les estimations de cette nouvelle
assemblée nationale
oui tout à fait alors je vous propose de
prendre un instant maintenant pour nous
projeter dans le nouveau visage que
devrait avoir les mystiques cette
projection qui va paraître devant moi
elle est basée sur les toutes dernières
estimations ipsos estimation actualisée
regarder le bloc le plus important et
c'est celui dans semble donc les députés
qui soutiennent le gouvernement il
aurait 234 sièges on est très loin de la
majorité absolue qui était à 289 sièges
je vous rappelle que sous la mandature
précédente
la majorité présidentielle conseil 3 136
sièges c'est donc une baisse
considérable ensuite le bloc le plus
important vous le voyez à gauche de
l'écran il est en rouge c'est la nuque
la gauche 141 députés c'est une belle
progression jusqu'ici il y avait 60
députés de gauche dans l'hémicycle à
droite elle vous la voyez en bleu elle
compterait 75 députés elle en avait 119
jusque là c'est une baisse mais ce n'est
pas non plus une catastrophe la droite
ce soir limite les dégâts enfin entrer
en force de très nombreux députés du
rassemblement national regarder il
serait 90 dans l'hémicycle sous la
dernière mandature ils n'étaient que
huit maintenant ce que je vous propose
c'est de rentrer dans le détail des deux
principaux blocs d'abord le bloc
présidentiel celui que vous voyez en
violet 234 députés il y en aurait 160 2
pour la république en marche des manuels
macro 45 pour le modem de françois
bayrou et enfin 27 pour horizon le
nouveau parti d'edouard philippe
maintenant rentrons dans les détails du
bloc de gauche en rouge la nuque là
c'est la france a soumises de jean luc
mélenchon qui serait le plus gros groupe
parlementaire avec 79 députés viendrait
ensuite europe ecologie les verts et le
parti socialiste 25 députés chacun et
enfin le parti communiste contre lui 12
sièges à l'assemblée nationale merci
clément et à propos de la nuque jean luc
mélenchon qui a porté cette nouvelle
union de la gauche pour ces législatives
ne sera pas premier ministre les
français ne l'ont pas élu à matignon
comme il le souhaitait mais pour le
leader de la france a soumis des biens
c'est c'est la défaite c'est surtout la
déroute du camp présidentiel d'emmanuel
macro les coûts c'est une situation
totalement inattendu absolument inouïe
la déroute du parti présidentiel est
totale et ont-ils majorité
c'est l'échec
plus graves
l'échec moral
de ces genres qui donnait des leçons à
tout le monde sans arrêt et qui se
prétendait le barrage à l'extrême droite
aurélie trouvé on entend jean luc
mélenchon qui parle de déroute pour le
camp présidentiel
vous allez vous n'avez pas non plus vous
de majorité vous passez à côté de cette
cohabitation que vous souhaitiez est-ce
que vous allez être une force
d'opposition ou une force d'obstruction
dans la nouvelle assemblée nationale
d'opposition la première forgent les
dits d'opposition et puis je le dis on
passe aussi une force de résistance à
une force d'alternative et de
propositions contrairement au
rassemblement national qui nous annoncer
ça il ya quelques semaines nous n'avons
pas renoncé à gouverner donc nous allons
continuer à travailler pour être en
mesure bientôt aux prochaines occasions
de pouvoir gouverner avec un gouvernent
avec un gouvernement qui représentera la
diversité de la nuque s est aujourd'hui
ce que quand il faudra patienter un peu
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'élection fops
disent oui mais nous avons aussi une
situation inédite et effectivement elle
est aussi lié je dirais à la déroute
mais aussi à au chaos dans lequel nous
plonge la macro ni je rappelle quand
même quelques chiffres qui suit de
profession j'étais enseignante
chercheuse en économie jusqu'à
maintenant il faut quand même voir où ça
nous a amené ça nous amène à une baisse
du pouvoir d'achat historique de 2% sur
le premier trimestre à une récession
économique baisse du produit intérieur
brut à une explosion à la fois du
déficit public et de la dette publique
avec encore un chiffre de plus de 6
millions de chômeurs inscrits à pôle
emploi avec un état qui a été poursuivi
pour deux fois qui a été accusé deux
fois dynaction climatique voilà le bilan
des manuels macron ce qui nous plonge
aujourd'hui effectivement dans cette
situation et ce qui nous impose nous une
énorme responsabilité pour répondre aux
défis sans tomber dans la stigmatisation
des populations dans la division des
populations que porte aujourd'hui le
rassemblement national sans proposer
aujourd'hui de véritables alternatives
pour le bien être est ce que vous
pourriez vous alliez peut-être avec le
rassemblement national je pense à la
réforme des retraites vous êtes tous les
deux opposés à cette réforme à 65 ans
est-ce que vous qui voulez vous mais
vous pourriez trouver aussi chercher des
alliances dans les mines y aura pas
d'alliance avec le rassemblement
national bien évidemment nous combattons
ces idées moi je viens de mouvements
sociaux ça fait vingt ans j'ai dirigé
pendant 15 ans le mouvement attac j'ai
combattu le rassemblement national et
les idées racistes qu'ils véhiculent
évidemment nous ne serons pas à lyon
rassemblement national nous ferons tout
pour faire avancer nos idées à savoir
par exemple ça et que plus de huit
français sur dix sont pour le smic à
1500 euros plus de huit français sur dix
veulent la retraite à 60 ans plus de
huit français sur dix veulent le blocage
des prix des produits de première
nécessité nous sommes les seuls à le
porter alors oui nous allons faire en
sorte de faire avancer toutes ces idées
qui sont majoritaires dans la société
nous ont pas donné majorité pour ça
alors nous snober sont majoritaires dans
la société nous avons un groupe de près
de 200 députés nous sommes là mais les
mobilise pas
d'opposition nous avons multiplié par
près de trois notre groupe de députés
donc nous sommes en mesure aujourd'hui
tu avancer ses propositions dans le ca
au sein de l'assemblée nationale 141
députés selon les estimation d'ipsos
pour la nuque florent but est de nouveau
député qui est bien vont représenter la
gauche cette alliance de la gauche à
l'assemblée nationale oui avec les
résultats qui nous parviennent dans les
circonscriptions très urbaine où les
bureaux de vote fermaient plus tard à
20h regarder sans surprise manuel
bompard qui s'est substitué à jean luc
mélenchon a marseille la 4e
circonscription des bouches du rhône un
énorme score pour lui près de 74% des
suffrages il est bien évidemment élus et
puis toujours du côté de la nuque
françois ruffin élus à amiens avec plus
de 60 61% des suffrages très exactement
c'est la première circonscription de la
somme on continue avec julien bayou qui
dans le centre de paris l'emportent
élection pour la première fois pour
celui qui dirige le parti élevé europe
ecologie les verts avec +2 58% des
suffrages il fait son entrée tout comme
du côté des verts sandrine rousseau qui
dans le xiiie arrondissement gagne avec
+2 58% des suffrages elle était en
ballottage favorable à l'issue
premier tour et puis dans le val de
marne on notera que matt hill panneaux l
emporte aussi à largement plus de 67%
des des suffrages elle est pressenti
pour prendre la tête du groupe la france
est soumise à l'assemblée nationale on
terminera avec la seine-saint-denis et
raquel garrido qui gagne un duel qui
était sur le papier très serrée
puisqu'elle l'emportent face à jean
christophe lagarde le président sortant
du groupe u10 à l'assemblée nationale
qui perdent donc son siège tant que nous
sommes en seine-saint-denis regarder
avec la carte on se rend compte et bien
que la nuque et bien elle fait un carton
plein dans le département de la
seine-saint-denis dans le 9-3 comme on
dit avec 12 victoires sur les douze
circonscriptions plus globalement on
voit que le mouvement le insufflé par
jean luc mélenchon et bien cartonne dans
les centres villes et puis dans le sud
du pays où en moyenne lors du premier
tour de la présidentielle jean-luc
mélenchon avait obtenu de meilleurs
résultats que dans le reste du pays
merci florent goûté on voit que la nuque
et tente est un peu par tout en
seine-saint-denis dans le val-de-marne
également victoire de la nuque marque au
pommier puisque l'ancien ministre des
sports oksana maracineanu et battu ce
soir
oui effectivement brigitte rachel tu es
gay s'est imposé dans cette septième
circonscription du val de marne la
candidate de la nuque par o2i 51% des
suffrages vous entendez peut-être
ailleurs la fête derrière moi sa
concurrente roxana maracineanu l'ancien
ministre des sports elle a obtenu 48 %
des voix rachel kéké devient donc la
première femme de chambre à entrer à
l'assemblée nationale son profil est
atypique femme franco ivoiriennes de 48
ans mère de cinq enfants elle s'est fait
connaître en 2019 car ces deux dernières
années elle a mené une grève à l'hôtel
ibis batignolles à paris contre le
groupe hôtelier accor elle a obtenu une
amélioration des conditions de travail
et des salaires pour les femmes de
chambre qui travaillait dans cet
établissement est ici il ya un peu plus
d'une heure elle a parlé d'une victoire
historique
elle a dit qu'elle serait une députée
exemplaires elle a parlé aussi de ces
travailleurs invisibles dans la société
et puis elle a annoncé aussi sa victoire
sur twitter avec cette phrase
l'assemblée nationale va trembler
merci marco la nuque qui fait carton
plein en seine saint denis à nous le
rappeler en bouteille tout à l'heure
aurélie trouvé la victoire de rachel
ticket elle est hautement symbolique
pour vous oui elle est symbolique mais
s'il n'y a pas qu'elle en fait il ya un
gros renouvellement du personnel entre
guillemets politique mais dont je fais
pas vous faites parti dont je fais
partie j'ai jamais été lue je suis
encore prof de fac pour tout vous dire
enfin la grotte paris jusqu'à jusqu'à
demain et puis et puis j'ai surtout des
militants que dont je fais partie des
responsables de mouvements sociaux aussi
dont elle fait partie aussi est
effectivement aussi des gens qui
viennent de dives de plein de métiers
différents dans cette société et c'est
ça que nous avons réussi en premier lieu
dans cette nouvelle union populaire les
gens ou envie aussi d'avoir des députés
qui leur ressemble et puis qui mènent
des luttes qui qui sont pour beaucoup
des militants bénévoles qui arrive
aujourd'hui qu'ils n'ont jamais été élu
et je crois que ça c'est très important
aussi pour nous pour renouveler c'est
pour pour insuffler cet espoir de
changement dans la politique et demain
vous serez présidente de la commission
des finances à l'assemblée nationale je
crois pas que ce soit à l'ordre du jour
pour l'instant nous avons des
discussions c'est important aussi des
discussions des décisions collectives
qui seront prises non je ne suis pas
candidate à cela mais voilà un poste
pour la nuque ça serait donc selon vous
qu'est ce que le rassemblement national
réclame aussi va postuler nous allons
demander évidemment la présidence de la
commission des finances je suis
candidate entre guillemets à ce que nous
ayons évidemment puisque nous sommes la
première force d'opposition la
présidence de la commission des finances
dans la lettre que le rn réclament aussi
souhaitent cette présidence qui est
stratégique en fait ce que j'aime bien
dans la nuit ps c'est qu'ils sont les
films souvenez-vous et jean luc
mélenchon devait être premier ministre
et ils ont répété à n'en plus finir que
ce serait le cas et je suis confuse ça
ne sera pas le cas jean luc mélenchon ne
sera jamais premier ministre
effectivement vous n'êtes pas la
première force d'opposition encore une
fois il me semble que c'est marine le
pen qui était au second tour de cette
élection présidentielle et malgré un
scrutin qui d'habitude est très
compliqué pour nous nous arrivons à 89
députés donc les seuls qui vont porter
une opposition tout à fait concret tout
à fait offensive à la politique daniel
mccraw qu'elle soit sociale fiscale ou
en matière d'immigration c'est
évidemment le rassemblement national et
ça va être l'occasion vous savez bien de
faire un grand groupe de tous les
patriotes de tous les souverainistes qui
veulent surtout l'échiquier politique
c'est ça ou non représente j'allais dire
une alternative très intéressante et qui
sera un premier groupe est justement je
dis à tout le monde de nous rejoindre
adhérez à notre mouvement venait
rejoindre ce mouvement qui fait une
percée phénoménale dans l'assemblée
nationale ce soir et on sera la seule
force d'opposition et vous aurez beau le
répéter à l'envi ça n'est pas vous j'en
suis la vie daniel quand vous voyez ces
résultats à côté de vous la soie pour la
nuque que ce soit pour le rassemblement
national a l'impression qu'il ya
peut-être une envie de gauche dans le
pays que vous avez peut-être gouverne
est trop à droite et en même temps si
vous êtes obligés d'aller chercher une
coalition avec les républicains c'est la
quadrature du cercle pour vous non
jugeant qu'il faut se garder de ses
interprétations trompettiste d'abord je
concept l'élection présidentielle on
s'est retrouvé face à l'extrême droite
qui était largement en tête devant
l'extrême jean luc mélenchon
nationale que l'extrême droite et pour
la violence qui n'est absolument pas le
cas il va falloir à partir de ce soir
typiquement une nouvelle ère et n'est
donc en fait ce n'est pas l'extrême
droite arrêtez d'insulter les gens qui
votent pour nous je vous assure c'est
fatigant et ça n'amène rien au débat
républicain et je n'insulte aucune des
personnes qu'ils vêtements jeunes
ensuite aucune des personnes cibles pour
vous mais vous êtes héritier d'une
famille d'un héritage celui qui seront
enfin
changer de nom vous savez ça vous a pas
échappé n'en a même pas irritable et des
fondations mais évidemment que si enfin
vous avez bien vu qu'il y avait un
changement de nom et que en aucun cas
nous sommes d'extrême droite donc c'est
fatigant et surtout c'est insultant vous
savez quand je reviens attendait là je
reviens sur le s qui n'ont pas de député
du tout donc excusez moi mais on va
avoir du mal à faire une alliance avec
des gens qui ne sont pas là pour tout
vous dire la députée est pas du tout là
la candidate d'eric zemmour n'a pas
appelé à voter pour moi vous voyez comme
quoi ce que vous imaginez ce que vos
fantasmes et finalement j'en arrive à
gagner sans suite arrive à gagner
le rn n'est pas d'extrême droite mais
bien sûr que l'extrême gauche écoutez si
elle se revendique d'être très moche
c'est son problème moi je peux vous dire
avec un je la vois je redescends enfin
évidemment quand on est sur le terrain
quand on fait les marchés ça apporte les
gens les gens sont blessés que vous
disiez qu'il soit d'extrême droite alors
vous vous en fichez parce que c'est
votre projet ça permet de stigmatiser
mais sachez que vous vous heurtez les
gens vous les sortez pas du tout avec
vos mesures avec les mesures que vous
portez de division stigmatisation des
bonobos 20 56 europa martyriser les gens
quoi bah je n'ai pas l'impression de
préférer son peuple oui ça n'a rien on
va écouter marine le pen qui a été
facilement réélu ce soir dallas dans la
11e circonscription du pas de calais la
présidente du fn qui se réjouit et
surtout des très bons résultats de son
parti qui atteint donc des records à
l'assemblée
le peuple s'est exprimé il a décidé
d'envoyer un très puissant groupe
parlementaire de députés rassemblement
national à l'assemblée
[Applaudissements]
qui maintient ainsi un peu plus
nationale ce groupe sera de très loin le
plus nombreux de l'histoire de notre
famille politique et nous partons en
gironde à bordeaux se trouve marion
becker marion vous êtes dans la
circonscription d'edwige diaz le
rassemblement national qui gagne un
siège ce soir là bas
même de siège
du rassemblement national les deux
députés élus nouveaux élus sont ici est
derrière moi et jazz pour la 11e
circonscription de gironde et
qui selon grégoire de furnaces pour la
5e circonscription
toujours de gironde le rassemblement
national qui confirme ici ça poussait
avec cinq députés en aquitaine 2 en
gironde est gigas diaz qui a gagné face
à la députée de la majorité sortante
véronique amour heures elle a appris sa
victoire ici entouré par des militants
visiblement très émue elle a ensuite été
félicité par marine le pen une victoire
individuelle mais aussi collective car
ils ont appris au fur et à mesure on
félicité au fur et à mesure les
différents députés nouveaux élus du
rassemblement national quand ils les ont
découverts durant cette soirée
électorale
merci marion un renouvellement des
visages à l'assemblée nationale on en
parlait avec la nuque on en parle donc
florent goûter avec le rassemblement
national ce soir va avoir de très
nombreux au lieutenant à ses côtés sur
les bancs de l'assemblée nationale
regarder ce soir laurent jacot bd en est
un exemple en moselle ils l'emportent
avec plus de 52% des suffrages lui qui
est le chef de file du rassemblement
national dans la région un grand test et
puis réélection de bruno bilde halle
était attendu à 20 plus de 56% dans le
pas de calais une circonscription
voisine de celle de marine le pen à
hénin beaumont on enchaîne toujours dans
les hauts de france avec sans surprise
là encore sébastien chenu dans le
département du nord qui gagne avec +2
57% face à son opposant du parti
communiste et puis encore une figure du
rassemblement national qui fait son
entrée au palais à bourbon à savoir un
julien odoul qui lui est le chef de file
du rm dans la région un bourgogne
franche comté regarder il frôle les 50
6% pour son élection face à sa
challenger du un modem on continue
encore avec philippe ballard ancien
journaliste télé qui s'étaient présentés
lors des élections en ile de france la
dernière fois et bien regardez il frôle
les 50 6% il est bien sûr élus dans
l'oise face à sa concurrente puis parti
horizon d'edouard philippe tout un tas
de figure qui rejoignent regarder la
carte est bien un des candidats et
rennes qui truste dans certains
départements l'intégralité des des
sièges regarder la haute marne par
exemple c'est le département historique
du général de gaulle ou encore dans la
haute-saône où tous les sièges sont
pourvus au rassemblement national c'est
le cas aussi dans le sud du pays dans
l'aude ou encore vous le voyez ici dans
le département des pyrénées-orientales
on rappelle que la mairie de perpignan
est dirigée déjà par le rassemblement
national regarder le var quasiment
toutes les circonscriptions sont de la
couleur du parti d'extrême droite sauf
celle du centre ville de toulon on
terminera c'est à peu près la même
situation vous le voyez dans l'eure avec
une seule circonscription qui échappe au
rassemblement national et qui échoue
dans l'escarcelle de la nuque merci
florent boutet lors la valette vous avez
beaucoup de nouveaux visages qui vont
arriver à l'assemblée nationale beaucoup
de personnes qui sont inexpérimentés qui
n'ont jamais été élu est-ce que vous
aussi vous êtes fier d'avoir des
amateurs on n'est pas des amateurs avant
d'être élue la première fois vous n'êtes
pas élu avant d'être maman la première
fois vous n'êtes pas maman c'est pareil
je pense qu'on va très vite apprendre
j'allais reprendre en marchant alors
évidemment et on en a déjà 7 et je pense
qu on est tout à fait la capacité
d'apprendre vous savez il ya des gens
tout à fait diplômés j'ai un bac +5 en
droit globalement je pense que quand les
gens parlent j'arrive à comprendre quel
combat vous allez vouloir mener à
l'assemblée nationale à un mauvais
combat le coup de l'amateurisme excusez
moi mais avant d'être élu une deuxième
fois en à d'abord été une première fois
le combat je voulais dit on va se battre
contre la retraite à 65 ans on va se
battre contre cette politique
d'immigration massive que nous subissons
qui nous va pas on va se battre contre
toutes les hausses de taxes tout les
signes exceptionnel qui ne sera pas très
constructive puisque vient
vous savez depuis depuis le mois de
septembre marine le pen oeuvre pour le
pouvoir d'achat des français le
typiquement quand elle demande à ce
qu'on ait le ce panier avec 100 produits
de première nécessité avec une tva à
zéro c'est celle qui demande aussi de
baisser la tva de 20 à 5,5 surtout des
l'essence le fioul électricité tout ça
redonne évidement de l'air aux français
on va se battre pour la dea conjugale
isation de la hache de l'allocation
adulte handicapé typiquement c'est un
projet que je sais que je porterai avec
fierté à l'assemblée nationale on va
demander la demi part fiscale pour les
veuves vous savez on a beaucoup d'idées
et on ça sera effectivement une
formidable caisse de résonance pour le
programme de marine le pen david à miel
ou autour de 90 députés rassemblement
national autour de 240 sièges pour cette
nouvelle union de la gauche est ce que
vous pensez comme certains à droite et
au sein de la majorité présidentielle
que la france va être ingouvernable que
cette nouvelle assemblée nationale sera
très très difficile
à gérer pour votre majorité ce soit
difficile c'est l'évidence on en parlait
tout à l'heure c'est un changement
culturel et quand on voit les réactions
des différents représentants des partis
politiques on voit effectivement qu'il
ya une lourde tâche à accomplir mais
pour autant je pense que la france doit
être gouverné
madame citait le pouvoir d'achat en
baisse au premier au premier semestre
vous aviez tout à fait raison vous avez
simplement oublié de mentionner deux
choses la première c'est que le pouvoir
d'achat avait cru pendant les quatre
premières années du quinquennat et la
seconde c'est qu'ils baissent parce que
les contrecoups de l'inflation sont très
importants quoiqu'ils soient moins
importants en france qu'ailleurs grâce
aux mesures du gouvernement mais
justement dès le mois de juillet il
faudra faire une grande loi pour le
pouvoir d'achat pour nos retraités pour
les salariés pour les indépendants et
c'est là dessus aussi je crois qu'il
faut rassembler une majorité de
conviction cette fois sur le pouvoir
d'achat vous et moi mais revendiqués
aussi de pouvoir d'achat est ce que vous
vous pouvez voter contre non mais enfin
pouvoir d'abord vous dire que j'avais
fait pour et que vous ni vous ni
d'ailleurs le rassemblement national
vous n'êtes pour la hausse du smic
réellement ce smic réelle n'a pas été
augmenté et d'ailleurs depuis très très
longtemps
ben
oui le rassemblement national ni ans la
majorité
présidentielle ne sont pour le blocage
des prix de produits de première
nécessité alors que neuf français sur
dix sont pour pourquoi je vais vous dire
ce qu'il ya de commun entre vous deux
les
vérités pour l'eczéma nous qui avons
déjà eu des noyades commun c'est de vous
refusez de vous en prendre aux ultras
riches en fait c'est aux multinationales
à vos élèves et là c'est pas là mais moi
je ne vous ai pas on se débat qui a déjà
une après l'autre je ne vous ai pas
interrompu madame donc on voit déjà que
le respect c'est quand même un an mais
aussi et de renault-nissan pas bien donc
je repars en c'est mieux ni l'un ni
l'autre vous n'êtes pour la hausse du
smic à 1500 euros et pas du tout
d'ailleurs de hausse du smi assurer l ni
l'un ni l'autre pour le blocage des prix
des produits de première nécessité parce
que vous avez une chose en commun qui
est que vous ne voulez vous en prendre
ni aux plus riches ni aux
multinationales et c'est vrai que le
blocage des prix ça demande quelque
chose c'est de s'attaquer au profit par
exemple de total qui a fait des profits
record de 16 milliards d'euros encore
l'année dernière donc là seul moyen
c'est madame mais assez dans le village
des pruniers le bonhomme est un essai
est ce que vous aimez vous n'aidez pas
les riches finalement et ce ne sont pas
eux qui consomment le plus et qui
pourront ce pays à lancer des produits
est-ce qu'il ne vaut pas mieux alors je
vais vous écrire quelque chose c'est que
en maître mesure que j'avançais c'est
que les sens comme l'alimentation c'est
ça occupe une part dans le revenu
beaucoup plus importante pour les
classes précaires qui ont des bas
revenus donc si vous en prenez si vous
bloquez les prix de ses produits de
première nécessité c'était évidemment
les ceux qui ont les plus bas revenus
qui vont en profiter en premier lieu bar
comptez vous aller est par contre la
seule chose que ça fera c'est diminuer
les profits de ces multinationales qui
sont de plus en plus importants et
dividendes des actionnaires ne font
qu'augmenter quand les salaires sont
bloqués et quand le pouvoir d'achat
diminue et dernière chose ni d'un et
revenez vous n'êtes pour une garantie
d'autonomie à 1063 euros nets bien sa
vie de mes choix qu'il a fait mais je
crois qu'à une différence très maître d'
approche est à dire madame et pour moins
de profits moi je suis pour plus de
pouvoir d'achat quand on regarde les
cinq dernières années il ya une
augmentation de 170 euros par mois au
niveau du smic vous pouvez trouver que
c'est rien alors effectivement on l'a
pas fait en augmentant les salaires
partout on l'a fait en augmentant la
prime d'activité on l'a fait en baissant
les charges ce qui fait qu'on a réussi à
faire deux choses à la fois la première
c'était d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat
de toutes ces personnes au niveau du
smic la seconde c'est qu'on a pu dans le
même temps réduire le taux de chômage
est la première des causes de la
pauvreté c'était bien de chômage de
masse dans notre pays il est passé david
quand même que ça va être très difficile
de gouverner le pays comme le disait
louis il ya quelques instants est ce que
vous comptez utiliser larmes du 49-3
pour pouvoir faire passer un certain
nombre de réformes et pourquoi pas la
réforme des retraites mais avant même
d'utiliser les instruments
constitutionnel dont vous parlez moi je
veux quand même faire confiance dans les
nouveaux députés on est trois autour de
la table à n'avoir jamais été élu je
crois et je veux coup faire confiance a
aussi la capacité des parlementaires des
élus de la nation à pouvoir se
rassembler sur des sujets essentiels
comme le comme le pouvoir d'achat je
crois à nouveau que cette culture
politique du compromis du rassemblement
qui existe dans tant de pays européens
n'est pas impossible en france j'ai
cependant contrairement à ios nous on
veut augmenter tous les salaires de
l'entreprise vous voyez c'est pas petit
bras celle-ci ming et si cette
augmentation expérience par le smic si
vous avez fait des conneries ça et on
commence d'abord par du smic pour faire
augmenter tous les gemmes vote étant
professoral madame franchement vous
allez avoir du mal à vous j'ai
l'impression à vous en départir auront
la même arrogance en fait moi je vous ai
à laveyron put vous allez vous retrouver
sur les bancs de l'assemblée dans
quelques jours mesdames et monsieur si
votre victoire et confirmé david amiel à
paris l'an boutet d'autres des derniers
résultats oui ça vient de nous parvenir
une figure de la droite réélu à nice
eric ciotti qui l'emportent avec plus de
56% des suffrages sur la promenade des
anglais
et puis autre résultat qui vient juste
de nous parvenir aussi en ile de france
nicolas dupont aignan président du parti
debout la france ancien candidat à
l'élection présidentielle il sauve son
siège dans l'essonne avec 57% des
suffrages il est en ballotage compliqué
à paris ça y est on a le résultat c'est
danielle simonnet qui l'emportent sur la
circonscription du 20e arrondissement la
15e circonscription avec +2 58% des
suffrages elle faisait face à une
dissidente de gauche une députée
sortante et puis laurent verger figure
de la deûle à ma chronique qui gagne
dans les yvelines avec plus de 63% des
suffrages il faut dire que sa
circonscription était plutôt facile on
observe aussi qu'en ce qui concerne et
bien les alliées de la majorité le parti
horizon pierre-yves bournazel députés
sortants sur le nord de paris il est
battu ce soir par le journaliste aymeric
caron qui pour la nuque emporte cette
circonscription avec plus de 51% des
suffrages pour la majorité on note aussi
la défaite de laurent pietra skis ancien
secrétaire d'état en charge des
retraites dans le nord il est battu avec
une grosse défaite avec seulement 43 7%
des voix c'est une candidate dissidente
ps qui gagne sur cette circonscription
et puis un dernier résultat sur paris
vous le voyez c'est la défaite du maire
du xvième arrondissement dans l'ouest de
la capitale francis szpiner qui était
pourtant soutenu par nicolas sarkozy et
bien sûr cette circonscription très
bourgeoise c'est le candidat de la
république en marche qui l'emportent à
noter que nous avons quasiment tous les
résultats désormais vous voyez la carte
est quasiment totalement implémenter on
peut par exemple se rendre sur le site
internet vous pouvez le faire dans le
département ici par bonds dans le
département de l'essonne on y va ici
vous voyez la 6e circonscription si je
ne me trompe pas avec ce résultat 13
traitement pas la sixième la 5e
circonscription c'est celle ci cédric
villani le mathématicien bien connu qui
perd d'un cheveu ce soir il faisait
partie à la base de du bloc de
d'emmanuel macro mais au fur et à mesure
de son quinquennat il a changé il est
devenu membre de la nuque ils perdent ce
soir il n'est pas renouvelé à
l'assemblée nationale au titre des
curiosités vous pouvez explorer cette
carte regardez par exemple la
circonscription du loiret où s'étaient
présentés jean michel blanquer air et
bien ce soir aller remporté par un
candidat du rassemblement national et
puis à titre de curiosité là encore je
vous propose la deuxième circonscription
de la nièvre celle qui était celle de
françois mitterrand par le passé
regardez ça s'est joué à un cheveu elle
a failli tomber dans l'escarcelle du
rassemblement national ça s'est joué à
quelques dizaines de voix près flop
devaient tous les résultats ce soir sauf
un celui de david amiel parce que les
téléphones portables et tablettes
chauffe sur le plateau et vous avez
votre résultat oui je vous confirme que
je suis élu avec le 59% des voix voilà
trois nouveaux députés sur le plateau de
france info on va revoir brigitte est
bien la projection de notre partenaire
et sopra et steria pour voir bien avec
qui vous allez travailler avec contrôle
qui vous allez vous opposé durant les
cinq prochaines années et voilà donc le
visage de cette nouvelle assemblée
nationale avec ensemble qui obtient
234 sièges qui est très loin de la
majorité absolue de 289 sièges
derrière la nuque avec 141 sièges
ensuite le rassemblement national 90
sièges elle est rude et divers droite 75
sièges divers-droite divers gauche 22
sièges et autres 11 sièges et merci à
nous inviter de nous avoir accompagnés
tardivement sur les antennes de lcp de
france info aurélie trouvé merci alors
la valette merci à vous amis amiel trois
nouveaux députés qui nous accompagnait
c'est la fin de cette soirée spéciale du
second tour des législatives merci avons
surtout de nous avoir suivis d merci à
nos petits camarades dans ces pays
et merci brigitte merci louis
[Applaudissements]
m